the following is a presentation of the
saint louis chess club
fireworks were on the boards at the 2022
u.s juniors and senior championships in
saint louis top players from around the
country have brought their a-game and
are ready to compete for a national
title the juniors came out swinging with
nearly every game in both events ending
in a decisive result the seniors however
leaned on experience
taking a much more cautious approach to
the opening round all except igor
novocob who with steady play was able to
defeat vladimir kopian for sole lead in
the senior tournament things are just
getting started with tons of epic
matchups on the way round two of heart
racing championship chess coming up next
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back everybody to day two of the
us juniors and seniors chess
championships held at the st louis chess
club we start a day in front of the
outstanding st louis arts museum with
pieces spanning over 5 000 years of
culture and genres well today the
players are going to express their
artistic creativity over the chessboard
let's go to the studio and find out
who's going to come on top
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome to st louis
missouri the capital of chess in america
we bring you three national
championships the u.s junior u.s junior
girls and senior championships here from
the st louis chess club to bring you all
of the action i am grand master
alejandro ramirez with my good friend
grandmaster yasser sarawan alejandra as
always a pleasure to be with you
absolutely we had a great start to these
tournaments yesterday everything we
wanted from this event absolutely yes we
did indeed hello everyone and thank you
for joining us and sharing your day
yesterday andrew hung brought some
world-class preparation to his game it
was simply astounding sparkling chess
through the three events let's take a
look at the standings alejandra do the
honors and how about the girls to start
with let's take a look at this section
first we have three leaders talia
cervantes sophie mori suzuki and ellen
wang all won their initial bouts but
they are chased by two powerful
competitors with many powerful
competitors as jennifer you and alice
lee seats one and three faced each other
yesterday and split their point and in
the junior section we had many decisive
games a total of four wins all of them
with the white pieces puts christopher
you andrew hong justin wang and balaji
tagupati all at the top of the
leaderboard one out of two points and to
see a wonder liang our tournament
favorite losing its first round that's
interesting and then the legends in the
legends we had a quiet affair everybody
drew except for one game igor novikov
with the black pieces actually bested
raiding favorite vladimir akhopian who
came in with a scintillating prep seemed
to know exactly what he was doing but he
just went wrong in his opponents
night or absolutely and there we just
see the seniors getting ready as big
larry christensen at the board he swings
a mean club
and there is our reigning
uh champion gregory kaidanoff without
the beard
i'm not used to it i love the beard look
and of course our formats
our fourth read for all three events is
the ten player round robin 90 minutes
for the first 40 moves and 30 minutes
for the rest of the game so classical
chess of course that includes the 30
second increment that you get from move
one you get no draw offers before the
30th move uh we actually went pretty
late yesterday we sure did and one point
for a win half a point for a draw no
points for a lot of the traditional
scoring system and our schedule our 100.
simple enough one round a day except for
tuesday july 12th that'll be our rest
day and every single round including
round nine starts at 1 pm and i love
that they're gonna have playoffs and we
have christian in studio good to see you
my friend as we get ready for our
gladiators
it's great to see you guys and great to
be back in the studio casting the games
of the best juniors as well as best
legends that we have living on american
soil there are so many stories but one
story that i'm definitely having my eyes
on is that of young carissa ip only 18
years of age she could have played in
the u.s junior girls competition but
decided to take on the challenge and
fight the best juniors in the country in
preparation for her olympic debut later
on this month she's 18 years of age
hailing from boston massachusetts and
her invitational rating stands at a
whopping 25 14 she's also the 2021 u.s
women's champion but let's take a look
at carissa through the years
well she's had a lengthy career already
and she's only 18 years of age she beat
her first grand master at the tender age
of 10 years and the youngest american
woman to reach national master status at
11 years of age at 18 is the second
highest rated chess player among women
in the us after irena crush the
eight-time national champion
and she also won the 2021 u.s women's
chess championships here in saint louis
last year by beating the top-rated
eight-time national champion grand
master irena crush the only grand master
in that event needless to say
she has already an incredible career and
so many years ahead of herself one of
the big stories in this event but we
have so many others
thank you christian for that and
alejandro what can our viewers expect in
the pairings today let's start with the
ladies let's start with the latest
indeed because we have a huge matchup in
this one uh first seat of the event
former women's champion jennifer yu is
going to be playing against talia
cervantes and that means that we have a
battle between seat number one and seed
number two that's one way to kick off
the sermon jennifer you start to play
against both alice lee and talia
cervantes that's gonna be for me the
game of the round absolutely and seeing
alice lee at the bottom there against
ellen wang also very exciting games
between rochelle and um morris suzuki
and and the juniors oh
and here's little alice getting wandered
making sure no cheating
no cheating alice
and the juniors and in the junior
section we have also such good pairings
but in my opinion this one between
andrew hung who really impressed us
yesterday
scintillating prep he brought to the
game against brodsky just absolutely
amazing he's going to be playing with
white again against balagi tagupati so
both players won their games yesterday
this is a big one and for me i wonder li
yang there too can he bounce back
against christopher you as a wonder goes
down our number one seed in the first
round that will be a game to watch and
of course last but not least the legends
definitely not at least take a look at
these pairings we have for you a lot of
fun ones if vladimir had one yesterday i
think shaba akopian would have
definitely been the pick exactly but
with the results that we have i'm gonna
go with game of the day being nick the
fermion playing against igor navikov
igor repeating black right but man was
it successful for him yesterday
absolutely uh
and if he can get through the challenges
of these first two rounds igor is going
to be looking good
as a favorite uh and there you see
that's the match-up we are talking about
exactly uh
nick the permian the california cool
usually his chair would be a little bit
lean back at this moment you know as
he's getting ready for the duel but i
have to say yesterday this california
cool well did not help him because he
had i would say almost a winning
position and unfortunately he made a few
too calm uh moves in the process and
managed to lose the advantage
that's not the the cap that she got
right
i mean when she did the drawing of lots
no that's a difference oh i mean what's
up with that she's not representing the
juniors come on
and of course they're fighting they're
fighting very hard for lots of money
alejandro oh absolutely take a look at
the prize fund this is for the
junior girls this one was actually
doubled a fourth this year thank you st
louis chess club six thousand dollars
for first place second it receives four
thousand third three thousand dollars
not bad at all absolutely in the junior
section we have a total price one of
forty thousand dollars first price uh is
twelve thousand and a ten thousand
dollar scholarship to college we're
gonna talk about that later in the show
at some point yeah duane barber and uscf
thank you for stepping up for them yeah
eight thousand per second five thousand
four thirds so that's definitely a big
one and for the legends wow that is a
very handsome prize for 75 000
total 20 000 going for first place
yesterday what are you doing here now
yeah exactly uh patting the ira i would
say uh you take off the microphone coach
let me in there
let me throw some patties at these guys
as we're in
as we're enjoying the new and improved
st louis chess club that is going
through a massive expansion and there
you see
new uh looks for
the plane
absolutely we are expanding here in st
louis we have a lot of new projects
coming in a lot of new playing space as
well so we have some temporary solutions
let's call them for playing halls and
this one is one of them as we see one of
the key matchups in the girls section
alice lee versus alan wang now ellen won
yesterday so that puts a little
additional pressure on alice alice
having a double white to start because
alice made a draw with jennifer you and
a fortunate draw what a draw it was
indeed exactly now max there you just
saw
he's
kind of smarting like he
yeah i agree max was totally in control
yesterday he's a very strong player very
fast player as well and it seemed that
he had all the tools to finish his
opponent off but it fizzled out he sure
did
all right absolutely and i in my
estimation this is definitely the match
of the day in the senior section because
i have to say a very slow start for him
yesterday he was uh in big trouble
against uh larry christensen and max
lughi on the other hand he was
completely winning so there is
definitely some disappointment left from
yesterday at least for lugi because his
position just
so dominant from move 15
upwards and he wasn't able to convert
and this will be our marquee match-up
game as just for you
former u.s women's champion uh drew her
first game and she's up against talia
cervantes talia winning yesterday with
the black pieces gets the double black
welcome to
the national championship championships
yeah no easy pairings here for sure but
talia is a very experienced player
they've actually played each other
before not just in u.s junior girls
championship but also in the us women's
right as both players have not only
qualified but jennifer actually winning
the whole thing exactly no telia i mean
it's kind of they're they're early in
their careers so they kind of mix their
uh defenses around uh
what will uh talya shoot talia choose
against jennifer should we see a c for
will she go for a queen's game but
decline and accept it
she's an accepted type of player she's a
qga player uh she's
defended this against pretty much
everybody okay i believe that her best
win ever was in a qga against alex
lenderman so
whoa she took down one of the us
champions
u.s invitational champion competitors as
black as i believe he was black yeah
bang yeah and jennifer well she's been
playing d4 forever right but she's not a
strictly theoretical type of player
she's not the type of player that just
throws 20 moves of theory out of you
right she's gonna do anything to avoid
and that's what she just did i thought
that was a kg move knight f3 so if you
play knight f6
it does give
black pardon me white an opportunity
maybe go into a london kind of sidestep
whatever you had in mind as far as your
queen's gambit accepted is concerned we
see knight f6 on the board and as we
keep an eye on this game i'd love to
throw it over to christian well a lot of
uh theoretical battles please guys and
this one might not be one of them but
this one the battle between andrew hung
who essays some incredible preparation
yesterday world-class preparation i
think it was something along the lines
of 20-plus moves going into a completely
devastating position for his opponent i
think it was plus five or plus six at
the end of his preparation completely
winning now he's facing balaji dakbati
who by the way used to be a student of
mine as well when i was living in the
bay area and he's also very well
prepared nevertheless he is in his last
year of high school getting ready to
apply for all the colleges so maybe he
doesn't have as much time actually they
both are in their last year of high
school getting ready to go to college so
it definitely seems like andrew hong is
well prepared let's see if balaji is
also well prepared because right now
they're playing a super sharp line let's
take a look at what happened the
sicilian knight to f3 e6 d4 take take
knight f6 knight to c6 the con variation
knight takes c6 e5 knight to d5 we've
seen this
recently essay at the top actually quite
uh a number of times knight to e4 is one
of the lines the main line which was
played in the game knight takes d5 is
also an option but definitely you don't
want to strengthen the pawn structure in
the center for black so knight to e4 by
far the main line also getting ready to
kick this knight away with the move c4
this is a typical idea this knight on d5
it's too good let's kick it away at some
point f4 first we have to defend the
pawn on e5
queen to b6 bishop to b4 king king tuitu
we've seen this and we know there's some
developments in this line it very much
depends on who's going to be better
prepared and if i'm not mistaken we've
seen this during the candidates as well
i'm trying to remember what the game was
richie ritchie with the black pieces he
likes to play all these sharp uh ideas
let's have a look at this one we're
going to have to keep an eye on this
because
we know this is going to be a
theoretical battle whoever has the
better theory is going to win the battle
and is going to dictate the remaining uh
the remainder of the game
nice i i
i love these theoretical battles because
i really think that with the engines
right the players can look so deeply
into a position i just turn our
attention to the game between uh david
brodsky and karissa yipp for just a
moment
and we're seeing
at the highest levels
the ajoco piano the two knights
played by carissa against the joco piano
inviting knight g5 a move david declines
with the move d3
now again i mean there's so much
theoretical uh groundwork to cover but
h7h6 is really a very recent development
for for for me anyway that i'm
witnessing and i kind of like this move
somehow it really does fit and after
castle's d6 a2 a4 i noticed that carissa
went to do a thing and i was thinking to
myself well what's she thinking about
everybody just plays bishop e7 here
castles and i started thinking well if
you're going to play d3
and if you're going to play a4 means the
move d4
is not coming so fast and maybe she
should play
g7 g6
and just fianchetto her bishop and then
castle and i think this move a2 a4
caused her to rethink her prep and uh
she realized also that wait a minute
you're not putting any pressure on me
i'm going to play g6 what do you think
about this uh move by charissa
she taking advantage of the moment
alejandro i think it's considered to be
one of the two main lines of the
position g6 the other line that is
played pretty commonly is the move g5 a
more let's call aggressive approach
trying to determine the same thing that
d4 is not coming
especially not now because d4 g4 might
work oops
so it just puts
a little bit more pressure on black's
white center okay whereas the move g6 is
a little more sedate
but it leads to positions that are a
little more long-term and can you see
that white's tried everything rookie one
a5 knight c3 c3 h3 knight bd2 all of
them are moves okay and we'll just go
into one of these joko pianos that never
seems to have an actual end
just on
the never ending storm
there we go knight c3 on the board we'll
keep an eye on this one too uh over to
you christian uh any other uh
theoretical battles going on well i'm
still trying to understand what's
happening in this game and where the
theoretical battle is uh headed and i
was looking through the variations queen
to a5 is also a move but generally black
uh decides against this because after
knight takes f6 g takes f6 the pawn
structure and the ensuing king's
position on the king side after you
castle is going to be quite weakened you
don't want to see that and the queen on
a5 is not necessarily best place is
going to be hit by a3 followed by b4
later on in the game so queen to a5 is
the second best move the second most
played move in the position but queen to
d8 by far seems to be the best option
now of course if you do take on f6 i'm
going to recapture with the queen i'm
going to keep my pawn structure intact
and black is going to be perfectly fine
so knight xd6 makes a lot of sense right
we're going after the bishop there and
we're trying to take advantage of the
fact that you have so many dark square
weaknesses around the king also you
don't have the right to castle right now
because this queen is doing a tremendous
job at stopping you from doing that and
after bishop to b7 king to d1 was played
rook to d1 is one of the top moves king
to d1 as well trying to take this king
from his usual spot on f2 after h3 and
then g1 later on to c2 all the way there
now that the position on this side is
simplified there's no more queen hanging
around here so you want to put the king
on c2 quite an interesting idea c5 queen
takes c5 bishop to e4 and by the way
these players are blitzing out their
moves right now so they're definitely
still within their theoretical
preparation as well as their
understanding of the position bishop to
e4 taking away the c2 square from the
king also the d3 square from the bishop
so right now i'm just trying to stop you
from finishing your development because
i know if you get your king to c2 rook
to d1 make the connection between the
rooks well you have the two bishops also
i just sacrificed the pawn so that's not
a lot of compensation queen to a3 clear
threat i'm trying to go bishop to d3 if
you do take on g2 i'm going to follow it
up with rook to g1 i'm giving you back
my pawn nevertheless i'm gaining a lot
of initiative in return you still cannot
castle so queen three through queen to
a3 i really like this move they're still
following two games from 2021 and 2020
respectively and i'm looking at the
names and i do think that these are
correspondence games so
queen to a3 seems to have surprised
young dagpati balaji right now thinking
and trying to understand the position
trying to understand what the plans and
nuances are going to follow up in this
game
wow
thank you for that i'm just kind of
stunned by this queen a3 or the idea of
bishop engines wow it's just amazing i
wanted to turn out
yes our attention to the game of
rochelle wu
and um
sophia morris suzuki
because i understand this
this is what i did
when i was playing competitively i
really liked the same-ish
variation that's with
f2 f3
and a bishop e3 and
in my days we
we work really hard on this very very
specific position that's coming up
bishop e2 uh and in inside chess
magazine i actually think i even did a
uh
what we called it at the time a survey a
survey an opening
survey of this uh variation with the
early h4 now what i prescribed was
getting the knight off of
uh
f1 immediately and only after a7 a6
including the move a2 a4 shelter
rochelle took a different tax she played
a4 right away takes takes and this
was a real question i think uh in my
survey the idea was you would wait
you would wait for the knight on f1 to
first move to d2
before playing the move h3 why because
after the move h3 we would play g4
players would play knight h7 and you
give
gave white the choice of being able to
play knight g3 if you start right here
with the move knight h7 which i think
was the theoretical move
then after knight d2
h3 and let's say you no longer want to
go you know you no longer want to play
this move because bishop h6 could
upset you a little bit
you'd end up having to play g3 and then
after f5 it was considered that black
got a very decent game uh for out of the
opening so
it's nice to see one of the old lions
making a comeback you know today they
play the neo
what what have you been calling new
vienna yeah the neo vienna and
everything's uh
polished and new i like to see these old
variations h3
g3 nonetheless okay so one of the
reasons for g4
is because knight h7 and f5 is on
black's agenda
and sometimes when you get to play g4
maybe you can be the one who's using the
g-file especially with your knight
coming to g3 she did play g3 and i'm
expecting knight h7 knight d2 f5 as the
game's most likely continuation again
white has a very nice space in the
center and black is usually looking to
counter punch with the move f7 f5 we'll
keep our eye on this as we turn it back
to christian or did you have a game that
caught your eye alejandra i'm just going
around the horn a little bit uh we
haven't talked too much about the
seniors well speaking of the seniors and
old school lines all right catch up uh
with this game guys the game between
alexander shabolov and vladimir akopian
who had a very rough start yesterday he
got a completely winning position out of
the opening with the white pieces
against novikov and unfortunately he got
lost in the middle game unfortunately
for him also the 40th move that very
very tense situation at the 40th move
where a lot of players falter and that
is that's exactly what happened to him
in this game he's playing the black
pieces and we're seeing this very old
school line the double i think it's
called the double spanish according uh
to the lycha's database maybe you guys
have a better understanding of how this
particular line is called castle castle
d3 bishop takes c3 and why am i saying
it's old school well i'm looking at the
top game in this position and it's one
spielman versus karpov from 1992 one
year after i was born
[Laughter]
they were mixing it up that puts it in
puts it in perspective and let's take a
look at how that went knight to d8 of
course we understand now in the absence
of the knight on c3 the queen on e7 is
quite safe there's no more knight
landing on d5 so queen to e7
is i'm not getting off the pin but i'm
getting ready to transfer this knight
from c6 to e6 a much better position and
let's take a look at how this game are
panned out bishop takes f6 queen takes
pieces knight to g4 with a wild battle
ensuing after this one it does seem like
white got the better outcome out of the
opening so let's see how this one is
going to develop knight queen to e7
knight to d2 was played and this is
a game between kasim jonov and bachulun
from 2017 so they're still following
some sort of top games but let's see
once again who is going to be more aware
of the nuances and ideas in this
position nice to hear qasim's name being
tossed about there uh thank you for that
uh christian i just want to turn our
attention to the game of nick defermion
versus igor novikov
again igor was the only winner yesterday
in the seniors and he's playing against
nick the fermi and now of all the
players in the field nick the fermion is
the most theoretical
why because he's the author of the
modern chess openings books
and he's played this bishop b5 check to
sidestep the knight or the
boring boring boring uh takes take c2 c4
and igor said you know what takes takes
and takes for the knight is like the
most old-school way of playing this line
when you go back when you go back with
check you're gonna go back to the check
bishop b5 yeah i think everybody
fashionably everybody's playing knight
d7 almost
right
some people play bishop d7 okay but in
the few cases that they play bishop d7
most of the time white is going like c4
or a4 they're avoiding taking on d7
right i've seen a lot of those yeah yeah
and taking but they do take on these
hammer you know every blue moon right
and then
taking with the queen is
automatic right it's like autumn you
automatically take with the queen i've
been taking automatically with the queen
since i was nine years old i remember
the game gary
the rest of the world right with this
whole queen g4 yeah and that was great
stuff that was a great game right
uh gary wright wrote an entire book on
that
one game and how it impacted this summer
anyway knight takes d7 okay igor is
eager c4
and knight e5
he's basically saying hey look if you
want to double my pawns guess what yeah
feel free i'll end up playing e6 and
you'll never get in d4
nick said you know what i'm going to
take a strategic risk i'm going to
accept the double pawns
and
reach this position which
i mean i've been around you know i've
seen things but really is this can how
can this be good for white i mean
how can this be good for white how can
this be good for white
why on what planet could this be good
for white it can't be good right
right
you go knight c3 the guy goes g6 i mean
this is like one of the best uh dragon
slash moroxy vines it's like equal with
the pawn on g2 yeah
you already traded two pieces which is a
bad thing right
in a meroxy there's a reason we say it's
a bad thing because white has space the
binding you have the binding of the
space when you have this much space you
leave a lot of weaknesses behind you
don't want to see
pieces disappearing
so i'm just sitting there asking myself
the question that we have not seen g6 by
the way when we haven't seen knight c3
just asking myself the question how does
a player like nick the fermion who's
done
so much work on the openings
accept this position and say i'm willing
to play white i'm not sure if he
accepted or if he prepared it this is a
game between anand and nepo miyashi wow
look at that two huge names and
2014. um of course nepo miyashi with
black just completely destroyed
thank you for that
i'm not sure what happened
knight to c3 g6 followed by c5 try to
simplify the position on this side take
advantage of the fact well later on this
pawn on c4 would be a target especially
in the absence of the light square
bishop so
you want to get rid of that i'm not even
sure if this was some sort of a blitz
game or anything of that nature because
of course
white doesn't seem to have gotten
anything out of the opening in fact it
was black who was putting the pressure
managed to corral this pawn on a d6
recapture and actually later on get a
better position and win
the game so this was played before
incredible i didn't have a feeling that
he's not aware of that game
so let's wait and see whether these
players are going to follow that game
with c5 if he does play the move c5
which in my estimation is not
necessarily an easy move to make if you
don't know it in advance then if he
plays c5 then we know that he knows this
game he's aware and potentially has come
up with an improvement based on that it
might be a wonderful pond sacrifice for
black but why sacrifice the pawn at all
uh christian why not just take the pawn
on c5 the queen will recapture
time out what h4 once can not be a good
one
i believe in the move h4 no it's short
yeah
that move what
okay nick is definitely being inspired
okay
that's what we're gonna call it no we
also use the word interest interesting
we don't know what's going on
but what is the refutation that is the
question right because obviously black
is going to try to go
g6 later on yeah
i think the move h4 is really directed
against the move g6
and you're trying to i don't know shut
it down like this so alejandro no no
keep going keep it going
i think is still the best move and
actually after uh h5 you have e5
ah we just wins the pawn which is just
absolute greed perhaps this is why i
love it
because the knight wants to go to h5
anyway and and
it's nice yeah
you can sacrifice your exchange but
nobody believes that what time did he
spend on this move h4 94. five minutes
age
i like that this is not preparation you
know what inspired inspired i love it
it's not the candidates who get to see
some fun chess exactly let the guy play
h4 love it well for and by the way uh i
just wanted to go very very quickly to
uh the reigning u.s uh
seniors champion uh gregory kaidanov
again we're seeing this
uh lines of the uh sicilian bishop f4
queen e3
bishop b4
castle e5 and h7 this is all the regular
stuff yeah 94 and h4 are the moves here
knight e4
wow
can we just take a quick gander at that
one because i'm
i'm
i'm a pawn grubber i want to get out of
the way i want to take am i losing to
some bishop h6 business no no no i think
it's just a3
at least the only game that's ever
reached here was a3 a3 i know it's not
queen a5
that's the end of my theory
you're my top agent on these matters
i am not a classical sicilian player
with white or black right i've analyzed
it because i have to
but this particular version of knight
takes c6 and bishop f4 yeah it's an old
school line i mean we keep saying this
about the legends and they really are
using what they used to use
in their dusty library days i get it
okay wow um
okay and
okay knight e4 what the heck let me take
you to the juniors because uh i feel the
juniors are in a sacrificial mood
and i kind of like that
in the game between one of our winners
yesterday justin wang with the black
pieces he's actually playing against the
lowest rated player of the event pedro
and he said
now i know why you directed this to this
game we got a bank together we sure do
we forget this at the candidates we
don't even get the u.s championship let
me get it at the junior of course
for those that don't know uh alejandro
has made a very very good career on the
black side of the banco gambit but a lot
of food on my table
you furnish your entire house
[Laughter]
queen a5 this is actually a move you
like because
i think it was one of your videos with
chess bass where you were explaining
why the move d7 d6 is maybe a tempo
that you don't want to
uh throw away and you made a very
compelling argument for queen a5 take it
away aleandra yeah actually
uh there's only one reason i'm mad at
this variation you're mad i'm very mad
at this line oh my i am i've been
playing the bank of gam in my entire
life since i was a kid you know
excellent results and stuff like that
but at some point magnus carlsen played
exactly this variation okay i was like
wow magnus carlson is playing my line my
line and it was against boris girlfriend
damn i was like this is great i can't
wait to see this exciting battle that
starts with the move bishop d2 if we can
go to your yes yes absolutely bishop d2
bishop
and i've played tons of games from here
i've played dozens of games from this
position know a lot of theory and
instead
golfing played bishop d3
bishop d3 yeah against magnus okay and
that move actually straight up blue
system knight takes d5
and that you don't tell me magnus didn't
no he saw it but i was like i've been
playing
vidcon forever nobody has ever allowed
you fish with d3
and you would have gotten the free point
like that point like that
is a bag
oh my goodness and the whole trick is
knight takes d5 as opposed to knight
takes e4
doesn't allow the bishop to move right
so after bishop takes c3 queen takes
white ends up having to lose back his
peace something yes and it's actually
really bad it's real i get on that
sensation yeah so magnus won a game for
free something like that yeah and you're
like
where's my friends
man
i knew this i
could be doing this
oh my goodness so uh okay what happened
in the game though uh in the game i
think they they went bishop d2 bishop
they say six which is the main line of
the position and tell us about this
position for a second it's actually
rather sharp uh white has a couple of
ways of trying to get an advantage the
moose e5 um are a little bit too hasty
in this position probably you have to go
here you have to go knight g4 it's not
the end of the variation there's some
games here okay uh it goes on and on but
the main lines here are both bishop e2
which i think is the better of the two
and the other one is bishop takes a6
bishop e2 prepping cast castle looks
very nice but bishop takes a6 doesn't
that fall into black's plans a little
bit yeah you take back with the queen
it's important not to take back with the
knight it looks tempting to develop with
the type of but it's actually much more
important to prevent castles and the
weirdest thing about the bangkok gambit
as opposed to most gambits is that the
queen trade actually favors black
isn't that interesting it's one of the
weirdest things in chats i think right
it's a gambit variation in which black
is actually the one trying to exchange
the queens exactly
and
when you gambit the the normal routine
is you're gambiting you know for active
play and attacks and to trade the queens
after making a game but especially is
black and yet those endings are where
black embraces this so that really
thrives
upon down uh interesting game we'll
definitely keep an eye on it as we turn
back oh sorry well because a wonder also
sacrificed the pawn i don't know if it
was accepted again one of the key
matches of today
absolutely again everybody a wonder
liang comes into this tournament
with
an unbelievable rating
2700 he's played in the u.s
championships that's what he's aspiring
to do is to win the juniors everybody
give me the title so that i can take my
rightful seat in the u.s championship
what happens he loses the first game
yeah
first round pardon me uh yesterday and
can he bounce back against christopher
you who actually won his first game it's
a big game for our wonder how did we get
here by the way i don't actually know
and here we have a wonder liang age 19
from wisconsin actually a student at
university of chicago right where he
does not only study he actually has
taken his team to a lot of success
congratulations to a wonder and by the
way is it something in the air today
because benko gambit
ish right white
it's an idea
what do we call it i don't think it has
a name
christian jump in here
you need to have a name everything has i
don't think i mean i can check on
leeches to see if they do have a name
there let's let me take a look at that
it's called yes
the english opening symmetrical
variation three nights
variation get lost maybe that's boring
nothing's like
guys that's the worst opening name i've
ever heard there's nothing like that oh
i know he's supposed to deliver some
goods i'm trying to see it i mean if you
had said the maniacal attacking
orangutang
there we go
i like it three nights let's rename it
let's rename it three nights symmetrical
english get
the lost line in the position
and in this particular position b4 is by
far the main line and it's quite well
known it was played at the top level
napoleon she played it artemyev played
it recently anton guijaro lecko as well
liko and nepo we know that they're
working together so there's uh
definitely some understanding based on
that this one will definitely be
interesting but i was
having my eyes on this game
the game between andrew honk which and
balaji because
we stated that this guy andrew hung
yesterday came up with some monstrous
preparation and he's doing exactly the
same today with the white pieces he's
maximizing his uh initiative given by
the white pieces queen to a3 was that
move that we didn't really understand
but it is the computer move and it is
the best move in the position right now
the battle is about to begin because
black needs to find a way to castle
right and he needs to do it fast because
if you give me one more extra move so
for example if you played the second
best move in the position a5 tried to
set up a potential queen to be eight
queen to a b4 and cut the action of the
queen on this diagonal well now i have
time to go king to e1 quickly go king to
e1 and now there's no more castle if you
try to prepare castle with the move at
d6 rook to d1 and you remove too short
you're too late to
do the castle so unfortunately after
rook 21 you're actually much worse now
he knew that it seems like bellagio
after like a three minute thing he
played the best movie in the position
that is d6 still following the two games
that we were discussing and after bishop
to d3 we looked at this as well bishop
to d3 try uh queen to a3 had a double
threat that is to go king to e1 and rook
to d1 but also bishop to d3 and get the
square available for the king on c2 so
after a bishop to d3 castle rook to c1
was played d5 c5 still blitzing out his
moves one hour and 34 minutes on andrew
hung's clock one hour and sixteen
minutes on balaji doug patty's clock
right now and he's definitely struggling
to find the best path forward which is
by the way not easy right now in one of
the games the only game in the position
bishop takes g2 was played not an easy
decision and after rook to e1
knight to g4 was played in that game and
i think c6 was the follow-up i do
predict that at this point andrew hung
has an improvement and i think that is
perhaps this move bishop to g1 we will
have to wait and see whether he's going
to come up with this move or
queen to a6 another very intriguing move
targeting the pawn on e6 immediately and
asking the right questions this is going
to be the weapon of choice for the white
side if i manage to get this pawn to c7
the game is over you cannot allow me to
get that pawn to c7 but it's not going
to be an easy task well i have to say
incredible preparation once again for
andrew hung and he's not even sitting at
the board right now he's just like
strolling around
putting the pressure from afar on his
opponents and just to be just to clarify
for a moment christian yes uh 90 minutes
that uh andrew story yes and after
playing the first dozen moves he has
more time than what he started one hour
and 34 minutes
he's just missing out he's just blitzing
out every single move we're at move 21
right now
i want this guy on my my team you know a
coach i mean it seems to me like this
guy it comes with the prep i wanted to
turn our attention back to the game of
david brodsky versus carissa yip because
carissa yep is going to face a challenge
we left it after the move g7 g6 we just
saw david play the move knight c3
bishop g7 h3 all very nice and good
bishop e3
knight h5 a move that black often likes
to play she anticip carissa anticipates
bringing her king to h7 she could have
done it in i want to say the style of um
king h8 knight g8 and f5 karissa said no
i want to go knight h5 queen d2 king h7
bang
g4
and now here's the challenge she can
play knight f6 and just say okay
are you going to come and get me i mean
how aggressive are your intentions i
will play defense while you play offense
or she could offer a pawn
knight h
knight f4
and say i want to counter
your attacking game with a pawn
sacrifice of my own for example bishop
takes pawn takes queen takes f5
and i'm going to try to play for the
initiative i like this approach actually
how do you like which one do you choose
i like the knight f4 approach i i'm
beautiful it's just a lot i'm getting
here a little influenced by the juniors
sacrificing their pawns i think i can do
it too yeah
yeah they make you feel young they're
very young again right
i mean to be so
careless
go ahead go sacrifice your puns so uh
christian jump in here you're you're
you're the coach of mizzou do you tell
your guys
don't don't be a punching bag
throw some patties of your own what do
you advice well definitely throw some
patties of your own especially if your
opponent is surprising you in the
opening so i do like that idea with
knight to f4 give up the pawn and just
hope that you're going to get enough
initiative nevertheless from what i'm
seeing in that game i think david brosky
hasn't spent any of his time
carissa unfortunately is uh closing in
on one hour on the clock so almost 30
minutes spent so far one hour and 32
minutes for david brosky so he's
definitely ready for that move knight to
for that
yes i mean it's
it's a difficult moment for carissa it
looks good this g4 looks a little bit
rash but
again he knows his theory it seems like
and david brosky i know him and i know
he's a hard worker that's one of his
strong suits uh his theoretical
knowledge and he's showing it today i
mean he must be upset about what
happened yesterday against andrew hung
and we saw a face of desperation
yesterday as we were
watching him going down to his last five
minutes and seeing two queens for his
opponent on the board and having to
resign he's upset about that game he's
trying to take revenge and bounce back
as soon as possible against carissa
right
and theresa well an easy draw yesterday
against romania with black i have to say
she maybe was a little bit worse out of
the opening but
she calmly refuted over the board
abimani's preparation and she did that
in a great fashion and at some point i
have to say maybe she was even slightly
better so definitely showing uh good
shape in the event up to this point
nevertheless her first big test seems to
be today exactly wanted to turn our
attention to the game of jennifer you
and talia
cervantes for a moment because after the
kg move knight f3 and move two i thought
she was going to do something like a
bishop g5 a bishop f4 and to avoid a
queen scan but accept it no jennifer
went c4 immediately talia showed her
preparation
queen's gambit accepted with knight c6
when i played it i was an exclusive a7
a6
player i saw recently well not recently
but i've seen magnus carlsen also prefer
the line that talia plays knight c6
and they
quickly got into
boy i gotta tell you i played this
ending on both sides so many times i
mean uh the queen's gambit accepted
ending four verses four two verses two
in the candidates we saw
dean larryn in a crucial last round game
actually
uh getting the best of hikaru nakamura
when
he had nothing yeah yeah nothing it was
one of those games where you felt hikaru
had it in the back right he was just
kind of slipping slipping yeah
this one moved that he was
bishop
he was just it was within your drawing
range
was probably even better at some point
in that game slightly better with the
black pieces well okay but as it is uh
jennifer you playing exactly that uh
same ending maybe not the same position
but the same ending we'll keep our eye
on that one i also wanted to say just a
second where are you
zoe this was the game
anna marie zoe no there was another one
sorry i think this is rochelle
it was this game
that i had been talking about sophie
yeah
okay and that was uh
i had expected as an answer to h3 the
move g2 g4 because in those cases the
knight can pop back
to g5 g3
something like g5 and you can really
have a lot of fun as white she played g3
a6
knight d2 bishop d7
wow uh
i mean my move a5 would
would arrive on the board so fast
uh i don't know
what would have stopped me castles
um i have to think the hardest theory i
know but uh now i feel like black's
getting uh
more play on the queen side well sophie
doesn't spend a single second so i'm
assuming that this is all
theory i'm looking at your database
there's eight games played from this
position eight so
still nothing new we still see star
strong preparation in every tournament
it's really been outstanding what the
players have been bringing in terms of
opening knowledge and opening theory uh
in every section i would say that in the
legends it was more impressive that it's
old stuff coming back in right still
cool trying to resurrect the old lines
but the us juniors and euros junior
girls are really bringing in when it
comes to like straight up deep lounge
theory uh we saw yesterday on alice lee
against jenny for you we're seeing it
today in this game between rochelle and
sophie
the black player has spent zero zero
time to get here
okay very cool and let me turn it ooh
again very very nice of the
st louis chess club and scholastic
center here as we're opening up a new
bay
for tournament competition
and all the 15 players are kind of mixed
it's not like you see uh the girls
section on the left and the junior
section on the right no no no they're
all
uh intermixed
and let's take a look at this game guys
the game between kaidanov and massim
lugi and we did say that the seniors are
bringing all school theories back
nevertheless i'm looking at gregory
kaidanov and i know he's coaching a lot
so he's definitely uh up to speed on the
trends the new trends because he needs
to be as a coach as a coach of modern
chess players he needs to be and this is
exactly what we're seeing and this is
also his style on the left you can see
gregory kaidanov in db also maxim
dloogie in deep thought right now
because he's under a tremendous attack
and this position could explode any time
soon he had a very good start to the
tournament maxim dougie unfortunately
for him after getting a winning position
in after the first few moves uh he was
unable to convert yesterday but let's
take a look at what's happening
on the board today so i think you guys
left it somewhere around this moment
right to h7 and you are mentioning
knight to e4 queen to a5 and a3 he
started off with a3 okay decide what you
want to do with this bishop do you want
to sacrifice to exchange it for my
knight on c3 or do you want to keep it
close to the king close the king side by
setting it up on e7 he decided to go to
e7 knight to e4
finally came on the board and the
positions that are going to issue i'm
very curious what's going to happen
after bishop to d7 because at least from
a visual perspective this move knight to
d6 which is proposed by the engine looks
very dangerous
from uh for me because after bishop
takes d6 he takes this is i have a
couple of ways of cutting the defense of
this pawn from the bishop on f4 either
with f6 followed by e5 or with the move
rook to e8 now
f6 at least to my eyes is a bit more
intuitive h4 e5 it looks like i have a
very nice center and i'm going to be
able to corral this pawn d6 bishop to e6
and you're going to have some
difficulties defending it the thing is
about the position is that white will
have a way to open up and force this
pawn to go to e4 via f4 my next move is
going to be f4 sy that's going to force
you to either exchange which i don't
think you want to do open up the center
with two bishops on the board this
knight on h7 a little bit out of play i
don't think you want to see that and if
this diagonal opens up this pawn on d6
is going to be a thorn in black's
position so you have to keep the
diagonal closed as much as possible
unfortunately it doesn't seem like
there's a way to do that we do have a
move however we do we do
that
that's the second option but once again
knight to d6 now after bishop takes d6
take on d6 this bishop is going to land
on e5 he's going to get
whoa g5 man i want to win your [ __ ] no
no no
oh i see
what's your [ __ ] you know i see what
you're saying let me throw her oh man
that's disappointing how come it's so
easy sorry i didn't disappointing i
thought you were going to play
it's pretty bad it's pretty bad now
you have to sidestep this action with
king to h8 but then my bishop escapes
and then h4 is going to come on the
board yeah this is the problem your
knight on h7 is not only going anywhere
just to go h4 and if you cannot stop me
from opening up the position if the h
file opens up your check made it if if i
go f4 you're gonna go queen c3 yes and i
get i can't take twice on d6 but no king
no no no no which had been on
the king
c6
this is not looking ah
weird position sorry so f5 sorry i
apologize tell us what you were thinking
the main line should be go ahead well
i'm not 100 sure what the main line is
because bishop takes d6 at least to my
eyes doesn't look good for black no i'd
be able to cement this bishop on e5 with
f4 and then i'm going to open up the
position whenever i want with the move
g4 on the keyboard i like the computer
suggestion there of knight knight g5 yes
keep going knight f7 or knight e4 knight
f7 the thing is i just take take and now
i have a free attack true i just simply
have a free attack on the key side i
open up with g4 whenever i want and you
don't have anything on this side you're
way too far yeah way too far
by the way at this point the engine is
saying 3.5
whoa
humongous advantage probably there's
some sacrifices coming bishop to h5 rook
h3 rook g3 and then you're going to have
to contend with the fact that rook takes
g7 or bishop takes h6 comes on the board
it's not looking good
not looking good so you have to maybe go
to e4 but then once again i can take you
have to take with the f pawn yes and
then i open up once again position
whenever i want to and maybe right now
f3
it just seems like white has a goal a
sensible goal in the position
of what to play for and black doesn't
at least this is
how i feel about the position
nice nice points and by the way uh some
some
tricky
tactical play there i i do like that i
uh apologies i wanted to go to uh
to see how nick defermion had followed
up on his inspiring
play inspiring inspiring play uh the
inspiring play went h4
g6 igor said
i don't believe you go ahead and kill me
knight to c3 not inviting h5e5 as you
want it like give me the pawn
bishop g7 bishop g5
queen a5
okay i think i
that stops c5 e5 it also stops h5 don't
hang your bishop
rook c1 rook c8
uh
where is white putting his king
well his position is just bad white's
position is bad right right this is
bishop
this is a symptom come on an attempt
bishop g5
bishop d2 right an attempt to maybe
invite a queen trade uh
no i'm not uh i i what white's almost
lucky that his position is not
collapsing right like a move like queen
h5 is
is close to winning exactly gift me the
pawn
and uh ask
ask uh white what do you intend
something like queenie but queen e3
drops e4 c4 and if you go queen d3 you
go knight d7
which is a dream come true of course
because you start thinking oh what
the lovely thing what beauties right
this bishop oh my god uh wow i mean for
igor
starting the tournament with two blacks
winning this first game as black uh this
would be uh he's got a great position i
know
you know right he's wondering why
did christmas come
come early this year
and uh christian what other games have
you been uh looking at well i was
looking at this game actually i was
following you also
yes and actually bishop to d2 seems to
have been an inaccuracy what the engine
was supporting was king to f1 keep the
bishop on g5 specifically for the reason
that alejandro mentioned not to allow
the queen to get to h5 quite an
interesting idea you're not going to
castle anyway right you just play the h4
you want to have the rook behind the
pawn potentially threatened to go h5 if
this knight moves away and then the king
on e1 is not great greatly placed right
because knight on c3 is on the pin so
you want to put it on f1 this seems to
have been the better choice in the
position i'll keep an eye on everything
else what's happening and i'll get back
to you guys okay cool i
just wanted to go to the game of igor
and larry christensen for a moment
because i mean okay i i know these uh
what do they call it the alapan c3 the
weapon in uh sicilian with c2c3 and a
lot of strong players have at various
times in their careers approach the
sicilian this way but then it's
kind of strange i i'm aware of this move
knight a6 knight a3 takes
knight takes i'm not aware of knight c2
at all i thought the move was knight c4
to take advantage of the fact that b6 is
weak right that you've provoked that
you've provoked
a6 so that you can now and then i know
they go like knight bd7 and i think you
go i think there's knight e3 or bishop
b2 i don't remember anymore excuse me
that was supposed to be bishop e2 but
knight e3 certainly it looks like a
tempo but knight c2
and i was really surprised by this
decision knight takes because it almost
invites e5 and i didn't know if we were
in theory or not after for example
knight e3 that that it's it's it's a
strange impression that the white
knights are having bouncing all around
but i didn't know what to make of this
position it's i don't know it at the
very least no okay definitely
yeah i mean i'll keep an eye on this one
as if you do go queen
uh to c5
queen c7 christian jump right in uh
what what's your database and engine
telling you
well that position after e5 is more or
less equal but i was checking uh this
game again andrew hung versus bellagio
because i mean andrew is just coming up
with brilliant preparation and i have to
keep an eye on it bishop to d3 d4 bishop
to d4 2 queen to d5
it looks obscure it wasn't one of the
top engine lines for black that moved d4
but andrew is still within his
preparation because he's blitzing out
his moves rook to e1 was played
instantaneously queen to f5 once again
he stopped for like 30 seconds and i was
looking okay king to c2 looks like the
best move but then i start understanding
that after rook to c8 you have to defend
like this and it does seem like after a5
black is getting a lot of counter
chances it didn't look good for white
the engine is still saying that it's
better for white nevertheless from
practical perspective i don't see it so
i was thinking about the position and i
thought that black bellagio that is is
getting his chances
after queen to f5 immediately bishop to
a6 came on the board still one hour and
34 minutes for andrew this is move 24
dropping below one hour is balaji dog
party right now in a difficult position
difficult also for from a practical
perspective look at him he's just
walking around
no worries in the world
happy that he got his preparation in
once again
maybe uh
another shower another cold shower came
up with this type of brilliant ideas
deep deep preparation by andrew hung i
have to say i'm mightily impressed with
what he's bringing to the table in this
tournament wow but that was bishop a6 i
don't know coach if you're if you're
you got a student you're doing a summer
camp and you're saying to your students
show me your best games you know so we
can
we can analyze them together
and your student plays bishop a6
your first instinct is dude think about
your king you know like like now you've
left your king trapped in the middle of
the board
and then you get the cold shower but
coach my 3600 chess engine says bishop
a6 is the best move
it's hard to argue with the 360
do you ever get that
did you ever like open your mouth to
criticize a student's play and then
you get hit with but coach that's what
stockfish 28 000 says
we're full of what happens all the time
yeah but it's not a practical decision
we
very good coach i mean of course you
have your whole repertoire i wanted to
turn quickly to carissa yep what up
david brotzky
david brotzky
came with the heat played the move g2 g4
it was a very direct challenge to
carissa carissa's been slow playing it
but you did
go for the knight f4 pawn sacrifice
right wow oh no partner she went for f5
she went completely crazy all right good
good good well i do see f5 f4
she's winning back the piece to begin
with it's not like it's a p sacrifice it
could be a pawn sacrifice it could be a
double bond sacrifice but f5 coach
what do you think i don't know man
let's go down the line because it's okay
you have to take the knight otherwise
this doesn't matter why did i play g4
otherwise i guess you play f4 i don't
see why otherwise why you play this okay
and for sure i'm going to toss it and
jack check because like that's what i
got to do
and i guess you're going back really
you want to put your king you want to
lead with your chin
i don't know you don't have a lot of
pieces right
i might uh
king
h7 i don't have to take this bishop i
think it's a nice point for black you
keep you keep the tension tension right
yeah you never know when you want to
take on e3 so king h7 so you think that
this pawn on g6 is otherwise kind of
like annoying
the thing is i'm not sure i get it back
ah bishop f seven that's yeah yeah if
the bishop seven didn't exist i would
just you know decide sidestep it but
right i'm not sure i get it back and if
i don't get it
that's a problem okay so let's go down
the line
down the rabbit hole for a moment here
let's pause okay yeah exactly that is
the pause moment right here
as
i'm looking at rook g1 and
queen d7 no i have rook g4 at least
so okay let me uh secure
the open file
um
christian jump right in if you feel like
uh we we we're blowing it
no no no no
you guys are doing well actually
king 2h1 is a bit more precise to live
that square for the knight because very
often with the king on h2 one of the
main ideas for black is with the bishop
c8 to go queen to d7
right yeah we saw that and then that the
knight might be better placed on exactly
it's it's all about
white forcing black to take on e3 so i
have to make a move later on queen to e
to potentially depending on what you do
right now so so how do you continue
after king to h1 yeah it was the greed
factor as far as i was concerned i was
trying to protect the pawn on h3 king h7
queen e2 now enforcing yeah
and now i take with the pawn
okay
and now you're having huge uh problems
it seems like with your king
let's say
black black is having huge problems yes
rook f2 well rook g1 let's go to g1 yeah
i think i have a big threat right now
and that is knight g5 you
oh i think knight g5 might be a problem
so you have surprised a big of a threat
maybe i can also start
here
who turned the tables on wow yeah
you're the one having problems with your
king that's wow that's the situation
right now
okay and and pawns are equal by the way
yes of course uh
a quick question for you though king h2
is fine as well yeah how did the engine
evaluate rook g1 just so that we can get
zen at the position so the position
after king h2 right yeah
g1 yeah rook g1 still a very decent
advantage but actually rook g1 throws
some of it away after queen to d7 okay
so not root g1 not right right
is is not necessary once again that's
your queen e2 movement or queen to d1
queen to e2 is not as precise in this
particular moment once again because of
queen to d7 and the problem is if you go
king to knight to g1 i have f3 coming
with tempo a lot of details in the
position that white and black will have
to understand later on f5
i have to say it's a gamble
she's a gambler
she doesn't know the position that's
what we call it an interesting move
again gamble it's like an intriguing
intriguing
a gamble a gamble i mean first
impressions were f5 and carissa was
being uh ornery and uh
and and and fighting back but now you're
calling it it's a gimbal it's a gamble
it's not a good sign it's not a good
sign and by the way just a another
question for you if you don't mind uh
after f5 i'm noticing that this knight
on c3
really doesn't have a great square so
for example no no take on h5 take on h5
you cannot do that
well you cannot do that no i wanted to
take it you're already much worse now
you take on h5 but then i go f4 yeah and
i've left myself the square e4 at the
end of the day right but you have to uh
get ready to jump there you cannot go
knight to e4 because of d5 so you have
to lose another tempe with bishop to d5
first which will get hit by knight to e7
so it's not really working that well uh
h1 f takes e3 and it already seems like
black is getting a decisive advantage
close to decisive advantage
wow okay well that's too bad
i was trying to get a nice square for
the night didn't work out alejandro it's
tempting
it's tempting though it's tempting but
you have to keep those two pawns on e4
and e3 to control all the squads all the
squares make sense yeah it really
doesn't instead of
yes okay very good uh a couple of games
we haven't seen just a a again just
taking a quick look at the a wonder
liang game for just a moment again i'm
really curious to see how this great
superstar of tomorrow i wonder liang
maybe even today i should say is going
to handle losing the first round
and will he bounce back after the move
bishop b2 by the way queen g6 obviously
a tickle
against the rook as well as trying to
keep the bishop honest
uh not developing because of the g2 pawn
bishop b2 c4
and
h4
are we in
uh how shall i put it novel
territory novelties were like long time
ago a long time ago we don't know where
they came
but we got this mess on the board
it's one of those games right you try to
explain to your students
and you're just like
everything that you're supposed to do in
chess
you've done
wrong right you put all your pawns on
like on dark squares as white yeah they
report and put all their spawns on light
squares
i mean this bishop on v2 is a monster
but you don't have development as white
you're not castle you're not close to
castling
but the queen is weird the queen has
moved how many times has this queen i
have no idea about it a lot of times
yeah three four times right
and i am tempted by the move bishop h3 i
love developing with the game of tempo i
don't mind knight take c6 and bishop g2
either yeah um jump in here christian
first of all where did the novelty come
second of all as christopher
overpressed over played his hand so it
seems like already queen to f6 as early
as after b4 queen to f6 was a novelty
c64 was by far uh the main line c4 also
an option and
the engine's
evaluation as the best move queen to f6
came on the board and by the way this is
one thing i noticed about a wonder where
i know i wonder from when he was 11
years of age and he was much more of a
conservative player he was playing
tighter openings and he wasn't taking as
many risks
as he grew older he's becoming more of a
gambler and i like it i love to see that
he's coming up with this type of sharp
intriguing ideas such as b4 and now he
does seem like he does have a slight
edge in the position nevertheless the
position remains extremely extremely
complex bishop to h3 is one of the lines
queen to a4 is another one of the lines
very very complicated battle ensuing
right now in this position white needs
to finish its development black will try
to do that as well but you have to be
careful because once you move this
bishop from f8 you're going to have some
problems on the long diagonal
with that cannon on b2 looking at the g7
square so
definitely a very complex battle you
know a wonder after losing with the
black pieces wants to come back exactly
i'm the rating favorite i want to bounce
back i want to get that title back to
the university of chicago because
and by the way alejandra you were
mentioning something uh very appointed
at the beginning of the show he has been
leading his uh team the university of
chicago to a great successes uh
throughout the year since he was there i
think there's another grand master at
the university of chicago we've seen him
in the championship last year remind me
his name again praveen
another great grand master from the
university of chicago i think uh he is
21 right now so he doesn't have the
right to play in this tournament but
what i was saying is that he is leading
that team without scholarships
so they're not attracting players with
scholarships but they are attracting the
players with the greatness of the
university as well as the greatness of
this team that he's leading
yes indeed thank you for that i'm just
looking at the game between alice lee
i just love her i i love telling about
her video
channel uh alice's upon palaces i mean
13 years old you already have your own
hit show get out of here this is amazing
uh she's up against alan wang and we've
just seen e4 knight takes e4 on the
board um i don't think alice really is
coming out of this opening with anything
to be proud of i mean knight takes e4
if you take with the rook bishop take
bishop b7 i actually prefer
black's position in that case queen
takes e4 help me if i'm
missing something here but i'm seeing
rook b8 i'm seeing knight f6 and i'm
thinking why isn't black doing well it
looks fine for black right exactly it
all depends this is one of those tempo
dependent positions where white has this
one tempo to get in a dangerous knight
g5 a dangerous d5 a dangerous bishop g5
something that actually
hits and hurts and hurts yeah but if you
don't have it black is put a tempo away
from consolidating position fully and
getting a tempo on herself bishop b7
knight f6 c5 takes d4
uh
and actually ending up with a better
center my first impression is that allen
won the opening battle okay i don't
think that white has anything here
exactly also the pawn on a3 makes a bad
impression i'm not sure why sometimes c
takes d4 the pawn on c4 could stick out
just a little bit but as we get prepared
for a break i just wanted to say do we
have i remember yesterday q boutique was
offering like something ridiculous right
seventy-five percent
get out of here get out of it no way
five percent maximum let's see
what we got today for you we have a
magnetic a travel chess set from
stl.com take a look at that very nice
very very nice uh
yeah
you can find us at cbtcastiel.com
right right very nice uh hand polish
there yeah
he's looking better and better every day
well i tell you he's
he's such a charmer he really is yeah
all right guys we'll take a quick break
and we will be on the other side with
still 15 games remaining
[Music]
hey st louis the ascension charity
classic presented by emerson is back
this september don't miss the excitement
when the pga tour champions best compete
again all for charity september 9th
through the 11th at norwood hills
country club pro-am spots hospitality
packages vip tickets and more available
now at ascensioncharityclassic.com
st louis university celebrating its
200th anniversary offering world-class
education in the heart of st louis
slough attracts students and professors
from around the globe
in 2015 slu partnered with the st louis
chess club to start a top-tier
collegiate chess team on the very first
year of the teen's inception slough
obtained second best university at the
pan-american intercollegiate chess
championships
higher purpose
greater good
st louis university
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everybody as we are in
round two of the u.s junior championship
u.s girls junior championship and the
u.s senior championship here in saint
louis missouri let's take a look at our
pairings for this round as we have a
huge matchup in the girls junior section
jennifer yu is currently playing against
talia cervantes with the white pieces at
number one seed against number two and
with a draw already in hand by jennifer
yesterday that means that she's playing
catch up absolutely alice lee at the
bottom of the pairings there against
ellen wang also a game that we're
keeping our eye on and in the juniors in
the junior section we had four decisive
games yesterday and we have a lot of fun
games today andrew hong brought the
preparation yesterday and he's doing the
same today it sure is against dagupati
in a wild sicilian between the only
players with one point facing each other
exactly and andrew's preparation has
been awesome he's just been playing move
after move but also at the game that
we're also marquee match up
wonderling versus christopher you can a
wonder the number one sleeve snap back
after a shock loss
yesterday and in the
the seniors in the legends
i wanted to say legends i couldn't think
of the word
there you go we have a bunch of cool
games guys against lugi i think is
really cool shabala vacopia is very cool
but still game of the day i think has to
be different against novikov just
because of the standings nobody won his
game yesterday against vladimir kopian
he's the only one sitting on one full
point as he was the only decisive gamer
of the round and he is now repeating his
black pieces against the fermion but we
like his position absolutely we do i'm
just looking at the game of wonder liang
for just a moment against christopher
you and i think christopher has just
mangled his opening the more i would
look at the position
the current position after knight takes
c6 uh b takes c6 again i'm just seeing
that first of all
this pawn
this pawn really means that it's going
to be difficult for black to ever find
uh king side safety uh that is to say
you want to play bishop g7 you want to
put your king on the g8 square you're
not going to the queen side and you're
not going to leave it in the center for
too long because at certain moment the
moves d3 and e4 for white um
play themselves
in addition black structure the part on
a7 just it's a very compelling target
let me play moves like bishop d4 queen
a4 rookie 1 and e4 i like what a wonder
has done i think christopher has
going to have some challenges to solve i
agree and even though black has i think
more resources than are apparently
available for example he could play the
move bishop e7 i don't see a punish
ah you mean i can't take you cannot take
on g7 i mean you can but the game ends
immediately with a perpet like i i post
up nicely
on the d4 square and you go whoops
and yeah i don't think there's any
hesitation towards taking the draw and
that's that's a perpetual check indeed
so okay i mean there's not more than
that yeah exactly it might be uh you
always look for you always look for that
right d7 what the heck right so maybe
the g7 pawn is taboo yes but you're not
running to castle on the other hand
because h5 that's a real pawn that's a
real pawn so you have time to play
something like you mentioned bishop d4
you never know when bishop c5 is useful
it prepares d3 in some way you could
play d3 immediately right then
i'm not tickling h5 that's the only
reason i wouldn't want to play it but
the resulting structure at the end is so
favorable for white anyway
maybe i'll just pause a moment rookie
one
i don't know because you're not castling
maybe i am threatening to take on g7 if
you don't have the perpetual
okay something to keep our eyes on for
sure and uh wilton gonna turn it over to
christian and say christian what's
caught your attention well uh just to
say uh in the junior section i was
keeping an eye on the game between
andrew hung and balaji and i was trying
to understand
what has transpired and what changed in
the last few moves we left it out after
queen to f5 and bishop to a6 came on the
board and we were mesmerized by this
idea because king to c2 made much more
sense at least to the naked eye just try
to get the king to b1 as fast as
possible and escape
this onslaught that is coming especially
if the pawn lands on d3 for example
black is like two moves away from
checkmating right if you do play any
sort of like uh natural move such as
this one queen two g4 just finishes the
game so after
after d3 you have to do something right
rook to c4 does seem to make way for the
king to go all the way to b1
uh quite nicely actually not only that
but after you remove this bishop from e4
i'm going to be able to transfer this
rook on the d file put a lot of pressure
on the d3 pawn and unfortunately for you
i'm going to corral that i'm going to
capture that i'm going to have two
bishops a safe king all the way to b1
and that's just game over so you cannot
do that you cannot hurry with a move d3
he played the move queen to h5 check
bishop to e2 of course has to come on
the board queen to d5
and now it does seem like this is the
position we have on the board if you do
want to repeat you could go bishop to c4
force the move queen to h5 and then
we're going to see the repetition bishop
to d3 again allows queen to h5 and a
potential repetition so
the only way i see
uh for white to continue this game is
bishop to f3 you cannot defend the pawn
by moving it because well unfortunately
after d3 it's resignation time you don't
have an extra tempo to get this rook off
the c file to go off the c1 square to go
to c1 with the king if you go bishop to
f1 bishop to f3 is going to come that's
game over we don't want to see that on
the board so the only way to defend this
pawn on g2 and propose the trade of the
bishops which is probably going to be in
white's favor is with the move bishop to
f3 a natural move i think we're going to
see this land on the board once again
i'm trying to understand how is black
going to continue at this game because
let's not forget black is still upon
down pawn down
no to bishops i'm the one with the
bishop para as well as white so if you
don't do something immediate right then
you're going to be in trouble so you
need to find some sort of complications
in the position to ask some questions
from your opponent and we see andrew
hong right now i'm not 100 sure what
he's looking maybe he's eyeing his
opponent
[Laughter]
or maybe just simply trying to remember
his uh theory because bishop to f3 does
seem like a very natural move right now
it certainly does uh thank you for that
christian and alejandro uh big
developments in the rochelle woogie we
were talking about andrew hong's
excellent preparation and i think also
excellent preparation is being seen by a
certain sophie morris suzuki she won her
game yesterday so she was one of the
winners of yesterday's round very nice
and she has an absolutely crushing
position with the black pieces
i guess one of the rating favorites
rochelle woo wow what happened
let's let's see what happened
or not we're still following a game no
kidding yeah we left it we were here and
i didn't like the fact that
black had gotten in the movie bb5 i
wanted to play a5 in a snap in a
heartbeat
and we didn't see these moves but they
were played bishop knight takes b5
winning the two bishops but on the other
hand the bishop on e2 is no great shakes
rook takes b2
uh oh i'm beginning to
wait a minute wait a minute do i want to
see this queen landing on a3 uh hitting
my bishop and then what happened after
f4 was played and i think queen a3 just
finishes the game really well they give
us the line i have to move the bishop
right you have to because bishop bishop
if i take this bishop the game is oh and
you're taking with check as well so i
know wait i was trying to make this work
and i think i did i think i can play
rook takes d2 it looks like a fine queen
and unfortunately i think knight f3
doesn't work because i take take bishop
somewhere you defend mate
but if you start with the queen
bishop somewhere by the way e4 is also
hanging out yeah ah but i'm tickling the
question tickling the queen so bishop
three attacks probably still
compensate i don't know i don't know
okay but you had a different i started
with the queen so you go queen f3 you're
threatening mate
there's only one way to defend i gotta
take it
but then i get
my material back and more
you win and four
and i get e4 on top of that ooh
oh that's yeah that says oh that's
pretty it's pretty and it's decisive i
think right visual
queen now the weirdest thing all of that
happened in the game no green gore i'm
looking at the database ring uh
grandmaster from belgium against
chaparrinov got killed and got killed
well sometimes you play japan
it's pretty good wow
wow
by the way after queen a3 the only other
move i could come up with was king f2
and that doesn't look
any better uh again i think you're gonna
just gonna make a uh a dazzling
combination on me right probably not
even that dazzling right probably
something very basic right right this
looks completely lost what am i doing
i'm winning in exchange for
i don't want to play white's position
i think after 93 you're very close
yeah yeah um
yeah
wow uh excellent
sophie uh with the prep right dang
that's
this is not quite the game no but in the
game between rochelle woods seems like
rochelle
should be moments away from resigning if
this move queen a3 lands on the board uh
followed by queen f3 that was really
really nice jennifer you i
jennifer and talia are basically
vacuuming the pieces off the board
nothing is going on between what we
thought hoped
uh would be a really really important
now this looks pretty dead yeah
a draw in the works uh alice lee oh ooh
just a second she didn't take on e4
uh ellen played bishop b7 oh immediately
inviting knight g5
looks fine no i can still take on e4
with the knight
yeah i think with the knight
okay
and
no trickies here right
no trickies that trick is but if you
take one i take with the
you can take with the knight actually
then
pretend the knight takes d6 is a that
takes a 6-0 threat right absolutely i
apologize it most certainly is
even also bishop g5 bishop g5 could also
be considered but no knight takes d6
will hit the rook hit the bishop
um yeah unfortunately you don't have
time to take on e4 with the bishop
because i am actually double attacking
losing the pair of bishops is not always
that bad right in this position right
because i can take on d4 get some dark
squares but losing the pawn losing the
pawn is just not acceptable though yeah
like check i don't care you can go king
fa king h8 you can decide later but as
you say you lose the pawn and the bishop
comes back and you're upon down yeah
that's it yeah
um
maybe this move
uh knight f3 to g5 by alice
uh
is giving her some
some chances yes yep yes is there any
immediate yeah knight takes c6 still a
threat big time that's still the main
threat actually right
yes knight takes d6 uh
uncovered uncovering a
discovered attack against the bishop on
b7
and we see ellen i think she's at the
board kind of struggling struggling yeah
right you see that concentration i
always love that when my opponents go
into those oh it feels like you're doing
something right you're putting that
pressure right right right it feels like
a position that black should have some
kind of solution to but i'm having
trouble coming up with it right it's not
immediately obvious if you play a move
like rook b8 say do your worst the
problem is
white might just do her worst that's
pretty bad
and you've walked into a shish kebab
there with you thank you very much i
mean doris is really uh a big influence
i tell you i think i'm still hardwired
by that whole candidate's experience i'm
going to talk to my agent and see if i
can't get some kind of compensation for
you know
hazard pay i don't know
when we what do we
don't you think christian
ptsd
over the ride
some pcs ptsd but guys right i've been
uh checking out the games in the seniors
yes actually yeah baby looking at this
game between kaidanov and uh maxim lugi
and in fact by the way knight to d6 was
played i think this is where we left it
after this uh enterprising move f5
knight to d6 and knight to g5 and we in
fact looked at the position and i said
that after h4 94 and by the way this
position has been seen before it was
your student alejandro benjamin bach
from st louis university against
riemer's ma
in 2015 i hope i pronounced that
correctly he played the movie g4 instead
of h4 so setting up uh different
questions for a black after the exchange
you're going to have to deal with the
weakness on e6 in fact very complex game
it was a black sacrifice in exchange and
got some initiative after that so g4 was
an alternative but he decided kaidanov
there is to go with the much more
natural move and this is what we thought
is natural move as well h4 it seems like
the computer agrees with his estimation
as well knight to e4 knight xe4 f takes
e4
and now came a very uh nuanced move and
that is queen to g3 we thought that f3
makes much more sense right and i said
that after the exchange of these two uh
pawns white is simply going to get a
free attack on the king's side i did not
see a very speedy attack coming on the
queen side for black so i gave this uh
the assessment for white definitely in
white's favor he decided to go queen to
g3
interesting move nevertheless after king
to h8 which was played uh in the game
it sort of starts to feel forced that
white needs to do something immediate
that something could potentially be an
immediate sacrifice on h6 whoa bishop
takes h6 exactly g takes h6 and by the
way the computer right now likes white's
position but after queen to g6 you let
it think for a while and maybe i'm
missing something but after rook takes
f2 take take queen to g6
king goes back to h8 and the key move in
the position that after rook to f1
you need to keep this files plot if you
open up the f file for the white species
for the white's rook to enter the
freight then you're going to be in deep
danger probably just simply lost so the
way to do that is not with e3 because
this would allow me to go queen to h6
followed by queen take c3 as well as
bishop to d3 and that's a big problem
right because you have another checkmate
to deal with you cannot play the move e3
and defend the rook on f2 like that so
the only move in the position is bishop
to c5 wow this could be uh difficult to
see from afar right you see all the way
to this uh you see an incredible attack
coming your way or coming your
opponent's way if you are kaidano and
you're looking at this type of
situations and maybe you could miss this
move bishop to c5 now the question is
does this force a perpetual for white
and it does seem according to the engine
uh and we tend to trust the engines uh
it does seem like it forces equality it
forces a perpetual and you can see he's
calculating bishop takes h6 because you
played queen to g3 that queen if you
don't sacrifice and invade via g6
that square g3 is not the best uh
placement for the queen right much
better would have been on e3 and get rid
of that central pawn on e4 which is just
a thorn in white's position right now
wow
yeah bishop c5
not intuitive and easy it's not easy
yeah easy easy move to miss but bishop
takes h6 followed by queen g6 is very
suggestive very very human uh i think
i think he's uh he's licking his chops
he's just
checking that rook f2 variation and
i mean he knows he's got the perpetual
in the pocket it's always a nice feeling
whenever you're sacrificing a rook or a
piece you
you know you got to draw you you know
you're not risking anything now bishop
takes h6 is not the only move and if we
look at the position we know that that's
probably the the direction this game is
going to go towards a sacrifice on h6
and then some sort of checkmating ideas
and patterns now how can you improve the
position to get ready for that scenario
is the question how would you like to go
bishop h5 to g6 but bishop h5 to g6 but
i like i liked your earlier suggestion
of f3
and trying
trying to pry open the g file after e
takes f three g takes f3 that would go
nicely i wanted to there's a problem
with f3 guys yeah now this is very
reminiscent of what happened yesterday
in the game between akopian and novikov
you're forgetting about
black's attack on the b file and after
f3 now taking advantage that the queen
is no longer on e3 i have this extra
idea queen to b6 followed by rook to b8
and you're starting to have difficulties
defending this pawn on b2 it is black
who's getting the attack right now
in fact it seems like the best move is
rook to h3 and this is the question that
i was asking how do you improve the
position to get ready for that sacrifice
on h6 you're getting the rook on the
third round
and then queen g6 is going to come and
then there's checkmates coming
immediately right
so rook to h3 a very uh intriguing move
bishop to c5 seems to keep black in the
game
but a very very complicated battle
anything can happen
you uh play this move queen to g3 which
in my estimation is quite committal
right so at some point which means
probably pretty soon you're going to
have to start calculating all these
sacrifices and be precise with it well
one of the things i really really like
about that move bishop c5 is it also
introduces the idea of rook on a8 to a7
uh defending along the seventh rank so
it make it takes all of the
oomph
out of those sacrifices i wanted to turn
our attention to the game of david uh
brotsky and carissa yep for just a
moment because david found that really
nice uh maneuver
of queen e2 king
we more or less accepted this position
uh as a human king h1 was actually the
engine's top choice for reasons inclu
facing queen d7 you have a knight h2 and
guess what carissa said okay this is the
this is the move i really like by david
brodsky queen e2 saying go ahead take my
piece and now my extra pawn is actually
doing really great things for
david
um yes sir you liked it with the king on
h1 i did the king on h2 remember i liked
with the king on h2 too no we looked at
this and this queen d7 actually turns
the tables no right now yes it does
because after knight g1 you have the
move f3 well that's right it was the
queen on d1 you had to play queen d1
exactly quindy one was a plus 3.5
advantage so right now
it is black who is in the lead
with f three three right now and she's
gonna play she played
she played queen to d7 she has to play
f3 okay after f3 i moved the queen queen
to d1
d1 okay and then the follow-up must be
that you're going to get something on g2
where's the knight to d4
knight to david four
jeez okay so you're protecting the pawn
and you're just saying to white well
knight untangle exactly threat sometimes
depending on if you move the knight on
c3 right
right and if i take the big moment that
you know
will be opened up
exactly if you take bishop to e5 is
coming and you're in deep trouble not
only that but i'm going to couple bishop
to e5 with queen to g7 guys guys we have
an engine but this is a piece
know to white
just ask i
like you're kind of frozen your pieces
are a little frozen what do you play
just what do you play like just give me
a move you mentioned that if you move
the knight 92 92 and by the way
it's not so easy for you to defend
um
uh h3
uh if you take the knight well thank you
very much that's a tempo and the bishop
will be introduced with check
and maybe the queen will come g7 queen
to g7
uh
so you can't move the knight on c3 you
can't move the bishop yeah you're
welcome to move your bishop but what
does that accomplish nothing but that
will give black carissa time to bring
her pieces into attack
uh
it's one of the most intriguing
positional piece sacrifices as i've seen
in a long while i've seen these
many
long-term reminds me of the game of
geary with the white pieces against
about to buy from the recent grand prix
series where the iranian player
sacrifices a knight on f4 yeah and it
doesn't seem obvious how
to get compensation the engine is
winning for black right and it just
takes a long build up but there was
nothing white could do in the long run
it didn't seem that
there was any need for anything
immediate yeah but that's a hard move
man playing f3 when you can just take
the bishop right you think uh
automatically to take i remember i i
lost a brilliancy it really was a
wonderful game by grand zuniga yeah he
played knight takes e5
just sacrificing a piece for a pawn i
had a pawn on d6 i took it he played f4
and then there was this positional
attack that was slow but somehow my
pieces were awkward and i couldn't
defend and you might be wondering why
queen d1 is so much better than queen to
e2 right and let's take a look at that
perhaps
why is queen e1 so much better because
this gives a completely winning
advantage what if you do the same f3
yeah and say like we still have this
spine on your pieces
but i have an extra tempo and that extra
tempo gives me
a decisive advantage because i have the
time to play knight to b1
followed by knight to d2 and you don't
have time to get your knight on e2 in
time
that is beautiful
it's it's it's it's bizarre it's a one
tempo situation right now and now you
can just simply take on it with the
queen exactly yes it's
wow attack dice knight b-1 to defend the
king knight to b1 it's a beautiful move
the best move not the only move in the
position but knight to b1 i think just
push the compassion actually the other
one is king to each one
so that you can play knight this one
knight before you take on d4 and there's
no bishop to e5 coming with check so
once again you gain another extra tempo
wonderful
wow great great stuff carissa
is in the tank she needs to find f3
though she needs to make the decision i
mean that that that's an ig i want to
ask about her time 27 minutes and then i
will i want you both to tell me
do you think she will find the move f3
well i'll yes please she will find it
the question is will she play right okay
that's guys
thanks christian
well that clarifies that there you go
you didn't answer
alejandro you didn't answer you were
supposed to get it in before she played
the move f3 this is impressive
this is awesome
right now this is awesome
if david plays queen d1 and she follows
up with knight d4 where's the gold coin
i mean okay quinty one is forced but the
boys are about to get their shower on
this board exactly what a beautiful
sacrifice sparkling stuff uh
wow
are you stunned i'm stunned i am i mean
it's so difficult right because exactly
you look at the position and after
knight d4 you have to make
you have to start making weird moves
such as b4 or a5 according to the engine
and just
basically say that okay i'm waiting for
you to find the checkmating pattern in
the meantime i'm just going to push my
pawns on the queen side it doesn't make
any practical sense
from white's perspective and david is
realizing
wait a minute you didn't take my p's
i'll play queen d1
i don't think it's quite sunk in but
after knight d4
it's weird it's awkward it's weird but
what is the follow-up christian what
does the engine
follow up into that let's wait and see
whether she plays knight d4 she's
definitely no there's nothing there's no
other movement
that's clear
f3 was the hard move yeah that then the
rest kind of follows automatically but
now i'm with you 100 alejandro i like am
i playing rook g8 am i playing bishop f6
like if bl if white plays rook a3 an
incredibly stupid move and i don't
recommend rook a3 just exactly how does
carissa bring her pieces to the king
well you have to imp you have to make
the connection between the rooks and get
the rook from a8 at some point into play
right clear so the way to do that is
find a better configuration for your
queen and bishop
you need to keep contact with the pawn
on h3 so
let's start with queen to e8 followed by
queen to h5
wow i mean this is the maneuver
wow and it makes sense because you do
want to have your queen on h5 that's the
most aggressive position true which the
queen can land on true
can i bail
can i play can i bail and take this and
take the pawn it might be too late
though yes i mean you take the knight
and
you've got your queen h5 amongst other
things you may have i mean so i'll be
let's assume the rook's on a1 there's
rook f2 but correct but let's assume the
rook's on a1 right yeah we can make a
less stupid move with rook b yeah i was
just trying to yeah like rook c1 rook c1
just so that we go a little bit yeah
yeah and if you go queen e a
takes takes knight three and here we
have something similar but the queen is
defended yes better thank you right
thank you absolutely
so still queen to h5
oh queen
i'm inviting bishop e5 check let's keep
going yeah
i think i'm getting killed i'm just
getting killed the queen's h4 yeah no
this is too much this is terrible bishop
one c4 is just not participating
right no no it's not looking great
exactly that bishop certainly needs to
be on g2 what is white supposed to do if
you don't have this uh
passing move we don't have an
interesting what what is white supposed
to do here christian well that's the
thing and actually this is probably what
he has to do something along the lines
of look to be one actually
but i told you there's no uh good
looking moves right that is true i
understand that there's a b4 a natural
move no no right what is the top engine
move don't tell me
b4 yes b4
the second best a5
the third best rook to b1
and none of those moves would have been
on my maybe exact one would be in on my
radar but a5 no be for no but then you
start looking at the position and you
don't have what piece to touch
right exactly every single move just has
a worsens your position right so what
about queen to d2 well then why did i
play queen d1 yeah does that make sense
why did you play queen d1 and actually
this worsens your position uh no because
i lose contact with the tremendous one i
can't i i can't i can't move my queen
off for the contact of f3 okay i've got
another suggestion rook on f1 to e1 so
the idea there is if it's my turn i want
to go knight b5 same thing yes queen to
e8 and this is key this idea of queen to
v8 followed by queen to h5 is key and if
i go knight b5 no queen g6 knight b5
queen g6 is just mate
the game is over you're right you're
absolutely right it sure is queen g6
forgot about that one
well
and you think about queen 28 as
potentially being a difficult move to
find but
then you think about how do you get to
the white king
is a big square the moment you see queen
e8 everything falls into play you have
to play it's like a link in a chain it's
a lick and a chain that's a very
important like you don't go into this
variation if you don't see queen eight
because you don't know what your next
move is and you're down a piece the
moment you see queen e8 queen g6 you
think oh my god that's actually just
made exactly and that's where you got
the inspiration to play this is
absolutely fantastic
truly it's it's what we would call the
intuitive sacrifice karissa's just
sensing there's some opportunity there
if she's
if she's calculated anything everything
mazel tov but i think she's just
realizing that white's pieces are kind
of contorted misplaced and it's not so
easy one more look uh kill me once again
rook e1
yeah absolutely queen with pleasure says
alejandro uh take the knight uh take and
let me follow up with i don't know
knight d5 so it's also just me queen g6
knight f3 but i think bishop b5 is just
mate
bishop e5 is just made h1 i can even
take on h3 immediately i think
take on h3 i have
by the way there's no palace guards
there's nothing there's like nothing on
the king side right
you know like i feel like my rook on a1
my bishop on c4 have all been uh closed
off and lost that's just mate ugh
it's so easy to get mated here it's just
amazing
geez louise guys yes this is a fantastic
game chris doing something brilliant
truly another guy that's thinking i want
my brilliancy prize there's no surprise
here
kaidanov bishop takes h6 let's go let's
see
let's see the senior the seniors bishop
takes h6 played and they're going down
this variation
f2 rook f2 on the board will
will grisha play the move rook f1
forcing black to find this
counter-intuitive bishop c5 well he will
find it
thanks for watching
away from finding it then i think it's
just too forced not defined of course
okay
is there anything to be said for the
rook left rook h3 is an oh rook no rook
sheet two i can i will take on g2 let's
take on two that stops queen g7 well you
know what the problem why didn't i start
with row cage
queen g6 king h8 then i go rook h3 okay
okay so it takes
we're gonna start with queen g6
king has to go back
h3 but don't i have time to get my queen
to age seven now queen two you got me
nice
nice you still have i just have a
perpetual but i don't know do you have
the perpetual because i have rook coming
back to yeah i don't have anything oops
so i'm sure you still have the perpetual
so hold on so it was
uh pardon me king queen rook h3 rook g2
you gotta move the king
rook h3 rook g2 and that's actually the
reason why you took on f2 not because
you take a pawn but rather that you have
to defend the chief but also because you
take a pogba and you take them out
uh but right
you hear the whispering it's uh
think chess whisperer
so what if you play it slowly with rook
f1 ah but you have bishop to g5 no no
after rook h3 rotates g2
h3 we're throwing rook g3 so rook takes
g2 we think is now rook f1 just try to
improve the position okay rook f1 it
also prevents queen f8 i think true
exactly yes how is the end game after
bishop to g5 and is that
first of all do i have anything
really to
panic no
i think i can calmly
kindly but it's still still kind of
rages on right queen h5 oh but this rook
is having move again right back
again yeah that was the defense that i i
enjoyed from afar that's a potential
blind spot right there right no i think
it's too much right yeah yeah and one
too much and once again uh the main move
was rook f1 bishop c5
and the engine was recommending a
perpetual just a perpetual yes at that
point it does seem like uh and by the
way queen takes h6 king g8 is on the
board let's say
uh queen g6 first rook to f1
and yes after a bishop to c5 and by the
way the engine at the beginning is
saying plus 1.5 and then only once you
get to this position it starts
understanding that after a bishop to c5
you don't have anything better about the
perpetual
what is that called by the way when the
the when the computer
has
what christian christian is
describing as a glitch you're saying
play good play good play good draw
you're you're referring to the horizon
effect okay uh where an engine can only
see so far in advance yeah uh and
sometimes it misses that at the end
there's a perpetual or something so it
gets to the position and it reevaluates
evaluates it it happens rarely with
modern engines it was something more
common
edges like 15 years ago right but you
still see it once once every blue moon
you do see it and this is what lila was
doing at the beginning when it first uh
came on the market it was having a very
narrow let's say horizon
very narrow
sometimes there was a negative horizon
uh queen g6 check uh once again uh king
h8 is basically bars right everything
else is
uh losing perhaps we're just going to
british repetition yes
yes it was we got excited about this
game but no queen to g3 was but i think
you throw in rook f1 right
oh you can if i mean if you find bishop
c5 good for you right right it's not in
the uh
obvious move right you're expecting the
guy might play queen f8 or something
else that looks reasonable but loses
in fact bishop c5 is brought his box uh
just checking in on the other games let
me just go around the horn very quickly
uh larry christensen versus igor
uh i like black bear bishops i don't
think compensates for the huge advantage
of space okay f5
coming i can see somebody making an
argument for white and i would buy it
but
instinct is i prefer black yeah it's
just easier to play it looks like to me
quickly as we just go around just to go
back to that game which maybe we can see
it uh on your board yesterday there was
a very nice moment earlier on so let's
go back the knight was still on f5
there were two connected nights
the superfluous knight
right here at this point i take c7 it's
a very easy move to make but
a very nice move and i think a move that
would have created some serious problems
for a black would be g4
just simply develop like that
get the bishop to g2 and then g5
you don't see this type of pattern very
often but
it sometimes happens and then probably
you're going to cast along
it feels like an opportunity alien trust
me it's
like an opportunity okay it wasn't
giving a decisive advantage or anything
of that nature it was like 0.3 but still
it feels like it creates more problems i
like it i like it christian that
that feels like a good idea a bishop
coming to g2 and like you say uh
probably even a quick long castles this
is the game between shabala
and a copian a copian
really starting with a a dreadful loss
yeah especially because preparation was
so great yeah uh he's now with the black
pieces but this this looks totally lost
for white no
totally lost for white wow
how did that what how dare you
explain
discuss uh
totally lost that you have on the queen
side is bad it's magical bad
and you have to have some sort of
initiative to compensate for that and
usually it's the pair of bishops well i
want to put the knight on d4 i don't
want to put the green on d4 right it
just feels that compared to one of the
normal versions of this structure nimzo
indian kind of indian all of white's
pieces little discombobulate they're in
the wrong spots right the bishop on f1
the bishop on g3 this knight on d2
should be on d5 or f5 or clear something
abstractive but it's nowhere near there
um
i
think it's
closer to
slightly worse for for white break the
tie first christian
well
that's uh
an interesting one so remind me the
question because
you guys are
it's a double pawns on c4 and c3 it's
unlike a nimzo indian the shabbat game
where yeah where
his pieces are wrongly placed
and
alejandro says winning winning advantage
black and i think that's a little bit
over the top
for me as well we're asking the engine
what does the engine say
all right
all right give you the engines turn it
off i'm not relying on christian
breaking this turning it on
ah okay
minus one it's not that bad
you win
so you got the better of me on that one
but a slide right we're on the same
ballpark between a very strong advantage
for what for black i don't think we we
are arguing that i thought it was a
slightly worse
yeah something but it's black that's in
the driver's seat clear clear
again with a great opening thanks for
breaking the tie christian really you
you're our deuce in the hole you put me
on the spot you caught me off guard in
that particular moment because i was
watching this game
i was watching the game between andrew
hung and bellagio because andrew was on
100 accuracy at this point
he played bishop to f3 yeah queen to f5
and now he's thinking finally his first
thing nevertheless he has a decisive
advantage
2.7 right now after the move which makes
a lot of sense once again the main plan
in the position is to find an avenue for
the king to hide right on d1 not perf
perfectly placed because you have some
problems on the light squares so you
have to find a way to get it to c1 where
it's going to be in a much better
position the way to do that is with the
move c6 and we said also at the
beginning of all this melee that if your
pawn gets to c7 you're going to be in
deep trouble with the black pieces so c6
makes a lot of sense it's a very
practical decision not only that but
you're also getting ready to play the
move rook to c5
with the tempo on the queen get ready to
shift away with the king on c1 no move
has been played so far c6 big moment
right now you can start with b4 as well
it does seem like once again his
preparation gave him a winning advantage
out of the opening absolutely impressive
c5 but i love the move scene oh
to c5
i just wanted to
complete my horns
with the seniors nick defermion got
bailed out essentially igor had a very
nice position out of the opening after
the move bishop d2 we love the move
queen h5
and we thought clear advantage black
when igor played the move queen to c5 he
really took his foot off the gas the
problem is the king
and when the queen trade really helped
white's cause whereas queen to h5 with
the idea of castles and knight d7 looks
like black had a very nice advantage
after queen c5 things really
tempered
especially
nick
traded off the pieces and has got a
position now after a4 where i think
a draw is by far the most unlikely
result yeah i don't think we're coming
back to this game
continuing with uh joe benjamin and
dimitri well dimitri's got a little
wedgie going on here
that's all i can really say i think
black's
looks close to equal here yeah it must
be
yeah i've seen a lot of these positions
even
karla nakamura
rajaboff they've been playing these
variations as black and making a draw uh
does it seems completely fine to me yeah
let's do the same thing this time for uh
the
juniors let's jump to the game of
carissa for just a moment oh my
god goodness wait a minute no that's not
the game
yeah and we do see king h1 play queen
eight immediately bishop takes the queen
e8 she did it of course she found it
immediately
immediately and
she spent no time on queen eight yeah
wow so bishop takes d4 how does this
continue pawn takes d4 is necessary can
i throw in just queen
h5 she's thinking about it
and i don't blame her what is wrong with
bishop
queen h5 looks
bishop takes h3 and
goodness
uh
crickets and
crickets on set but i can help you guys
please h5 is very tempting but not the
best basically
um because
your
surprisingly and counterintuitively
you're putting the queen on a bad square
so after queen h5 i'm going to go king
h2 and now after you take on d4 yes now
i have knight to e2
i sacrifice my piece this way and after
you take on it i take back with the
queen and i create an immediate threat
so you have to lose another tempi
and this seems to be
still better for black but i'm getting
close to equalizing or finding some sort
of a battle couple
don't take the knight what happens if
bishop h3 here
well i've got 99 knight j-3 bishop e5
and i've got knight h oh knight h3 yeah
i think c3 what's happening where's the
mate no no no no no no we're crying
we're crying we're crying oh my oh my
so as tempting as queen h5 is right but
it's actually the wrong move right so
what did you just take exactly i think
that's the move that carissa is going to
do i think we looked at this where there
was like we had played rook a3 or rook
b1 i don't know this is such a sad
position because bishop takes h3 is
coming also i mean everything opens up
no the deflection two bishops
cutting the board in half it's not
looking great but karissa is correctly
taking her time here because
if she thinks she sees a win with queen
h5 she's going to play it it's tempting
it is very tempting very tempting i'm
actually surprised that's wrong to be
honest i know i mean i know we have an
engine and stuff but i'm a little
surprised that queen high doesn't win
well
and for that matter could i also ask
yeah well she'll say h3 i guess you just
take
and somehow you search well i'm
threatening me you have to excuse me
where
bishop takes you right away immediately
yeah not to take on d4 not to go queen
h5 but i was threatening so if i take
on h5
queen h
oh bishop e6 thank you yeah actually
that clears the cobwebs
truly truly okay but uh carissa if she
all right let's predict it does she play
queen h5 or she takes on d4 i think
she'll take on
d4 i think she'll realize that any line
that allows bishop e6 as a possible
defensive is a no-no
don't even go down that road but at the
same time it's a bit counterintuitive
that you don't want to see the king on
h2 even though the bishop comes on e5 we
check right right that's tempting right
to see another check coming on the board
yeah in this position just from a
psychological point of view
um i think she's going to go for queen
h5 i'm going to
go for that one
yeah
big big big big moment right wow yes
seriously
and she knows it yeah and that's one of
um
the factors whenever you're trying to
assess whether a player is in shape or
not if they spot and stop at the
critical moments yeah i think that's a
very good factor of analysis by the way
guys
it's not inspiration i don't even know
what it is but in this position where
you know the queen gets induced to h5
tricked if you will to h5
knight on c3 to e2
how
how crazy would it be to play bishop e5
check and just
another positional piece sacrifice just
right so like just chill like bishop d7
and say what did you mean rook f4 i'm
actually kind of well rook f4 was the
move i wanted yeah but it's not you
can't play rook f4 because he takes h5
yes exactly
but okay okay this is this is exciting
stuff close to me take on d4 come on uh
carissa i mean we're getting the gold
coins okay come on guys uh
reach for the pockets no she did it she
played h5 i'm telling you it's that
bishop p5 is so tempting it's so
tempting it's hard not to play queen h5
right
i mean you're looking at bishop h3
you're seeing double check mates
forcing the move king h2 is bad
incredible
like that is
i mean that is so counter produ counter
intuitive and
wow that doesn't say that david brosky
right now is out of the woods because no
i mean your king is still in shambles
right right i'm still getting my piece
back right in all the variations yeah
you're mentioning united state too i
can't just capture and not gonna be i'm
not gonna be worse i think right
actually why am i not better
no i'd say two takes no you are better
you are slightly better yes bishop e5
and now i have to go f4
yeah no choice because give up right but
if i take if i take with the rook you
cannot take my queen correct because the
rook f2 king h1 is a beautiful mate ah
double check that's media that's a
double check very nice
okay so i have bishop so i have to take
and go king h1
which means right here
we have to take on f4 take on f4 king h1
advantage black
but not the translating patterns that
he's not coming to thanksgiving dinner
he's not coming to christmas dinner
no easter no no orthodox
church that's it
and this is something that david brosky
is going to be super happy to see on the
board an end game right
viciously attacked seriously all of your
opponent's pieces to see a simplified
endgame thank you very much right
wow wow okay we have to update so many
boards this is a scintillating game but
we we have to move away from it there's
so much stuff going on where would you
like us to go we have to update that
game a wonderly and against christopher
you haven't do it in so long uh we left
it in a position that we actually liked
i liked uh a wonderliang's position a
lot i thought he was going to castle he
played the move queen c2
kind of
interesting move queen c2 queen g6
christopher
he was kind of happy to see this whoa
whoa whoa whoa you're giving up f2
why is he giving up f2 f2 is the base
you can't even start hold on there is c6
though c6 is hanging oh he's got this
idea
g6 is hanging all right what if
this is this is hacking there's a lot of
happenings g6 bishop ish
a lot of hacking who is calculated best
i guess you have to go rook back to
f7
i guess you don't really want to i don't
want this g7 right i don't mind losing
h5 but i i do mind losing g7 yeah and i
might just end up taking it but it looks
like a lot of vacuuming just go maybe
maybe advantage white a little bit but a
lot of vacuuming taking place here
christian
oh absolutely yes yes a lot of vacuuming
in that one by the way andrew did find
the move c6
c6 c6 is on the board
he's just playing the best moves the
best plans he knows the positions very
well after his theory ends he's just in
great shape right now rook to c8 uh was
played c7 is an option makes a lot of
sense to do that bishop to b4 seems to
be giving a white a tremendous advantage
uh followed by after the ages bishop to
e7 and actually exchange the minor
pieces and that's just going to lead
to
a major piece and game with a lot of
extra points for white you don't want to
see that so
it does seem that after rook ac80 has a
lot of avenues for an advantage now
also brandon jacobson seems to
be tightening the screws in this one
against abhimanyu mishra because i'm
starting to get worried about young
abimani's position this night landed on
d6 very nicely placed you're still a
piece down i know you're going to
recapture probably the bishop on e3
probably immediately like this but with
the knight on d6 the bat bishop on b7 a
lot of things starting to attack it and
also all of my pieces are ready to
potentially transfer on the king's side
with devastating consequences imagine a
rook landing on g3 followed by a knight
coming back to f5 that's bad news for
black so absolutely we have this
position
from a practical perspective i'm
starting to be worried about my pick to
win the event i'll be money because
brandon jacobson right now is feeling it
and he has a much better position what
do you guys think looks good
yeah seriously i loved your explanation
there the rook transferring to g3 with
knight f5 very coordinated attack i
wanted to look quickly at the
bank bank thank you depending on the
side of the world
pedro so many people call it the volga
gambit yeah i think in the very very old
days i used to call it the benko pal
revolutionized the whole line it is it's
a justified uh it's a justified name
change but i feel it's also very region
dependent when i actually yeah when i
ask any russian player about the bangkok
i mean they're like what on earth is the
benko gambit
they say the volga gambit okay
okay well let's take a look at what
happened we still call it the leningrad
dutch too right right even though
leningrad doesn't exist
like what queen c4 and uh we see our
queen trade knight b6 uh
pedro espinosa our u.s junior open
winner he's coming into this tournament
with a lowly expert's rating and all of
these top masters he's allowed this
knight b6 and you were explaining to us
that uh
it's in the it's in the end game that
the power that the banco gambit really
excels how is
how's it going the dream the dream you
got your palm back and you maintained
all the structures still intact yeah the
structural integrity of the banco
and this is uh pedro uh espinoza
uh from new york 18 years old welcome
welcome welcome to st louis uh pedro but
boy i really hope you you did your
homework because you're going up against
the wolves here a bit of a upset for him
yesterday because we felt he played such
a nice game he was so deserving of a
draw of a draw right absolutely just
wasn't able to hold on to it exactly uh
but in this game i feel
that he's just worse in this end game
right
uh but one of the things that maybe he
can hold out for is like some kind of uh
business where
he goes like b3
i think it's not i don't know i mean i'm
struggling here it's advantage black
black right all day every day maybe even
f7 f5 will will and that's such a
typical break in this position f5 you
break open the structure the d5 pawn
becomes quite vulnerable don't forget
that you really do have to deal with a
move like c4 or
even rook b7 instead of knight b6 just
winning a pawn because of the background
problems exactly uh advantage black no
avengers black for sure for sure uh
charissa just checking in after king h2
on the board don't worry about that that
was the pedro game and this is
uh
c8 well this is it this is the moment
that andrew's been waiting for once he
plays rook c5 as christian's been
mentioning
then you make room for the king and once
that king exits
that is a hero
all right like it's bringing home uh the
the point that that pawn the the beauty
on c6 is what it's all about and finally
i think it's the ladies turn to just go
around the horn briefly yeah we have a
lot of news here or we have a lot of new
moves we can update that one okay so for
for sure
where are we
alice easily against ellen wang so ellen
didn't find
any way outside of the tactical problems
that we saw so she actually
came up with a pretty creative solution
in exchange she gave up an exchange but
for a pawn and some light squares on the
king side i think
okay
i don't think it's four
i don't think it's quite enough for the
exchange but it's it's close yeah
a moment ago just before the movement if
you did get in the knife knight c5 yeah
you did get an a5 we could be talking
advantage black but after the move b4
we're up to date with the players again
you feel that it's not enough for the
exchange but it's awfully close it's
awfully close you do have a strong pawn
on d4 you're going to have to defend it
with e5 with that so no question so
let's just do it just do it and
eventually you want to get some light
square play you can think on a great day
you go queen e6 knight f6 queen e6 f5
you start got rolling these pawns of
course these tactical problems you're
gonna have to watch out for while you do
that uh well i'm
i'm
pausing just because i see a double
okay if i can get a second passion
that's a good it's a good question uh
what do you think bishop f4
what do you do against uh knight f3
check i don't see bishop what bishop f4
knight c4 helps me with though
exactly i was just trying to get the
bits out nope that doesn't help me much
okay
so knight e5
uh christian
weigh in on the alice lee
versus ellen wang we just stopped
ourselves from jumping to other games
because we saw that ellen has this
opportunity for knight e5
and we're thinking so what if i go
bishop four
yeah that was what we were thinking
knight takes c4 that's bond number two
i'm still in exchange up though exchange
for two pawns right
so what if i go to rook c1 roxy one rook
ac one
rook ac i'm assuming we defended
um i don't have any trickies with rook
takes c4
remember she won her first game why not
right right and she's up against a
pre-tournament favorite
she's bringing it look at this they
don't hunt i think right wow i like this
with knight e5
and this almost feels like she's ready
to make a move which is weird
yeah i think she had anticipated when
she played the move before i think she
had anticipated 95 but uh not
that quick to respond uh we'll keep an
eye on
this one
by the way guys yes
um
it seems alice is just completely
winning completely winning yeah after
simple or not so simple rook to d1
rook rook d1
david one
stepping away from knight f3 makes sense
at the same time indirectly defending
the pawn on c4 because if you do take on
c4 or rook takes d4 or queen takes d4
your attack is over correct yeah so then
the spin on the d-file is really
annoying rook d-1 is a very strong move
day one is huge
and probably the only move by the way
after 95 you don't find rook to d1 uh
bishop to f4 the move that we uh offered
after knight takes e4 it is black who is
playing for a week that's what we felt
that's what we thought by the way the
move rook
is like
nicely
camouflaged and it's one of those that
as soon as you put it on the board
you're like right of course of course
all the problems you said knight f3 you
hit the pawn on d4 and it's advantage
alice
yeah i i agree
yeah okay all right we'll see if she
comes up with it let's keep walking
jennifer you again we think that the
jennifer you uh
um italia
cervantes game is really just
even two even two even zoe what's
happening with zoey
i don't think we've looked at this game
zoey tank against uh anne-marie vella i
think
uh
knight c5 queen e3 i'm look i'm
eyeballing queen h4
playing hall
yup
but it's actually the game zoe tang if
we can see the players zoe and anna
marie actually try to pick up on their
yeah they're actually the
they're actually on this shot they're on
the bottom
far end yeah well i'm looking at queen
h4 like give me mates
i'll give you a knight f3 though
and i was going to take a ball
i'm missing something
my bishop is hanging okay i'm not
missing anything
oh that means no
oh yeah okay well then i may have to
take the pawn directly bishop takes e4
can you
that's my question okay i go knight b5
okay this is bishop d5 i guess i have to
block lock d-file that was why i wanted
queen h4 you know like getting off the
getting off the um
d file all right this doesn't seem so
clear what if bishop takes e4 i go
b4 i'm a little more direct okay
that's definitely a great challenge
and
now i'm really really looking at queen h
well what else do i do
queen
h4 gift middle checkmate
knight f3 bishop f3 that's clear
i'm safe
i don't want to hang my pieces man
i'm channeling my inner carissa
g3 here in knight f3
so how many pieces have i hung now
nothing yet but i feel that too much is
in the air no
uh
again uh
help me out here i need some help yes
sir
am i am i channeling my inner carissa
badly no you're over it's okay
forget about it yes these juniors are
having an impact right right when we see
their games so they're just throwing
pieces around i i get i feel like i got
to do the same
i don't want to alarm you but karissa is
down to her last nine minutes and 20
moves
after kingdom h2 okay
which surprises me because
do you have any other ideas except
taking on d4 you could take on h3 first
but
we that wouldn't be good news for her
right because taking on h3 is not a
great move
uh remind us why just uh just take back
uh let me sorry i'm in the wrong um
you can take it because we're worth the
other section okay so hold on uh
bishop takes h3 let's take a takes h3 oh
this was the bishop e6 business no no no
no this is different okay g1
rook to g1 well you are threatening
knight to bishop to e5 which is almost
of course of course of course rook to g1
oh have to cover so the way the recovery
is bishop
g3 rook g3 let me take
one piece that's okay let's take you
take one piece now can we do anything
with this uh alejandro
rook f4 okay four maybe even like
the thing is i don't even know what rook
g8 does look for d4 rook f4d4 that's a
problem that's a problem so i think holy
smokes uh
she cannot take on h3 but she's
definitely looking after i do this
there's a bishop e6
we've been here we've done this it
doesn't work once again there is a
psychological dilemma that she's facing
right now simplify the position allow
the simplification which is more or less
forced after taking on d4 in 92 the
variation that we discussed initially
take on e2 and then bishop to e5 we saw
this you see f4 and you see the ensuing
end game man triple zeros how easy it is
to do this and to go for this
psychologically that is the question
right and then you see bishop takes h3
you know that you're not losing
but it's a material imbalance that might
not favor
your position so do you go for that with
only 10 minutes on the clock right now
right now actually down to her last
seven i think i simply
no i'm sorry but i i pull the parachute
at a certain moment i kind of look
forward
it's too late come on chris it's too
late don't go for bishop takes h3 right
now it's not the practical decision
truly there's nothing practical about
having seven minutes and 30 seconds for
20.
but fortunately this is not the
candidates and the players do get their
30-second bonuses uh again just to
finish off a wonder i think we
we said what uh what we thought was a
better
well it looks like a draw wow
yeah they've really been
again it's like the vacuum right
by the way guys please it seems uh like
alice did not find the move rook to d1
oh she played
the bishop f4 which we thought it was
initially recommended
but after knight takes e4 queen to c6
just bishop takes f4 and it is black
please please you gotta take that you
gotta knock it with the knight you have
to take the knight but then i have
bishop d2 bishop c3
that's advantage black we know that for
sure right yeah yeah two pawns i'm going
to be able to slowly slowly push them
you i don't have any weaknesses to worry
about and you don't have any penetration
files for your rooks exactly you're in
trouble yeah exactly i agree she did not
find rook to d1 she right now is in deep
trouble but one player that is
well just killing her opponent right now
that is maurice suzuki because i mean
you guys mentioned this position a while
ago and it was minus six it's still
minus six and there's absolutely no hope
for white this is the position keep the
queens on the board don't exchange them
play the move queen to d4 c4 c3 is
coming you have to deal with that
you you're tied up i feel physical
completely tied up uh when i see this
move queen d4 exactly exactly like what
do you do go king h1 yeah
c4
you're still not you're not stopping my
seatbelt
and then my bishop is defending me too
yeah yeah
it's so horrible yeah
but she could have finished the game
right with rook takes d2 we didn't miss
anything there
uh at what point uh a few moves a few
moves back if we could go to christian's
board yes
and yeah queenie yes yes yes yes
was was great yes rook to d2 sometimes
sometimes we see something queen f3 rook
d2 queen f3 yeah that's what we said
that was it that was it was nice yeah
yeah yeah yeah that was right and uh
thank you uh to everybody who is
enjoying the show and
we like to reach out to our audience as
much as we possibly can i apologize that
we can't get to all your questions but
we do have some social media and join us
on our conversation we're on youtube
we're on twitch and the one everybody
wants to know
why he is yasser not playing instead of
commentating well and the correct answer
is
you guys wouldn't miss my commentary
no in truth really i really i feel uh
like i kind of hung up my spurs
i so much enjoy uh watching
uh my colleagues
the seniors play i really enjoy watching
the juniors
coming
and playing a competition is a
completely different mindset
and you know you've got to come well
prepared uh do your homework and you've
got to make a lot of life choice
sacrifices really to to be a player even
even at this level i mean these guys are
not going to give you anything and in
fact they're going to try to kill you
so uh if i'm not willing to to do a
minimum
of you know my openings and stuff like
that i think
have you have you ever heard of the
chicken chess club yeah
i think there were others before me but
yeah i definitely joined the chicken
club there you go uh i have one more
explanation thank you cochran for
the very salient but yes right it gets
more salient if you offer 200 000
i think you're not playing because you
weren't brief on the increase in the
price fund yeah before
but right now 75 thousand dollars the
truth
shall
shine
uh i just wanted to say brandon by the
way knight takes me seven
why did he voluntarily trade all of the
pieces i think he just kind of
gave up on
i thought he was doing
some attacking business yeah he's still
better but this is not us
knight takes we were looking at rook g3
yeah rook g3 was very compelling in
knight f5 right wow yeah but he played
and he just quickly traded everything
and just
continues okay maybe he has an edge he
finally has an etch but
but how palpable type of vector serious
is it like okay i take you take i've
moved my rook i get it i get it i i mean
i'm worse but
give me a chance to get my piece back
into play and maybe i'll salvage
something okay you might not sorry more
social media yeah we have more social
media questions here for us let's take a
look at what our producers have selected
as the commentators asked the best line
against the banco maybe i'm wrong but i
think it's busted
well
i'll tell you guys
i mean you know not even making a
donation to the panel nobody's asking
straight up what up what up about the
bingo well the banker gambit i think the
word let me put it on the board yeah we
can use yasser's board for this one okay
d4 knight f6 c4
okay c5 i'll get there the conventional
way right yeah okay takes ace you think
this is the best way i think that if you
want to refute the actual gambit you you
have to accept it and i will help sign
it i think b takes a6 is okay but i i
actually do believe e3 is more dangerous
than okay he takes a6 so
he's looking for the bust there's a lot
of lines here i mean black obviously has
tried g6 a lot of times the main lights
nowadays front a takes b5 okay uh bishop
takes b5 okay queen a5 check knight c3
yeah bishop b7
yep and here the old line was to play
bishop d2 and people figured out this is
actually not very dangerous okay uh and
people started to realize that both the
move e4 and the move knight e2 were
actually very dangerous moves wow really
yeah you take on e4 you've got an ige
too and it's a it's a development thing
it's a development thing right the
knight can retreat to d6 but it's on d6
it's kind of in the way of and this
setup in particular even though it's not
busted it's not refuted you can't play
this as black it's pretty unpleasant uh
i i actually lost it wong
uh with the black pieces on this on this
variation and ever since i felt it was
it was unpleasant okay
and by the way where did you play uh
when you we actually played a university
match uh university of texas of dallas
against ningbo university we played over
in beijing china back now 2008.
international uh competitions guys
yes not the persian bubble but
carissa right now is down to her last 1
minute and 45 seconds
let's take a look at her clock right now
can somebody wake her up
so she did take on d4 that was the right
decision very good but now after 92 take
on it to queen to e2 still she has to go
and accept that end game will she do
that bishop e5 check bishop to e5
followed by f4 i mean you know we've
been loud in carissa for for good
reasons but david is finding only all
the good moves he's fighting although
he's finding them quickly right putting
the pressure on her on his a lot of
pressure right exactly i like it
so i mean shout out 19 moves to go for
karissa with only one got a minute
yeah she's she looked at the clock like
maybe i should make a move
but why is queen h4 i mean i i could
easily convince myself that bishop e5
check f4 would get me into triple zeros
i therefore precisely why not go queen
h4 but queen h4 was the wrong decision
and actually would have given white
quite a significant advantage because
after f4
i'm just going to
force the trade of the rooks rook takes
a 4. i got the other broken and then
king to h1 and your light square bishop
doesn't actually have great squares and
this bishop on c4 finally relevant
exactly yeah so she fights great great
removed by karisa
bishop b5 we also expect this to be
played quickly i think king h1 is just a
bad move and king g2 straight up loses
to bishop takes h3 so
you have to play f4 exactly yes for
david not much choice we talked about
charis's time one minute that it must
mean that david has all the time in the
world 54 minutes wow
yeah that's a lot of time that is a lot
of time but he's playing fast f4 there
we go and look at him go he's just but
that checkmate that you pointed out
alejandro from before that's such a
beauty we got to show it to everyone
again
we're expecting rook takes f4 right now
right here it's also the original
actually and it's the only deal as well
and then we're offering the queen and
that would be the worst thing you've
ever done as it's
checkmate in two double check
by the bishop and the rook there's
nowhere else to go you've got to go back
and rook h2 is a beautiful smothered
mate so we are expecting rook takes f4
in that uh
and after a bishop takes a four king to
h1
and no
no
wait a minute wait what is that she just
down a piece now what oh okay she has
queenie
take oh look at her
what a tricky move tricky girl
okay sorry so let's go back so she has
played bishop take something that we
stopped ourselves from doing because we
were fearful that rook takes f4 would
just cost
uh carissa a piece perhaps the best move
in the position but rook takes f4
queenie fine he keeps it spicy but
brodsky up to
task slightly instantly king h1 and this
i don't like the fact that karissa is
taking so long to make her moves jacob
is okay but
all of her time no
and she's just played queen h4 by the
way she did it who who did we see it was
jeffrey jeffrey
america
bang bang bang and jeffrey leisurely
presses the clock loses on time so this
is a different approach by carissa
keeping the queens on the board
which is totally double-edged it's not
completely clear that this favors black
because the white the black king also
has some issues yeah
it might be
a question about the traffic right on
the g file
um we could we could play
conventionally with queen f2
but it actually looks dangerous if i
play queen f2 i can't trade right i
don't i don't have enough time to trade
you you'll end up losing something
something on the f5
so queen f2 probably is going to force
queen
backwards queen what g5
i don't know backwards backwards
we're back uh help us out uh christian
where we're we're getting you guys on
there are are on the right track yeah
queen to f2 you cannot
exchange you have to go queen g5 queen
g5 which is in fact probably the only
move in the position to maintain the
balance and now i'm going to continue
hunting your coin with queen g2
queen g
but now i can now i can trade the queens
if i felt like it you can if you want to
isn't this like finally you can develop
too like bishop d7 there was this yeah
right it was his candidate's game where
the bishop stayed upstairs
and this one has finished we kind of
leveled it around right it was that
perpetual they they did play the move
rook f1
did find the move bishop c5
on a draw draw was agreed a little bit
of a sizzle in what started out blazing
hot yeah queen g3 was wrong i loved that
move f2 f3 i think max
dodged the bullet i really defense
though yeah yeah i really do i think he
dodged the bill by the way i think
that's the first result
of this round two of all 15 games it was
amazing i mean no i mean people came
here to play yeah
they got their knives their swords their
battle axes like
no no friendlies around here right yeah
it's it's already like two and a half
hours into the round we have zero
results right the candidates we had
three results one game like one and
seven minutes yeah yeah you wanted seven
minutes i remember that mepo versus naca
right yep okay uh okay we're going to
keep our eye on the correctness again
check the andrew hong game please check
the angel game take it away he's just
playing every single best movie in the
position
wow
absolutely scintillating performance
right now by andrew huang
bishop to b4 you remember i was saying
was the best movie in the position rook
to e8
trade trade and now rook to e5
wow
absolutely no more problems
extra pawn
no more compensation
i have all the right pieces on the right
squares right now this is over this is
close to being over put the pawn on c7
and if we can slap the bishop i don't
know on d6 yeah no i mean c7
bishop d6 bishop very close right behind
i mean
ambition d693 is that clear
i didn't think you were doing anything
it's one tickle it's one check and
that's it and that's it you're gonna
look prettier than i have g1 no this is
over yeah maybe actually wow uh i i
thought it was one check no
showing showing the business here two
whites two excellent preparations
superb super player i mean uh different
level right yeah you i was watching the
k well obviously i was calling the
candidates but
uh one result so far this one between
gregory and maxim as both players have
drawn their first two rounds but i
wanted to say that one of the things
about the candidates i was really
looking forward to with some great
novelties we saw some good stuff knight
h4 by fabi really was maybe one of the
very very highlights of the uh prep
but andrew is stealing everybody's
thunder whatever
i forget about fabi look at andrew hogg
and his crap
let's play career
because uh quinto f2 was played and
queen did not play the number five g5
was the answer so came quickly too queen
to h5 now
this might not be the most precise way
for karissa
well you can't talk precision when you
only have one minute on your clock and
queen
still hunting that queen
you got i mean it's the same issue right
you don't have another movie queen h4
you have to go queen h4 now
a draw we were just talking about
results and suddenly it could it could
open up
uh
by the way if i was in david's shoes i'd
be playing queen f2 and saying let's get
out of here yeah it's funny the only
reason you don't play queen f2 and get
out of here is because of the time
situation right karissa's put herself in
such a bad spot true that you start
thinking man how do i take advantage of
that but on the other hand yeah i've
been under pressure the entire game it
almost feels like a relief that i'm
escaping with half a point truly truly i
it really does uh david is actually guys
why don't you just stop and think and
may you try to find something better
well that's what we're saying
should he play rook f2 maybe not here
but after queen to f2 that queen to h5
was not the right move right by carissa
we expected between g5
he had a golden opportunity to take the
advantage with the move queen to g2 at
that point queen g what after after
queen h5 queen g2 my plan is very
straightforward queen i want to go rook
to f3
rook the other one from a to f1
and you don't have a very clear way to
defend against that i'm not so clear
what you're saying christian wait do i
have to into h5 let's get back to that
position okay
g2 instead of queen to f3
queen to g2 instead of g2 instead of
queen f3 okay you're throwing your rook
takes off four and clearly i don't think
you're in time so bishop d7 has to be
played there's a mate
made on g8 thanks to the bishop i'm
threatening rook takes so i'm not in
time after bishop d7 bishop d7 now i go
rook to f3 rook to f3
okay i see that i'm the one setting up
the tempo right now it's you're the one
that has to find the precise defense you
can i can't defend twice because of the
same problem exactly if you go to six
that's kind of hilarious that that's a
big problem that uh i can't maintain the
bishop on f4 because there is that same
checkmate on g8 that we mentioned
earlier
interesting and especially with such a
low time situation for carissa wow
that's a big practical question that
david could pose at at this particular
moment
exactly
queen g2 queen f2 queen h5 queen g2 and
the point being that queen to h5 is not
the most precise move because you're not
keeping contact with the bishop on f4 or
the or the position or g2 yeah and the
other thing that i liked is that when we
retreated the queen to g5 and if you did
play the move queen g2 any queen trades
allowed me to anchor the bishop with h
take so i liked queen 35 a lot better as
well alejandro are the games what does
caught your eye i saw you had the wonder
liang yeah i see you have shabballah
yeah i wonder yeah she's going in the
draw i'm just going through every 15
games is a lot of games
uh let's take a look at one of our
marquee uh games between um
jennifer you
and natalya
uh
jennifer just
she got a rook to c5 she's got an
isolated queen pawn as well this is not
what is concerning me my concern is how
does this bishop to a4
well now that it's on a4
bothering no one
that's outside of civilization what is
bishop what's the full ship on a4 i'm
thinking if i'm white and i can go king
c3 or c8 yeah
that's good
the
advantage is definitely on the white
side here i think talia did something
completely wrong right back here
she
okay they should be three
mission b3 was okay but then trade rooks
we're gonna have to talk about this yeah
trade rooks
bring the other rook to d8 and then
bring your bishop back to d5 when it's
necessary but never on a4 but what did
she do rook to d3 bishop a4
and jennifer
i think she's just a sense of
opportunity yeah i i i do as well i like
by the way uh let me go back to the game
of
alice lee for just a second to see you
look what ellen did she parks her bishop
on c3 and it's advantage black all the
way and it's just an unpleasant position
to play with white because you have no
plan
ever and not only that this rook on b3
is not on an open file where it can
infiltrate in fact it's kind of offsides
as well and she played rook b3
voluntarily just played rook b3 which in
my opinion
in my opinion she's going to do it she's
going to sacrifice the exchange but she
maybe should have done it and then nice
way yeah i agree with that a nicer way
rook to b3 okay sorry i stole your
thunder there aleiandra i think she's i
think she's ready
you got to take over yeah yeah and go
into a queen ending upon down and just
suffer your way through uh
um
the horrors of a
of a torture yeah the thing about this
kind of endgame is is that it's
difficult to determine which one you
want to suffer in right
i'll go with the queen and then you go
with the queen end game yeah i really
would uh
what's the alternative just stay put
right
yeah i know it's not much of an ounce
it's kind of horrible but
sit there sit at the board twiddling
waiting for your opponent to go e5 e4 e3
and somehow you know smash you i don't
know uh alice i think is a active player
she's not going to want to sit back and
she probably feels that she could hold
this queen ending and
maybe she will uh challenge and uh
christian
what's caught your eye well i'm
wondering
whether rochelle is getting any chances
in this game against uh sophie maurice
suzuki
because sophie morris decided to
exchange the queens we were saying don't
exchange the quiz queen keep the queens
on the board set up the pin
c4 c3 resignation right nothing to do
against that
she decided to take take take but now at
least white is getting something some
chances i understand bishop to d4 was a
big threat right you have to defend
against that but there's only one way to
defend against that and you have to see
it you have to calculate it and that is
e5 take on e5 and i'm not going to take
back i understand you're going to take
back on e5 then still bishop d4 is
coming nothing changes in the position
but what i'm doing is trying to create
my own counter play and she does that
right rochelle does that she plays the
move d6 now i'm only two squares away
from promotion so you have to start
paying attention exactly e4 seems to be
the best move in the position not and
that's by the way that was been played
good move good move uh by sophie and
after d7 you have to give this check
force the king to h1 because if you go
to f1 knight takes h2n unfortunately
there's another check right
and that's not possible force the king
to h1 and then just simply go back
still winning but she's making her life
a bit more difficult than it should have
been okay this is what i'm seeing in
this game and uh still
karissa still playing this position they
haven't repeated yet david is trying to
find something right maybe maybe sensing
opportunities
and
as we get ready for our last break just
before the time control by the way i
once again want to thank the audience
for their social media questions sorry
we can't take all your questions but
indeed
how would they uh contact us alejandro
we are monitoring youtube we're
monitoring twitch and you can send us
questions as well to our twitter i think
we're going to have that up kind of soon
and remember
and we have our journalists sabina
feuscher women grand master of 2017 u.s
women's champion absolutely great
performance she had there you can send
us tweets at st louis chess club stl
chess club you have it on your screen or
hashtag usgs champs sabina will be
browsing through them she'll be
answering some herself she's a strong
very very very strong player plus core
against me
and
the ones that she thinks are most
interesting we'll share them in a group
wonderful we'll see on the other side of
the break
[Music]
how does it feel to once again be back
in st louis playing in this prestigious
event i mean it's pretty exciting like
i've never i've played a few of these
people before i've been playing it in
like such a well-known like venue and
like with all these amazing players is
definitely exciting and should be a
great experience i mean it's really
exciting because i grew up watching this
event over and over through the years
and i was always really impressed by the
players and how and how how wonderfully
smooth the tournament was ran so i'm
really glad i get to play this year as
well it feels great i mean like i
haven't been in st louis in a year i
think
um and it's always like really nice to
come here because
it's just like such a welcoming place
it's always nice to participate in the
juniors i'm really looking forward to it
this year because it's my last year
actually so hopefully i can go out with
a bang and you know
get like one really nice good memory out
of the event it's been a while since i
played like u.s juniors or u.s
championship here um i believe
last time was probably 2019
um junior is just one of the worst
tournaments of my life so
i'm hoping to make it better i don't
think i've ever played a good u.s
juniors and it's kind of funny that like
i've won a u.s champs without winning a
u.s junior so um i'm just trying to try
to like enjoy my last year here it feels
amazing especially since it's my last
time and i'm just trying to have as much
fun as i can i've been telling myself
you know i'm gonna do something
enjoyable every day even if i lose or
even if it's a bad day i'm gonna try to
do something enjoyable and just make the
most i can out of this trip and this
tournament and my experience here
uh it feels good i've been here for a
few times so it's always a pleasure
coming back it's really exciting for me
because i grew up watching this event as
well and so many of my role models have
either won this event or played in it
numerous times so yeah it's really
exciting for me to be able to follow in
their footsteps and even compete and
meet with them
oh it's a great honor to be back here of
course playing in the junior girls
championship i was here last may
and saint louis is just one of my
favorite places to be to play chess i'm
very excited i'm excited to play some
good games
i've really
been looking forward to this event
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everybody to the
championships in st louis we have the
u.s junior girls diaz jr and the us
seniors here being played for and we
have some important results yes we do as
some of the leaders have finished their
game in
the
16 years gregory kaidanov drew his game
against maxine gloogie in a fascinating
richter rouser attack in which grecia
went before the throat didn't quite get
there exactly it seemed like he had more
than the draw and uh well the sacrifice
didn't pan out but other nice results
too yeah more importantly in uh the
legend section as well igor novikov with
the black pieces drew against nick
defearman we had expected that for some
time as nothing much happened but a
totally poorly played opening by nick
deferming he was white and he got the
worst of it as igor novikov winner of
the first round continues to lead at
this moment in the seniors any victory
by the remaining players could catch him
but
nix is going to have to work on his
openings and a modern chess opening
there bring it but the biggest result so
far i believe is in the juniors andrew
hong has been playing perfect chess
excellent preparation yesterday
excellent preparation today showing good
stuff this is what we want to see from
the juniors is what we expect from
somebody that's going to win this
tournament andrew hong just excellent
chess today got his prep in played very
well after that
and balaji just didn't have a chance uh
not only that but hit the speed of his
moves was just incredible i mean he just
played
all of his prep got it in
but then followed it up by continuing uh
to put the pressure on his opponent and
he finished in style just at the very
end rookie five queen g6 bishop back to
d2 knight d5
f5 what a what a blow that was queen
rook takes knight bishop takes rook
takes pawn takes and it's all over but
the shouting uh
you're as you're a piece up in the pawns
on c7 and finally uh black had to give
it a rest uh but for andrew a 2-0 start
i wonder liang is wondering
wait a minute i'm supposed to be in the
u.s championship i'm i'm here to win
this tournament this guy's got a 2-0
lead i believe he's making a draw
today
yeah uh just wanted to double check
right we had just seen the game from the
first try guys under one minute let's
jump to that one
and it's terrible hey take it away
christian well let's let's look at the
bird's eye view because yes
you played dropping under one
all right big decision right now what's
wrong with rogue g6 rook g6 is a move
okay
thank you thank you
[Laughter]
[Music]
but the problem is this is a very
committal move okay
knight takes f4
yeah because queen of the bishop g3
actually runs into trouble
what do you think knight takes f4 knight
takes f4 yes okay what do you mean
i take
queen h5
i i apologize i didn't see that the
analysis board wasn't up let's see we're
looking at this position we've just seen
the move right g6
and our main line is knight takes f4 yes
this is our main line and we're taking
the queen you take with the knight which
is the tempo against the queen but it's
also a tempo on the rook and that
requires you to play russian three
and now i am required to recapture
because if i capture the queen then the
rook is hanging with chat yeah so we
take
and now what christian was saying like
hey guys don't forget there's a rook on
f7 so let's go let's go you can go up
because knight four is not made but it
was enough
it's embarrassing that's a royal fork so
we got to go to h8
we got to go to h8
and now a paw is here because knight f4
that's almost mate but it's not much of
a winning attempt is it because queen f3
at the very least
that's right i can't just i can i was
trying i was going to crawl around the
first rank but that's all wrong
you can check me all kinds of ways okay
and of course i can't take the bishop as
desirable as that would be queen takes
h3 as an oopsy daisy
do i have a pipette
you do i i don't see anything against it
right if you go king a cheddar just go
to rook fade as a draw right is it is it
just a drunk or can you can you nobody
you cannot you cannot no you have to you
can't you can sack them requests
yeah wait a second the queen back the
bars are attacked okay but let's go back
guys
let's go back a couple of moves guys
you're getting ahead of yourselves all
right
king h8
uh sorry so no no keep going keep going
all the way up okay all the way through
the end okay king h8 now i go knight to
f4
we thought per pet per pet yes okay okay
all right i don't have to worry about
you sacrificing the queen back and
having a better end game right right you
think it it will be a draw with proper
play what what is the purpose actually
out of curiosity
okay i got king h2
we got queen enough to check but queen
after knight g2 actually surprisingly i
think wins for white yes
probably does but let's go queen d1 i
don't know about this queen f3
it's limiting your options so you have
to be precise as black queen d1
i don't think i'm taking that pawn
actually i'm going queen d2 right okay
so that i have queen e1 whenever you go
to g3 i see yeah no this is i i i i
absolutely have to respect the threat of
knight f4 to g6 exactly so i can't
afford to
indulge my
queen takes uh c
two but let's pause ourselves for this
carissa game because
uh christian you have a special guest in
studio
absolutely yasser we are indeed with
nick the fermion nick first of all
welcome to the club you are coming here
in st louis for the first time as a
player is that correct that's correct
how does that feel to be playing at the
saint louis chess club it it's
just the most fantastic place the mecca
of chess everything's done so
professionally so nicely people are so
friendly and and all the chess
organization and i'm
very happy to be here well you almost
started with a blast yesterday with the
black pieces it definitely felt like you
have an edge at some point how did you
assess that game yesterday yes that uh
that london system's a bit solid but i
managed to get something and uh
i
at one point i had to to make a quick
breakthrough but uh i'm a little bit
rusty it's been
a few years since i played tournament
games and uh just getting back into the
swing of it now and let's speak also
about today's game you started off with
this uh very committal idea allowing
bishop takes f3 g takes f3 the doubling
of the pawns and then h4 did you come up
over the board with that idea or did you
have some ideas before it was well the
the
pawn to d4 that was stockfish's
suggestion
okay but it's
you know
when a human looks at it you say you've
got to
you really have to get something pretty
good for those double pawns and
how would you progress
and in the game i was trying to see some
uh
way to to get an interesting play but uh
igor he's really good with the black
pieces he is in the world team
championship he was great and uh so he
was he was very solid and uh you guys
became world champions together
i wasn't there you weren't there got it
but
so but uh yes he's he's good with the
black pieces and when we got to the end
game it's it's not
were you at all worried during this game
that you might be worse if the queen
trade wasn't going to happen
oh i i wanted to keep the queens on so
you would have welcomed that yes i
wanted a more lively game but uh
the way played i i lose my c pawn if i
don't trade queen so so any other
critical moments after you guys traded
the queens off
it's uh it's an end game and and there's
play uh
there
even in those simple positions as you
know you get the wrong strategy and you
end up with a weak pawn exactly and they
play like magnus and uh they end up
taking it 40 moves later so
yeah both sides had to be a little
careful and and here i was in the end of
the end game i thought can i just get in
pawn to a5
uh and maybe get some chances then then
yes but now he goes he's you know very
solid so
shut me down there and and nobody can do
anything at the end
nick a solid start for you what are your
ambitions coming into this event well
actually i i
[Music]
i i just wanted to play i was without
ambitions but my thought was
you know get uh get started get rolling
and especially in the later tournament i
hope to play
some uh more active chess
definitely cleaning uh that dust off
your shoulders
feeling good right now feeling in shape
we'll let you rest get ready for
tomorrow's game and we'll see you in the
next few games okay thank you a quick
question for nick nick uh first of all
great to see you love
love seeing
love seeing you play
uh but uh watching the juniors do you
get inspired
they play without fear that's yes you're
looking at carissa's game
sacrifice everything uh
but then again
okay igor is he's uh really good
defensively
it's not as easy to sacrifice all your
pieces against igor
there there
good luck in the rest of the tournament
nick thanks guys cheers
all right and where would you like to
take us alejandro that is a great
question there's so much that has
happened recently two draws in the
seniors games again
we don't have anything finishing up that
i can see in
the girls actually we are being told
that uh sophie did finally finish her
game off exactly against rochelle
that's a huge result for sophie because
it puts her at two out of two to begin
the tournament
whoa early there we go and playing
against one of the rating favorites
rochelle is up there in terms of raiding
in this event exactly we see that uh
score now on officially yes on our board
i just want to catch up with the finals
uh moments there because we thought
there was a number of ways
of winning the game
and i thought that maybe e5 had
made black's task a little bit tricky
but let's see how she finished e4 d7
bishop d4 check
oh
no we didn't like the move bishop we
thought king h1
was uh
the move
i think everything was losing anyway
though was it yeah okay it would and
after bishop f2
uh bishop f6 did she lose on time or she
just no i this is
uh the problem is knight takes e4 oops
don't forget about the back rank mate
yeah it's actually pieces
yeah it's uh it's bad so a very nice win
for sophie if she gets no that's huge
for her wins round one
wins round two with excellent prep just
beating her opponent out uh with the
book
and we have this huge game actually
between jennifer you and talia cervantes
we hate this bishop on a4 just like what
did you do tell you bishop on c4 the
position was just equal but exactly the
bishop on a4 right that's the sore thumb
and the question is can jennifer make
the most on you know one of the things
that i would be afraid very much if i
was in tell your shoes
is that i might get myself into a bishop
of the same color ending like after a
move like rook c6
rook to d6 d5
and after takes
the one thing i would absolutely
absolutely want to avoid
is this ending because
all my pawns are on light squares and
therefore a target
for at the beginning
yeah the king on shade is running to b6
right now exactly exactly so i think
jennifer is
you know with good technique should be
winning the game alice lee
uh forced her opponent or i should say
uh ellen found a way of sacrificing an
exchange
uh for very very good compensation and
we like ellen's position uh against a oh
i'll say it a pre-tournament favorite
yeah
but how much do we like black's position
after a4 i think
very much guys
twenty-two seconds for all
think we should move to right
all right just because she has 20
seconds on the clock so 20 seconds well
now 40 because 50 because she moved but
they're going straight into this
variation right yes exactly what we
analyzed knight takes f4 rook takes g2
knight takes g2 queen h5
wow and we expect rook f7 with the truck
and rook f7 seems to be the only move
right now but it's not actually carissa
has to find queen d1 check and not
right quick three checks was that the
only draw at that point christian
let's take a look queen to d1 no there
was also the move queen to g5
which is very counterintuitive check
okay so knight f4 and now queen to g5
now you keep
pressure contact with the knight yes and
keep the g6 square protected oh man
but i think the easiest is to just go
queen d1 queen g2 queen 21 queen d2
okay
but that's the type of thing when you go
h4 and your your opponent plays queen
takes h4 and you reach for your knight
to go
you go touch me
got you there
oh boy oh boy
have you ever had one of those touch
move moments uh in your
career no i i don't think i did one of
the worst things uh i i did in my career
is i played the second move of the
variation i was calculating hey doing
that that's that happened
that's the worst and it was
losing in one move i was just resigning
next move so i calculated this variation
for like 30 40 minutes and then i played
the second move of the variation and
then bye-bye came over
oh
ooh and here is a result rochelle will
with the white pieces elusive to sophie
mori suzuki congratulations to her as
she moves to two out of two wow
nice and again what's the clock times i
wanted to ask of the carissa uh game uh
the charisma
50 seconds versus 23 minutes yeah no no
david brosky had tons of time 23 minutes
is a lot of time the problem is that
this particular move
has to be forced there cannot i don't
nobody will convince me there's another
move that don't require exactly then
you're making h8 instantly because
everything else loses
and then we think but but
after the move knight f4 what i have on
my analysis board so we're expecting
rook f7 check carissa has got to drop
back with her king
knight to f4 queen g5
is much more
sensible it's more than queen
d juan check yeah this one actually
looks to uh to win the game instead of
just making a perpetual right
you're on the queen against two pieces
it's tough but i have the perpetual it's
telling right make the perpetual moment
right yeah or i'm not going to let you
uh you know yeah i mean i may end up
playing moves like bishop or yeah i
don't know bishop takes and uh you the
perpetual could be gone
gone
but we do have a guest at studio so
we're going to turn it right back to
christian
thank you uh yeah sir we are indeed with
a very happy victory of the days around
sophie mori suzuki sophie welcome back
to the studio we've seen you last year
as well here how are you feeling right
now after two victories
i feel great i feel
you know
like i
and this is the best i could hope for i
guess for now
blazing heart start for you how did you
prepare for this tournament
um
i didn't have much time during
the school year
but within like the past few months that
i've been on break i have been able to
play in a few
tournaments
to get back into the swing of things and
yeah so far it's paying off
definitely playing off yesterday with
the white pieces a convincing victory
today you decided to play uh
aggressively from the get-go how did you
come up with that strategy
um
i don't i mean i just i just thought i
would play whatever is like
the most fun that's how the most part
and you came up with this very
interesting benoni line of the benoni b5
tell us where did your preparation end
um it ended after
rook b8
rook to b8 all the way
up here wow wow
and she had 47 minutes at this point
what were your notes saying
um at this point to b8
at this point i just kind of stopped the
preparation just
or stopped like my line and
concluded that this was
you know almost winning for black
absolutely and it wasn't it and i just
we have a result in the liang versus
christopher eugene a very important game
of the round and that was a draw as we
expected
let's keep going with the analysis and
what else what other critical moments
did you feel like you had to
overcome in this game
yeah the whole calculation process after
queen a3 was uh
not easy by the way there was a funny
line um
rook to d2 at this point did you see
this move yeah but i didn't know if i
had no idea if it was queen to f3 queen
oh
oh
i just only saw knight f3 and i take c4
yeah queen to f3 is a very uh
this is very sweet fine yeah
i i have i have a feeling during the
game that i didn't play the most
accurately
so let's keep going still you did not
release any of your advantage queen
takes f3
were you getting worried at this point
at all
when you saw this pawn on d6 close to
promotion maybe giving your opponent
some chances were you worried
yeah i really thought i'd
i mean i thought i was i still had good
winning chances but
i
really wasn't sure if it was
winning winning anymore
but it was after bishop to f2 because
now knight e4 to b1 is coming
very nice victory uh for you two out of
two what are your ambitions right now
um
just
don't mess up too much
excellent great games so far sophie
we're looking forward to see you in the
next few games thank you our
congratulations from uh alejandro as
what alejandro and myself as well good
start great start
excellent excellent prep i love seeing
these deep reparations rupiah i stopped
winning good enough good enough and she
was right she was right cruiser to
victory exactly and again
we have a very important result we
mentioned it uh during the interview but
christopher you saved a very difficult
position against a wonder liang
and by virtue of that save a wonder
liang our pre-tournament favorite is
only scored one and one draw out of two
games and
i tell you start to
question
yourself uh alejandro even though it's
very very early uh
getting off to a good start is so vital
to your confidence yeah i mean we have
had u.s juniors in which people lose the
first two and come back but they're the
exception you really want to start well
in these tournaments exactly i do have
uh the game of dimitri garvich
as white against joel benjamin i'm
looking at this game
and i think joel is busted out
in a sense if we go back to this moment
right here i'm thinking you know like
okay black is solid black is good but
the bishop on b5
not a lot of black's pieces are working
in other words i like the bishop i like
the rook but these guys over on the on
the king side rather sleeping and then
just look over the next few moves
as to how joel's
pieces suddenly emerge
now suddenly
wait a minute the night
can come to b5 harass this bishop it
should you take like this this knight
could also
uh come alive
uh on the e5 square things are going
black's way at this moment and what are
the clock times uh the clock times are
not so much time for either player four
minutes for joel from his 44 45 sorry
and dimitri 8 minutes 30 down now to 6
minutes 30 sorry
uh but still
12 moves to make for both players bishop
f6 again i just feel like joel's
pieces are
breathing coming alive coming alive
you can imagine d4 and e5 to follow
again this knight might end up on it
with the pawn on d4 pardon me
d4
knight b5 knight c3 i can really you
know enjoy
the progress that black's pieces has
made white's pieces
knight on d2 uh the knight on e1 bishop
on g2 bishop on a3 but they're making a
good impression oh very stuck right i i
feel like joel's got a big advantage
we'll keep an eye on this one what have
you been looking at alejandra
um
well there's a lot of moves in the
currency game i've been looking for
since we've been focusing on that game
so much for her good reasons we don't
want to move we don't want to miss that
we felt that carissa was playing a
brilliancy she sacrificed sacrificed a
piece
for
what we want to call intuitive play she
just had a good
good feel and then a couple of slips and
used all of her clock but it takes two
to tango and kudos to david brodsky he's
found excellent defenses all the way up
here including a sacrifice of a queen
yeah and it seems that the players might
be shaking on a drop pretty soon
chris that has found the right move
queen d2 not queen take c2 because of
king james 3. because of king g3 you got
to respect the threat of mate
uh well check followed by mate and uh
we are expecting carissa to force a draw
to force a draw she still has two
minutes left which is pretty good
considering the previous time situation
she only has four moves to make right so
no no real issues in that regard anymore
and for carissa again she comes into
this tournament
um
one of the lower one of the lower seeds
i want to say i mean she's taken the
challenge she could have played in the
girls where she would have been the
prohibitive favorite no she wanted to
play in the open section and uh she
started with two blacks one of the worst
numbers you can choose and b wars
but she's acquitted herself imagine she
makes a draw here yeah she started with
two draws against i'll be minor and
against brazil i think she'll be pretty
happy exactly and that's what we think
so you think and suddenly
an extra white farther remaining
seven games
and it doesn't seem like white has a
clear way of
doing anything or trying anything at
this point knight to g2 doesn't make a
lot of sense you might even lose that
exactly so you don't want to go that
route king g1
just allows the perpetual king g3 just
allows for simple perpetual that is the
problem because i have queen to e1 and
there's no way to
to go a different direction and what is
happening in brandon's game i don't
think we've looked at this for a while
actually all of the junior uh games have
been simplifying in the last right right
yes so after the explosive first round
of four
games
sudden fall back to earth
there's a clear person that benefits
from that and that is andrew hung the
only person that is so far two out of
two exactly this is all the games you
guys again i'm gonna bring my prep i'm
gonna win every white exactly and i'm
gonna run to the finish line but not any
two out of two right because you started
with two out of two but maybe some shaky
games he started blazing hot
perfect preparation and perfect
execution after the preparation which uh
just goes to show how in shape he is and
this is going to play out in his favor
moving forward great right uh we don't
expect much from this brandon jacobson
no
not much i was uh
pedro i i have a sympathy for pedro
being the lowest rated player in the
field how will he do how will he perform
um somehow
he's kind of in there he's
uh okay structurally he's worse but
how much worse exactly i mean four
versus four uh this pawn on
i mean if the king was on e5 we'd
probably be
you know
playing taps you know
uh but with the king uh
still cut and chances for you know to
get in the move f4 the king
we're going to try to keep the king out
is what it's all about right like even
if i have to play h4 and f4 ugly moves
uh
what
i didn't see that move coming
you kind of went a little bit
uh
i'm not sure i like this move at all uh
christian was that
computer approved computer approved it
looks it looks dangerous well that way
let me check among others
yeah i'm not a great move not a great
man not a computer proof it doesn't look
right yeah it felt h4 felt much safer
sure you keep out the cage talking about
that and on king f6 you go f4 or keep
getting out you know maybe you're not
happy about the g3 pawn but you keep the
king at bay you should be able to draw
it g4
feels like um pedro
wants to force uh a drawn position but i
don't know but perhaps too much right
yes perhaps a little hasty the way
yesterday right he was on the cusp of
getting that draw
made one move rookie eight that just
collapsed this position very similar
we're going to keep an eye on this one
alejandro we have a lot of updates in
the alice lee ellen wong game of course
a huge one for the standings because
right now i think ellen is the only one
that can realistically catch
sophie uh at the top because talia is
not beating jennifer from that position
no no
and check this out though allen has
actually won an extra a third party
third bond for the for the exchange
change that's a lot of fun that's a lot
of fun
so alan should just be able to nurse
this uh victory right yeah cruise
control right now rook to d6 to stop
to stop rook takes me yeah like queen b7
2. you got your choices exactly every
move is very similar three pawns for the
exchange that's great that's a lot of
compensation so yeah uh i would say just
not root d6 right
because rick takes d4
still works oh
oh i was trying to stop brooke
uh maybe i should play e5 in that case
to try to just stop rook d4 i mean i've
got everything protected
right which is what i want you feel like
it's one of those positions you can
secure everything yes exactly exactly
and the cursor game is over they
draw their game beautiful game uh
applause to both players this is a very
very very crazy game yeah i think when
they go back to their rooms and they
look with their chess engines they're
going to reflect on the fact that
uh both of them
had some really really good creative
moves and uh oh this was awesome i kept
those on our seat this was awesome very
good good stuff what else what did you
say about the jennifer game uh jennifer
is putting pressure on talia which we
would expect talia to win this now does
she lose it i'm not so
short
somehow black got in this move a5 which
makes this bishop look less ridiculous
before we go to that one i think we
should uh check this game out which we
haven't looked at very much and that is
the game between malnitsky and uh larry
christensen because larry christensen
right now is
setting up some tremendous pressure on
the light squares we see the presence of
the opposite color bishops but the huge
difference in the position despite the
fact that black is upon down i'm getting
this bishop on e4 and once i get that
bishop on e4 setting up this
tremendously unpleasant pressure on the
g file potentially cementing it if i
have time with the move f5 then i'm just
simply going to be able to reshuffle my
pieces get the rook back into play via
the d file and i have a feeling you're
just stuck as white because if you lose
this pawn on g to open up the long
diagonal you're going to get checkmated
so
the way i'm seeing the position right
now develop it seems like larry
christensen is nursing uh what could be
an objectively decisive advantage
and we have a couple of moves played
bishop g3 i think that takes something
just like top rook takes g2
pick up the pawn why not yeah that's
another past pawn the difference in
strength of these bishops is just so
obvious exactly it's just so obvious a
big pawn against a beautiful bishop this
is a winning advantage this is over i i
i feel very very strongly as well and
here are our results at this moment in
time yeah david brosky gets his first
half point he lost yesterday to andrew
honkey
rectifies the ship a little bit there
with a draw and karissa two blacks in a
row two draws for her good start of the
tournament exactly being one of the
lower rated players in the field
she really accepted the challenge
she's going to be in india on our
olympic team right that's right and this
is what she wanted she wanted to really
test herself
going in to india she's feeling good
about it she'll be facing grandmasters
there for sure so it's important that
she gets that experience in before she
goes to chennai
exactly okay and
i was just going to say we've seen the
joel benjamin game we've also seen the
larry christensen game there is one
other game that we haven't seen in a
little
while that's the schabaloff game um
the players are playing checkers right
on one side you've got all the dark
squares
yeah and white has a lot of white
squares
um i like black
i like that dark square this looks very
bad for white it's right the only
question is
where do i break through as black is the
only real question here exactly it's uh
it's going to be a long slow
uh
at some moment
i don't know can i ever
should i play like rook h7 and we do
have a result in the game between
dimitri and no no no
the draw he's checking out and guys i
have to tell you that i saw yasser write
a speech about how black was better in
this position and he just had to scrap
it and throw it in the garbage oh my
gosh it was a good speech too hold on by
the way he took
not that was interesting
i got the wrong relay i think i had a
relay where we were taking with the c5
pawn it was a d-pawn yes pardon me with
the d d-pawn on c5 he actually took with
the b-bond bishop
yes
and
knight c2 draw off or draw agreed
okay with a beep on taking it's it's
yeah yeah okay i feel like that's
actually
much fairer otherwise i would be like a
joel i mean
chase him down the street what are you
what do you think you're doing you're
not getting away
all right
so uh there's a game that we please i
think we haven't looked at it at all
please and perhaps we should look at it
at some point
uh gracie prasanna is playing ree young
young all right let's go to gracie uh
this also looks a little like checkers
and it also feels but in this case
gracie's in trouble chris is in huge
trouble look at that black rook already
penetrated into white's camp rook um
f3
uh going after the base pawn followed by
bishop c5 and it's black all day
no
sorry but this is a really bad position
for white that's pretty terrible
yeah i feel like rook rook f3 might just
in fact claim the game
yeah the very difficult to stop right i
guess you have to go bishop f2 or
something rueyang lost yesterday did she
sorry i i want to say yes but i forgot
who she lost to
and i'm gonna just check because i can
you can do that i have the technology
yasser we we have a
drew yesterday against against rochelle
and we do have a guest with christian in
studio indeed the answer we are with
david brotzky after a great game against
uh carissa david first of all let's
start with yesterday's game i hate to
bring back bad news and bad memories but
what happened how did you feel when you
fell under the sword of that preparation
it was torture i mean i knew that this
is probably equal but
i
i couldn't find where like i i saw this
this queen sack but i i didn't see rook
h5 rook at five that's so hard to find
like
it just just felt
yeah yeah it was yeah it was it was it
was really hard as a theoretical uh
theoretically inclined player yourself
it must feel quite unpleasant to lose
like that how do you deal
psychologically with that and what do
you do to recover um
yeah i
like like yesterday okay i didn't look
at that much chest after the game and i
just looked at look at the opening saw
that okay this queen sack is somehow
playable
and then okay i had dinner went for a
long walk and prepared a little for
today
well today you definitely came very well
prepared because it seemed like you were
building a nice time advantage out of
the opening you came up with this idea
of g4 uh it felt like you surprised her
were you uh shocked when she played f5
oh yeah actually g4 was kind of prep i
was just looking at some some games this
morning and i saw that someone played
knight h5 in this this game and white
played g4 and it was a little better for
whites i'm like okay might as well play
it but then the five came i was like
oh
and uh what were your feelings after f1
i thought it's you stopped you thought
about it you took the piece yeah were
you concerned at all that her attack
might be successful
how did you assess the position no i
thought this is good for me
but i messed up later on like okay
i think yeah
i just
and you had the right idea
to try to get the bishop out right uh
but you could force uh this taking only
three with queen d1
because f3 doesn't come with tempo
oh wow queen d1 is smarter
oh wow but some other moves are probably
fine too right like there should be
other moves queenie one is just the the
best movie in the position
oh yeah and queen d1 and okay i don't
really care about the tempo as long as i
neutralize everything yeah i somehow
missed knight d4 and then i realized
that it's it's
not so clear right because if you if
it's white's uh move uh after queen to
d1 you go knight to b1 or king h1 or
king h1 yes yeah and that just wins the
game so i tried later okay here i'd yeah
kids king h1 is best okay queen eight
you should do four you know no queen
tries a mistake well
okay 92
yeah and here it's probably just nothing
special for white but she spent all her
time which i didn't understand yes
so i thought i might be able to generate
something were you surprised by this
move queen to h5 were you worried about
taking on d4 first um
what lines were you calculating oh queen
h5 yeah i was expecting that you weren't
expecting that okay yeah you're taking
and yeah what what's the deal taking in
if the ond4 seems to be much better at
least from an objective point okay so
yeah i'll probably go 92
[Music]
knight e2 and probably take
queen six
and uh something perhaps bishop to e5
or f4 maybe okay okay that's fine
yeah this is this is bad just to set up
the pine like that yeah
and she played the queen to h5 she was
getting super long time down yeah last
minute i thought i could i could
generate something maybe i don't know
you had this opportunity and
you understood that you have to put a
queen on g2 but i should do it with the
queen and with the queen on h5 yes
okay now i have something right because
she doesn't have what she had in the
game she she's not in time to double up
on the air file yeah but okay it's
probably i'll always still some
resources right it's still close to
equal uh-huh but but you have some
chances yeah i
just didn't realize that this is
holding an 82 bishop oh richie's six
yeah richie's six and it's like the
queen and there's actually nothing
everything is just forced yeah like
queen h5 is nice
oh it's only move
now okay
i can't really
i mean i could play knight g2 but that's
too risky i mean she takes a4 i'll never
get the night out anyway because i'm
gonna get hit with checks everywhere
oh
david uh a difficult start yesterday
specifically and uh today unfortunately
a missed opportunity but also uh it was
quite difficult to get your pieces out
after you missed them
oh this is from yesterday
our producers like uh likes to to show
our players suffering unfortunately
yeah
yesterday yesterday was tough
how would you uh assess your preparation
going into this event
are you happy
well after my game with andrew i'm not
happy but
okay that's it's really tough to find
like
yeah today's game was pretty good prep i
think and
yeah i guess we'll have to we'll have to
see more games and what did you do
before the event how did you approach
this tournament overall did you do any
special preparation train with any of
the players in the field
oh i didn't trade with anyone in the
field but yeah i worked in some quite
openings quite a bit so
yeah we'll see i might have some
surprises we'll see excellent
that's what we like to hear who do you
have tomorrow uh balaji
big game
we'll let you rest we'll let you recover
thank you and we'll see you tomorrow
david we just want to get in a quick
shot from our side uh over here as we
thought that you and carissa played a
great game in fact and it was very very
en entertaining so really a big hat tip
to you and carissa both absolutely
we enjoyed
we appreciate it we're happy we have
their gold coins we're throwing them on
the board yeah you know i played an
entertaining game and i didn't get made
it today so that's a that's an
improvement wonderful
that's what we all aspire to as chess
players it's about to get made not to
get mated good luck david good luck
david and we have to update especially
in the u.s junior girls a lot has
changed okay as we have this result
dimitri grievitch did drug against joel
benjamin as we saw
uh but we have to update the junior
girls in uh alice lee against ellen wang
okay i think this game is
moments
from resignation
wow because yeah
and you can see the body posture of both
players alice lee says everything right
it just says everything ellen's looking
down like a hawk
yeah like her body completely over the
queen side right like which spawn am i
queening exactly look you can see her
looking at that a4 like it's a new queen
like all we got to do is play a3 and
what are you going to do and she has one
move into the fourth yeah a3 is actually
the only move that she has to avoid but
i think she can chill with queen before
queen b3 why not queen b3 is just
lights out exactly queen b3 i mean a382
is such a devastating threat don't
blunder rook takes d4 rook d8 checkmate
exactly but as long as you're not
plundering that like a3 rook takes d4 i
was actually gonna take this until i
realized i'm blundering something
a2 almost and wins
really not not something not so much not
so much queen a8
check
and you actually end up even taking my
bishop gosh that hurts you're not going
to take on a2
[Laughter]
nice nice and quick meanwhile in the
game she's done
queen b4 looks fine that looks fine as
well and importantly that makes move 40
for both players okay so they reached
their time control they do reach their
time control in the game of jennifer you
antalya cervantes which is our key
matchup exactly for the girls section
today
it feels that jennifer
is no longer better four versus f four
double rook ending with the bishops
traded that's a big deal for talia yeah
especially considering the bishop that's
on
b4 a4 uh but this looks dead drawn right
rookie seven if i just go rook d2 looks
like an obvious move
rook d2 yeah yeah
okay
i'm just
i
yeah it's actually feeling like
talia's got no worries no words yeah you
start thinking maybe yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
sometimes it does just because you know
like these pawns could yeah
uh expecting a draw so uh fighting back
italia there is uh gracie we thought
gracie was in trouble frankly and she
was still complete enough she just kept
on alive but her position not good
no they're just it's too passive zoe
this looks dead drawn
four versus four four versus four and
nothing to say uh setting up a potential
cheapo with bishop takes and don't you
dare touch the pawn on h5
alejandro don't be grabbing pawns that's
what i keep telling you don't every day
every single day we learned that lesson
yasser
okay uh rookie
there's nothing to see in this game
exactly
uh what have you got for us christian
well actually guys uh
you went through the analysis too fast
in this one because
b4 is throwing a large part of her
advantage away no
quinto b3 was dominating yes that's
clear queen to b4 allows rook to c1
and i'm starting to get something i'll
play something something there right you
can go f5 okay six okay okay root to c8
king to h7 and now i can go queen to f1
or queen to d3 queen to d3 makes a lot
of sense no no no no no if i manage no
queen d3 i trade queens how do you with
queen queen e4 yes yes that's probably
good
by the way her only chance you've played
it what about queen to f1 though because
if you allow me to get to a6 now i'm
starting to try to tackle your opponent
e6 as well as ideas of queen to a8 i'm
creating something oh wow i'm not saying
very very dismissive i i'm shocked
because i thought that the pawns were
just marching march march march and done
done um but this is how you spoil this
type of advantage with
small mistakes like this
accuracy you go from -7 to minus two
point eight seven then next move minus
two point one then next move one one
point five and that's how you lose the
advantage goes slowly i think she just
missed rickshaws she did she did miss
ruxin it's a powerful move because it
creates something in the position
otherwise white wouldn't have uh any
chances
just
the position and all of your pieces are
dominated does it make a difference
whether you play f5 or g6 after rook c1
let's take a look g6 is already 0.4
boy we talk about slipping slipping
slowly so you're right close to giving
me everything i need yeah okay well h5
is just enough right you can see that
you see
you see that it breaks your structure
you don't want to see this on the ball
oh this move queen before was a big
howler big holler yes i'm not saying
she's still winning yeah let's get that
straight she's still winning but it's
not as easy right queen to b7 is an easy
move to make
rook to c4 c4 now you're sort of in
trouble exactly you're losing one of the
pawns right right a3 rook takes d4 and
we're taking advantage of the pin not
that easy this is all i'm saying not
that easy still winning but not that
easy but also by the way queen b3 i know
that's dominating but i'm i'm sitting
here thinking queen f3 also was a nice
way of posting up because it's all about
keeping the rook
controlled
yeah
it's a great move yeah yeah yeah
it's the easiest yeah
no moves yeah just just just freezing
the play yeah wow uh alice lee fighting
or waiting
and
let's uh go back back to the game of
larry c big larry c
attacking genius
from seoul you could call him the
finalist from uh last year's event
exactly
it was uh
very well disputed against kaido
but look what he's doing he's just
played the move rook d2 and that's huge
you just can't defend from that can you
oh boy this looks ugly because this is
only
queen e1 bishop h3 is
game right that's a problem
well do you have queen e4 no queen for
f5
and i defend on g7 at the end actually i
don't need to defend anything rick takes
f5 bishop takes g2 sweet
don't take rooks take pawns
oh boy
larry by the way a writer of two just
wonderful books storming the barricades
and rocking the ramps
yeah i love those books uh he talks
about his career and you know
these games that he played and one game
that he played
was uh during lone pine they had a daily
brilliancy
so he's looking at the board and he sees
that you know one move you know just
crushes but the other move sacrifice is
a rook
and
yeah you're winning at the end so for
business reasons business
transaction
he sacrifices the rookie the business is
business uh business was good the man 65
years of age from massachusetts uh
three-time u.s champion oh yeah and
grammy if i'm wrong but he's one of the
few players i believe
that did not get his international
master title right that's right he
skipped
i am he went from master to gm
uh
and in the
day and age when it was really really
hard to get the gm
so just skipping the i am title all
together i mean
that's like accelerated uh graduation
you know
instead of going to an eight-year
college it was like a four-year college
but you can uh fill the class whenever
he plays these attacking games right
it's just everything flows perfectly yes
and we do have a move on the board it
was queen
e3 three on the board queen e3 on the
board which is nice
oh i missed this move
okay okay if i play rook d3
uh rook d3 is a very very good move i i
i thank you i'm thinking about business
reasons business business reasons check
all right
i know you want to play bishop h3o
correct it works correct
you got it
is too vulnerable i mean again if there
was a brilliant surprise and it was
still not convinced worthwhile
maybe f5 here
which f5 f5 yeah i think it's not over
yeah
five hiding to f4 on f4 and i do got
checks
well okay but you wanted to play much
more prosaic after queen oops sorry well
i don't think that's necessarily the
problem queen 3 queen c1 i think bishop
e1 might be a problem also uh i think
alejandro just suggested the
gary
obviously good
after rook d3 uh any issues for larry
here
i guess we go back sorry your bishop is
hanging dude okay you win my bishop i
win yours yeah but i'll take on h3
uh
oh boy where did i ever heard that
before
okay so it does feel like uh
larry's uh
in the driver's seat on this guys why
are we getting tricked right by
semantics right now because
the whole point of his attack was to
target g2 correct so why don't we just
simply go queen c2
continue the attack on g2
and has a point
you defend the bishop firstly you can't
take the bishop i've got it into mezzo
and
as he said i mean
the light squares that's
the big problem right right and the
position so let's just focus on the
light squares but wait did did larry
actually swindle a pawn on the queen
side as well yeah yeah yes
excellent
very good stuff uh very nice a man of
taste and then a good taste
d3 was played rook d3 guys we might have
a heartbreaker in our hands no eleanor
queen b8 played queen v8 no allowing
rook c4 rook c4
i'm telling you man once you miss rook
c1 things are not easy anymore oh my god
what a turn of events
can i see that let me just
go back to that game because
wow
rook she would okay so
let's let's set the stage
ellen was completely winning she has
three pawns and a bishop for an exchange
she just played the move queen before
when she could have played the move
queen b3 which would have answered all
of the issues
uh defending her pawn getting
ready for a3a2 she aired with the mook
queen before rook c1 was a nice hidden
resource that introduces some counter
play
um
that could be answered by f5 and g6 to
cover the back
door checkmates
instead
queen b8 we rejected this because of
rook c4
now is that
really the case so we go a3 i want to
anchor the bishop
right rook takes
can i play about rook takes you have a2
rook takes a heavy a2 better yet right
so what's the problem i think you go
queen c2 instead of rook takes d4
ah
a3
i'm just getting a little scared i'm a
little stuck right because you have to
play bishop c3
and then i go i think i go rook a4
and i just the thing is you still don't
have queen b2 it's still a mate you have
to lose another tempe i'm picking up the
pawn and we will i don't think i'm
losing that
what what what
rook see four is on the board but d3
here yeah
no no quinter queen e4
i think you might be in trouble
don't get in trouble yes sir well wait a
minute i got the
these pawns are are good okay not that
good
for you maybe not that good huh not that
good ooh i mean
a3 is on the board and if she finds
queen c2 right now not rook takes d4
yeah queen c2 we feel is necessary and
gracie ii just forces matters yeah
because once again a tricky that a
cheapo
that i fell for is after rook takes d4
obviously i'm in a pin but the move a2
turns the tables instantly that's it
game over
so you can't take the pawn but this move
queen c2 menacing
rook
c8 and let's get the bird's eye view see
if she makes it ellen
has she spoiled it i think she did if
she finds queen c2 this is it what's the
eval
zeros
she's reaching for crazy i i i i rose
i see her hand is just so close to the
queen on b1 she's got to be worried that
she's going to make it and she made it
this is the cold shower
wow
that came pouring on pouring ellen my
goodness and alice
[Applause]
you know the sign
that uh uh yeah
deal with it yeah things have turned oh
wow
oh my goodness
now she starts understanding what went
wrong
queen b
you that's why chess is such a cruel
game hours of play by ellen wang
brilliant play she was right
three pawns nursing this winning
advantage
one move mo forty four move forty was it
queen four was move forty queen before
move four that's even worse oh god what
a feeling oh we've all been there truly
we have all been there we have another
result by the way the game between zoe
tang and anne marie villa definition of
draws we expected that was the game with
like four versus forward
bishop and bishop nothing nothing
happened
and
let's see what happened the equalizing
move the equalizing move queen c2
alice the brilliance of uh television
instant replay how about that my
favorite part
exactly
well there's one thing alice is uh not
missing and that is confidence
she's definitely very confident
only how old is she is she like 13 years
of age right now yes 13 wow that's crazy
13 years of age out
and again that we unfortunately didn't
have too much time to talk about we just
had such
so many games we have 15 games of chess
guys and we have games like carissa yips
against brodsky that dominated our
attention unfortunately for good reason
for good reason unfortunately because of
that some did fall through the cracks
yep this was one of them it was a good i
went through it it was a well played
game from beginning to end not just not
a very exciting one right
exactly
and again we're just looking at this
game of alice lee for a second i
need to refresh my board because i yeah
she did she played queen c2
bishop c3
rook
a4
and the very desirable queen b2 is going
to be met by a back ranked checkmate so
can't do it i tried queen f8
but is this where you popped out with
queen e4 on me yeah queen e4
with the deadly threat of rook a4 and i
can't
push any of my pawns to deal with that
no not on time not on time
man oh man what have i done what an
opportunity missed
truly
so and now with that being said it's
still not over right no i mean there's
still some play left yeah but
i mean in this position she might just
dig down and go you know something like
g6 and give up the pawn and then it's so
bad to give up basically i know i know i
know exactly and say okay i got two
pawns against your rook let's go but
yeah sometimes you just have to reset
your mind and say that was in the past i
i've spoiled my winning advantage easier
said than done truly so we have this
game going we have one in the juniors
okay guys wait just one second i have a
funny idea in in that game can we look
let me go back all right
so what if i try to defend after uh
a4 bishop to b2 the bishop just came
from b2 yeah and then you can just
simply go rook c4 i was calculating
queen to e4 i'll show you my funny idea
please okay queen to e4 d3
d3 and i was trying to assess this
position
after rook two a take take but you just
have king f1
you catch
uh the d-pawn with your king you don't
need to use your queen
as
we are being told that uh jacobs on a
mishra did draw their game yeah left
that rook and game some time ago nothing
much happened okay it felt like a game
in which both sides had their chances i
think brandon got outplayed
after he got a good position right yeah
we
we did think uh that brandon actually
had an edge in that gate boop so that's
the wrong
um
section
by the way uh
only one decisive game uh
in the junior so far yeah i mean we got
uh as we said you know andrew is happy
yes andrew is the happy man seeing
everybody draw their game while he keeps
winning with his prep let me just see
this
final game it just zips up
yeah yeah yeah yeah this is the
the ending
a couple of four rook endings today
yeah okay this is just a drop
nice
all right uh and uh christian once again
uh what do you have for us well one
thing that has clarified is the game
between uh malinitsky and larry
christensen because larry did pick up
another pawn
but in return allow the exchange of the
queens
so how do we assess this a new imbalance
in uh in the position everything i like
about chess tells me that white is
completely busted
right it has to be right
how easy it is pretty easy
okay do you think
should we do a man versus machine guys i
mean i don't know if we still have it
i can't lose my advantage
i think we can do that i think we
[Laughter]
um wha why do you think uh it's awkward
uh first of all if the bond was on well
i'm seeing the blockade against the pawn
was on that three maybe yeah but now
with the pawn still all right vulnerable
like i could go bishop to e4 and rook to
e2
it shouldn't be it shouldn't be that
difficult no i i agree with you guys
either get mated on the light squares
or you put a passive rook to defend the
cheese and then you enter with the
questions
no this should be very easy yeah yeah
perhaps you guys are right yeah i think
yeah i think uh it's quite easy you know
we're right
you know we have all this like mad
versus machine
segment and of course right all right
it's it's out the window the moment the
humans keep going right right the humans
are right and they throw the segment out
guys keep going no no i'm not done
i made my speech
right why did
how did larry um
force the win at the pawn and how did uh
igor manage to trade queens so after
rook d3 queen c5 was played rook take
take and now bishop takes h3 i see
bishop f2 bishop d7 and now we have this
okay guys but rook to c7 what what do
you play how how do you do it rook to c7
how do we play how do you do
okay i kind of like the pawn on h5 you
got any objections about
advancing a little bit no
or do you want to put the rook elsewhere
bishop b5 bishop f5 i want to give the
bishop to b4 and then to f8
i'm a very ambitious young man
okay all right let's see you do it let's
see you do it
before
h4 can i go h4
let's just let's encourage him too oh
yeah let's encourage him to do exactly
what he wants right exactly so then we
get our pawn to a4
okay keep going keep going with what
i mean just make some normal moves i
don't have
can i go at five
you go f5 it's legal but then you just
go keep h6 yeah yeah you don't even have
to take that i think yeah but even if i
do i'll be very happy to take it don't
you worry
uh christian with a special guest
indeed the answer we are here with
anne-marie valla anne marie first of all
welcome to the show welcome to st louis
this is your first time in saint louis
uh yes this is my first well not st
louis but first time in this tournament
yeah first time playing uh in the junior
girls how does that feel
very exciting i'm happy to be here
how did you prepare for this tournament
um
just making sure that i analyze all my
games from before and learn from any
mistakes to try to not repeat them here
and
playing and making sure i have all my
openings everything down and how do you
feel so far after two rounds of play um
so far
i'm feeling pretty fine i think
it's not that i have um
i lost my first game and now i just drew
the game
but i'm
i have good hopes for the next rounds
perfect actually let's talk about
today's game take us through the
critical moments of it
from the opening preparation did you
feel like you're winning the opening
battle
the opening was honestly i feel like
a bit of a surprise i wasn't really sure
like
exactly what she was gonna go for in the
opening but
i was a bit surprised um
the opening fell the opening felt fine
for me
i didn't really feel
like i was worse really
um
did you feel under pressure at any point
she did have the two bishops but it felt
like you have enough compensation for
that yeah
i i think a key moment was around here i
decided to sacrifice a pawn
so
with c4 yeah i i saw all of this i knew
that she was like gonna go queen c3 and
try to capture that pawn on c5 and i was
i wanted to play c4
and tell us why why didn't you take on
e4 was that an opportunity at that point
taking on e4 right now no no if we go
back a few moves
um instead of c4
you also have the opportunity of taking
a pawn with bishop to ec4 right uh yes
what were you uh concerned about
um the same game i was concerned so
after bishop takes e4 rook takes c4
queen takes c5 queen takes c5
um
rook takes c5
and i was concerned about rook a5
and then she has the two outside past
pawns and i didn't want to play against
those
absolutely you also have to defend
against checkmate first yeah
that's a problem
so i didn't think that was a good
position for me
but
instead sacrificing the pawn gave gives
a gives a very big compensation
and she's also under time pressure so
it's harder for her to play
when
she has a position where she has to
defend
absolutely and she kept her pawn but you
were picking at her pawns as well yeah
slowly but surely and after that is
simplified into this end game
very decent game absolutely a good start
for you uh what are your ambitions
coming into this event
um i so this is my first time playing
but um
i want to get do my best get some good
experiences good games and try to finish
with the best end result that i possibly
can marie
go back get some rest get some
preparation going who are you playing
tomorrow um i believe in playing
rochelle woo
oh that's a difficult game
well perfect thank you very much for
joining us thank you and we'll see you
tomorrow yes a quick question from from
ours outside
who do you consider the favorites in the
field
who for you
are the favorites to win the girls
championship
who are the favorites in your opinion to
win the championship
[Music]
i'm not sure who the highest rated is
but i think i'm not sure if there's
really a clear favorite i think it's
more every game actually that i've seen
so far is a battle so it's going down to
the last seconds the last
like the end game everything so
it's very
i can't really tell who is gonna be you
should say yourself
good and one last question is vela a
romanian name yes romanian there we go
my compatriot
all right well thank you and uh good
luck in the rest of the tournament i
hope to see you again in the
guest seat absolutely absolutely as we
have more results then we saw this one
brandon jacob some people i guess abby
my new mishra right uh one point for a
reminder brandon of course lost
yesterday so he's stuck with half right
and how many games do we have remaining
yes we have three games remaining in the
ladies section again um
two in the seniors and one in the junior
exactly jennifer
and talia
you know this is really a weird game
i'm not sure that tally is not better
it's weird it almost feels like black is
the one playing for an advantage exactly
you get in the pawn to h4 your rook it's
light over
by the time you start pushing this pawn
you realize it goes nowhere because yeah
right in front of them black uh ends up
behind the pawn
so this is actually a really a very
important game because once again
italia did start with a win
number one against number two exactly so
again that's that's the biggie uh in the
seniors oops sorry that's not the
seniors that is the seniors yeah this is
uh oh that was our analysis against a
computer wiki
we
thought
that uh the a checkers game that was
going on between the shibalov and
vladimir
was
advantage black black yes but we just
weren't sure how you were ever going to
make the breakthroughs that you need i
mean if you get to play bishop f1
it's going to be very hard there's no
weaknesses yeah it's an ugly bishop but
the bishop actually holds on to the
entirety of the position michael shuba
uh good bad
good pawns that's a great line gosh i
wish i had come up with that damn it
hate it uh so maybe a draw is at the
favorite in this one we do expect larry
to win and
christian uh do you have a
favorite i was trying to assess this
endgame how easy it is for
espinosa to make a draw in this one
against justin wang because what are we
looking at so the
this is where we left it that was the g
form
we didn't like the move g4 we didn't
like right
away h4 right yeah h4 is much easier h4
follow it up with g4 later on king f1
you can sit like this no problems
g4
was his decision but right now okay we
got this one and i understand
objectively it seems like after rook to
f7
is close to equality but sorry is it
king taking takes d5 yes king i would be
h7 i would be afraid that i was i would
lose it with the passive key yes yes
it's a race right let's go e5 just go
down the line e5 take king e4 or
whatever king e4 probably g5 only move
apparently and then get the rook to g
get the right b if you go king f3 i have
rook g4 g5 is a huge move it's so
difficult it's a huge move it's so
difficult wow
he by the way played the move rook to a
d2 allowing and now rook to f7 is easier
to make because
i will
be so happy but still the king gets to
f3 okay can i check you from a3 can i
check you from the side yes i'll get you
out of my yes
yes yes that's probably the best way and
i'll get you here and i don't know about
my
products anymore so if i go here you
just give me a check check throw me back
kf1 and king f1 by the way not the only
move but it seems like the
by far the best i i i'd want to corral
the d-pawn yeah
it's pretty clean yeah wow uh this is
the position right now espinoza with 16
minutes to go against 22 minutes for
wang
still shaky not as easy as
i would like it to be for espinoza yeah
by the way talia did play the move h4
hinting hinting that maybe i'm ready to
play as we see bedroom right on cue play
the move root cave seven and we think
especially
well that's the king
of three right yeah yeah okay you have
to take
pretty clear exactly we can wait for him
to do that no reason not to
and again i wanted to say that jennifer
you
for us pushing
you could get yourself into a little
trouble
you could over press uh these the these
endings and
uh hard for me to tell do you see in
talia's body posture that she's happy
camper oh yeah yeah she
she's thinking
beyond
unequality at the moment yeah i think
she's realized that she's out of danger
especially because she can see rook c67
right so i think she knows she's out of
danger
so how do you play the brakes right now
how does white put on the bike exactly
yeah how do you kind of break
this into a draw right so rook c7 right
let's just say rook f5 is a bit and then
rook c5 try to hunt the hunt the rock on
the rook makes sense if i manage to
exchange to drain one pair of ropes
i don't think i'm even worried if i lose
the b-pawn right fair fair yeah
although that four versus three yeah the
structure is a bit suspicious it's dried
it'll take a while not very clean right
right the structure is not great i think
as we get ready uh for the
eventual uh
time i'm not going to say time trouble
because we do get those 30 seconds we're
just going to take a short break and
we're going to see you on the other side
of this break tough games
[Music]
can you hear it
[Music]
it's the sound of hope
[Music]
and health
and strength
[Music]
it's the sound of compassion
of open doors
where people and machines are in tune
and miracles occur
[Music]
it's the sound of personalized
healthcare
[Music]
and active communities
it sounds like life
and it's what you hear
when you really listen
listening to you caring for you we are
ascension
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everybody we are in our
trio of championships and in the seniors
also known as the legends larry
christian said well a legendary player
himself has won with the black pieces
against igor
and is now with one half points tied
with igor novak tied with igor navika
for the lead absolutely we've got one
game remain remaining in the seniors
alex under shabala i want to say is
nursing a
disadvantage
i've seen the defense seizing the
defensive against vladimir
kopium that's been the case for quite
some time and
basically
shabbat has been shuffling his bishop
back and forth
between f1 and e2 and saying to his
opponent
how are you going to make progress
anytime you you
focus and play knight takes c4 i'll take
once and then i'll take on d6 and i'll
be a happy camper with my counter play
and i'm
i am expecting the draw
it kind of feels like it right that yeah
the black hats already
moved everything with everything around
yeah the knight was on that f4 the king
was somewhere else yeah the rooks were
different i mean he's gone around and
around which is what you're supposed to
be doing in this kind of position so
take the position where you're better
forever right and then you try to
improve it to the maximum before you
make a break or a threat but and then
you offer a draw and then you're for a
draw because you can't break you can't
make any breakthroughs right exactly and
then in the um
uh junior section we have one game going
on
that's between uh pedro and justin wang
okay let me see
check i'm a little surprised by the
movie by the way we do have an important
result in the girls as jennifer you as
we look at it right now has drawn her
game against talia cervantes not a very
happy jennifer you see it on her face
i'm sure she felt that she was much much
better at some point in this game
definitely and especially from her first
game yesterday
where we think she should have won in
the game against alice lee
she's looking at two draws from
favorable positions she's not going to
be happy but
one lady who is going to be happy talia
she started with a win yeah she's not
quite leading because the half point
means that she can't catch sophie right
right clearly in the lead
all right and
let's see uh there was actually uh three
alice is still going off of course and
we have a guest with christian
larry you picked it up where you left it
off last year with a game against
kaidanov how did you strategize that
battle um well yesterday yeah i thought
i had an edge yesterday
looking look
looking for revenge and then i sort of
faded
near the end i think it was plus two or
something and let him off the hook
today was a better
better let's let's take a look uh at
today's game you played with the black
pieces was the strategy you try to
complicate matters as fast as possible
um you know i looked like a lame opening
but uh that
second thought it looked pretty
dangerous after
93. it wasn't um
i was planning queenie four that i think
that would have gotten me into bigger
trouble i may have been in trouble here
actually i think we need four was the
best move engine
i thought f3 and
or something like that g6 i was afraid
of something like knight
i don't know
knight c4 trash is that working oh my
goodness and if you take and then king
december some sort of nightmare
no beat but my basics yeah night b
who knows like probably black and castle
castle
like a maniac yeah it's probably good
for black
but you know i wasn't quite sure of my
calculating ability looked a little
dangerous but you decided against uh
queen e4 and chose the more tame queen
v8
were you surprised by this exchange on
e7 we were actually looking at this move
before i was up for i was a little
nervous about g4 not that it's i'm not
sure i'm quite dead but no no no but 88
i think i go rookie eight
he has some you know some
g5 maybe bishop g2 just some solid
development then knight c6 i guess and
uh bishop f8 perhaps and then knight d4
maybe at some point maybe yeah
i think i may have even had that in the
game i was
but that was a little too simple but you
were a bit worried i was a little
nervous i would have played that myself
yes
that's what we
thought as well yeah
okay so here he's got a little problem
with this okay so here's a tough call i
was thinking about eating things like e3
didn't quite work
you know the sack
i think he plays knight e3 and it wasn't
quite working for me mm-hmm the queen's
you know now that stuff so this looked
like the logic
knight takes e3 we exchanged that
d5 yeah there was a knight e3 knight
takes bishop takes uh bishop f5 i guess
f5 yes but then he plays uh
now he has queen g5 right
yeah yes exactly queen g5 or queen up
yeah that's right
forget it it's not working
and what if you go bishop d5 to have
that bishop protected yeah then i think
bishop d5 he's got bishop h6 that he
saves oh very nice yeah
yeah that keeps uh i'm
up up to the wall zoo here or up the
creek
keep see more live for sure yeah all
right so you decided against e3
yeah bishop here
so you know lot like rook lifts i've
been talking about it for years so now
you know classic
i have some nebulous pressure you know
cheat a lot of cheapos i look you know
looking for those cheapos on h3 and so
forth
so you are feeling comfortable at this
point i knew i was and it was
complicated i think i played queen eight
didn't i no i played queen c will you
play queen eight at the beginning yeah
yeah yes i played queen eight later yes
and now i get to now clarifies a bit i
thought i had pressure
uh well i do have pressure i think did
you feel like he misassessed uh this
position yeah it's uh because of that
you know i mean earlier
i'm going to lose it he's going to lose
a pawn and plus perpetual pressure on g2
you know the poor guy i mean he's got a
passive bishop hard to make loot without
you know
something bad happening and and you
assessed it uh perfectly because
actually the computer says you're
completely winning at this point oh
really completely winning yeah i looked
like it was
good chances so yeah at this point i
thought it was comfortable win yes
absolutely maybe two pawns up you know i
have to be careful
you know he actually had this move after
rook to d3 you had this uh well save to
save one more pawn that is bishop to e1
there should be one here yes would you
spot this uh well then i think i would
resource i would keep them queen i would
keep queen c2 queen to situ yes keep the
pressure going
and then you know look so he's got to be
careful about um queenie two maybe
oh queenie he plays queenie too okay
yeah and he's um hanging in there
try to get the same end game but with
the pawn on h3 still yeah that's a
little bit different yeah
but he did not spot that and after that
you just yeah after upd3 i think it was
all over
we were a little surprised larry by rook
to d3 we thought queen c2
made a lot more sense just you know
pounding the pawn on g yeah um
yeah i was uh i i saw queen c2 look
promising i didn't rook d3 looked like
you know two pawns up okay so i mean
and i think it's only because of bishop
to e1 that he gets to stay in the game
if he doesn't see that then he's out
yeah i mean this is just you know pure
torture yeah i think i could trade rooks
it's must be winning too right yeah sure
what's the what's the diagnosis
it's probably winning the two pawns but
i like your decision yeah
why bother with that yeah i mean you're
you
you your rook is actually released
on a2 and you know yeah escort service
and g2 pressure yeah what kind of
service escort service
yeah it's a family show
[Laughter]
nice uh feeling good larry you got one
and a half points out of two nice start
uh what did you think about igor
novokov's victory coming
uh
in round one oh yeah that was um where
he came from from a bad position yeah
quite a quite a um
comeback counterattack exactly exactly
yeah he's a tough customer with black
with the black pieces he's real tough
coming into the tournament larry
who did you think were the favorites
uh well the young guys
copying joel
the young guys
the young guys dimitri
younger i think
the young guys how did you rate your own
chances seriously i'll be honest can i
have modest goals here
how i just said you haven't actually
more concerned about you know
breaking 3 million 650 000 steps
for the year 2022. oh wow say what yeah
look i'm a nut a nut on this whole thing
so what are you using
yeah i use this
of course application
yeah the application so i have to pad uh
my numbers
walking around the uh tournament hall
it's one of the you know another gm
quirk
excellent well
give me the number again first of all
three uh that's you know ten thousand
days uh steps per day
on average uh three hundred three
million six hundred fifty that's a lot
of stuff like going across the country
twice or something
so
yeah
nice and st louis is a great walking
town actually throughout here
great park and all that
foreign next to us absolutely larry
congratulations we'll see you in the
next few years okay thanks thank you
thank you for joining us
three million six hundred fifty thousand
steps like what i thought i was gonna
say dollar so i was like i was like
that's pretty good yeah
and once again uh with jennifer uh you
are drawing tell ya this is a huge
result we can't
underestimate the fact that jennifer has
already played seats two and three right
and that talia survives playing the top
seed of the tournament with the black
pieces exactly uh big big success
uh early days
and in this game gracie persona did end
up drawing holding a difficult position
against rey yangyan in fact i thought
that gracie was toast but the fact that
she
hung in there i mean it really speaks to
tenacity absolutely nobody's giving away
any points in the in this uh tournament
are you kidding me it's so hard to win a
point nowadays wow you see the carissa
game i mean that was crazy that's just
crazy and there's so many positions in
which one side gets an advantage
but the opponents don't collapse no they
still fight and they hold on and they
try and they try and they try exactly
one guy who's holding on is alex
shabadabadoo
uh he's covered everything he's covered
all of his bases like we say bad bishops
can uh protect weak pawns and vladimir
is
you know testing him let's put it that
way it's kind of one of those positions
that makes chess feel unfair right
white's position is such trash right
he's just going back and forth and
saying you're defending all he does is
defend weaknesses you there's no breaks
there's no breaks and when you try to
pick up this
you you rediscover that your knight can
go to e5 and you put your rook on
anytime you try to win that pawn b6 goes
yeah
drop so where's the break guys no i i
feel this is just a draw i feel it's a
draw too
i mean you i would i'd spin my heels as
well
uh
but
no i just don't see how uh
oh
vladimir is going to break through uh
turning to the game of pedro for a
moment uh
i was
come on i was surprised by the king e4
yeah king force has such an unusual move
in this position i mean if you're not
trying to play king g3
win a pawn and get a passer and you know
the other passer as well
king e4
doesn't that just invite rook h6 and now
this king will happily march towards the
spawn and you
at a certain moment you start to think
gosh if i could get into g5
you know if things could really uh so
let's take it one move at a time please
let's go d4 let's do it d4 it seems to
be the most threatening solution start
with g5 okay fair i mean i
that's okay let's continue okay
d3 is that a good one all right at a
certain moment don't i take this pawn i
think you take the spawn right i don't
want to get myself in trouble all right
king e3
and i suppose i should
i don't know get behind the thing or
check yeah time though rook f2
there's nothing here yeah yeah there's
no no no no this is winning right
queen and rook queen versus rook can't
be winning
oh this is actually how do you make a
draw though d2 yeah and rook f4 maybe
check checking f3 whatever
okay
i think this is winning
i don't think you can avoid me from
going rookie two rookie two is a problem
what okay just a second hold on hold on
so nut check
this is gonna do the same thing rookie
two yeah rookie yeah you're just gonna
play with p2 right
g6
you're not on time check oh sorry
i the the rook doesn't end up on e1 it
ends up on d1 on d1 right apologies
you're right okay
so i cannot well we're going to see it
because he has played d4 he's played d4s
play rook takes h4 not with g5 not g5
okay okay so we expect d3
maybe we're being too hasty with check
we should go look down down yeah
yeah okay this makes a lot more sense
right of course yeah
yeah g5 is kind of silly yes
and that way we can just check the king
and tuck our kids right in front you
want to be in front of them exactly you
don't want to be away from the pawn
exactly exactly rock h2 king one yeah
yeah yeah king one and i think i mean
the moment you play king e1 it's a draw
even without the two pawns on the side
this should be easy
okay very good we'll keep our eye on
that one and again let's just go
to we have one game in every section
yasser that's it
and against ellen wang they're still
playing uh okay we left it ellen had
really slipped up badly
alice had found a wonderful way of
activating her rook
that won her the a3 pawn
and this is what we were saying that
okay
re reset recharge
uh we're gonna try to win two pawns in a
bishop versus a rook
and we're hoping
for the
best that's a funny look man loser
that's a funny puns i know right you're
gonna get a pawn on d3 but it's like uh
space invaders
you want to get the pawn to f4 okay if
we're in
ellen's shoes
what is she trying to do she's trying to
get the pawn to f4
so that she could artificially isolate
this pawn right and when one could take
it right very good maneuver the bishop
back to f6 and the the pawn to f5 all
right
now if i'm white yes and i decide i
don't want to see any of that yes and i
play the move f4
you do get two connected past pawns
are you sure you want to allow me to do
that uh christian
coach do you like the move f4 would you
jump out of your seat if uh one of your
students paid i wouldn't jump out of my
seat but
it doesn't look pretty it's not pretty
but i is it good
is it good so let's go bishop eight
what
let's go what else
the ship fa right right hmf8 or bishop
i'm just trying to transfer my bishop
somewhere else no i'll give a check
check i've got to play f6 i understand
okay otherwise there would there would
just be a backup portfolio yeah and i'll
i'll play rook i don't know b5 i guess
boyfriend let's see if there's an actual
uh where does my bishop belong on the a7
diagonal
that's the thing so i could play check
that's the thing how do you get there
i i was actually thinking it's going to
take me a long while exactly yes and
once you get the g one i got king f1
rook to e5
e5
also kind of freezing a little bit the
structure a little bit but no yeah of
course because that
your f4 move was designed to stop stop
yeah f5 rookie five kind of does the
same thing
rook king g6 not f4 pardon me rook e5
so black looks a bit stuck
my goodness how do i get the bishop to
the a7 diagonal
so i need to get you in to some sort of
a suits fun right so let's get
tom our producer loves zuke zwong you
you tell us how we do it and tom
seven heaven d3
which d3 david three three check victory
okay king
okay we won you tricked us show show
oh sorry you take on f5 never mind
forget about it no tsuzu my spidey sense
was tingling and now
you know they take it away from you you
know the moment they it was that time
okay but let's
at least get to that point that i want
to make so king g7 forget about it don't
take my pawn go rookie eight
okay cool man let me have some fun okay
king f6
okay
and
did i achieve anything that is the
question now at least i have bishop c1
so i get my bishop out right sure i just
don't know what this accomplishes that's
the question does it accomplish anything
or not because i can't even attack h5
like bishop c5
now we're not really going anywhere
that's the now it's time i think at some
point we need to stop making good moves
for white yeah make bad moves and figure
out if white has they need danger yeah
like what what what is black's
i might blast yeah no no
it's just a draw getting ambitious yeah
yeah rookie five by alice this would be
a huge save by the way i think alex
really would have dodged
think she's saving it yeah by the way
you channeled ellen because she played
d3 she could have played it at anything
right there yeah
good job good job that's why he calls
the games that's right
that's right we need them on set
um
pedro's game is winding down
because that king
has made it to in front exactly what we
thought it's going to yeah rook requests
pedro espinosa game versus justin wang
okay and we're expecting it's still the
akopian one
unfortunately i mean they've come to a
standstill in the acopian game i mean
it's been a while right since they've
been actually when does the last pawn
move
the last pawn move or capture was king
take c6 move 42.
so we got 92 uh we're using the 50 move
right now because we've got c4 we've got
as much we've got c4 on the board here
so it's actually if we move 43 yes
that's like three with c4 so we're 18
moves into the 50 move rule okay that's
not that many moves no but i mean the
point is that black's not doing anything
the black hasn't done anything for 18
whole moves right
exactly well i only need to get shibalov
down to his last minute
and then manage to find a break
kristen
i don't see the break either it's got to
be put my knight on f4 rook on h8 and go
h3 he did he had all that he had it he
had it in the back i'm not saying it's a
good break
i'm just saying it's a break
this is how it looks
it's a break it's a break by the way one
of my absolutely favorite stories about
the 50 move rule was larry christensen
he's playing drajan chahovich
and he larry's been slightly worse for
the whole 50 moves right the whole 50
moves
and
uh
it's a dead draw now it's a dead draw
and larry
finds a way
he contorts himself to allow
shahovic to come up the board and
deliver a mate
but
i'm sorry that eight's on 51
not on move 50 ouch yeah that's how the
rules work larry wrote a double move
so that guy mates him on move 50.
it's not move 51. oh
[Laughter]
he never saw a guy storm out of the
playing hall
with more brute force than larry did it
was great
you you know [ __ ] larry
you know the hotel bar had a good night
in terms of business
oh boy
yeah
yeah it was pretty bad it was pretty bad
shocking shocking
um
well again the spinning of the night by
vladimir he's just i mean he you may
have channeled uh him uh there
christian by the knight could come to f4
the rook would go to h8 you'll play h3
i'll take it and you might be worse
because i don't know if you can
recapture on
it's
hmm
it's bad luck man
all right all right another idea though
another excellent all right all four
let's go knight f4 what do you do uh
move my rook
no no
what do you want me to do tell me what
you want me to do
on c3 ac3 d5
we got him
finally
is this even that clear
maybe it's at least a try right it's a
try he's going for it the knight is on
f4 i mean rick's is right it's a silly
move though
okay uh and now we start calculating
right yeah
i'm not gonna calculate something that
will never happen never happened never
happened no
that i think we were a bit too
cooperative with rook c3 we can't help
you
that okay one thing you have to play
already
king f2 okay
so now basically d5 is going to be met
with
context what d5 phone takes i take i
take back i don't think the bishop is
unhappy about this okay uh we've got to
throw in a check i go to f
seven right two aye
[Music]
you'll be seizing the defensive before
too long like can you imagine 97 rookies
here it comes here it comes
masterful man yeah that's not looking
good starting to look like you're on the
back foot there
oh well i i don't see it no what can i
what can i say i don't see it that's why
we think it's a draw
yeah we just don't see any breaks that
are every break that we find is helpful
for white exactly exactly so i guess
let's try to improve the position even
more let's get the king off the e5 do
you want the k that's the whole question
vladimir has been asking himself for
some time so why do you like your king
on c7
was he there i think he was actually
seven early
he was on c7 yeah exactly
so
but it was also the king was on g7 or g6
earlier too
so he's trying to be square he's trying
to find the proper home and
unsuccessfully uh
alejandro
yeah yeah yeah good defense by shabba i
have to say yeah yeah back foot for the
whole game yeah since the opening he had
this bad structure with a double c pawns
and he defended valiantly up to this
point so we have three games remaining
and it does seem that all three are
heavily favorited to go into a draw
right pedro is holding against justine
wang we see this end game we analyzed it
already rook on d8 is a good one exactly
still looks like a draw here wait wait
wait wait wait is this
as easy as we thought it is rook d8 has
to be a draw yes
i mean if you compare and contrast this
to the other i mean i know it's a draw
because
the table base is saying
[Laughter]
nothing because
than god master knowledge the table base
the romanian school of chances
guys known for its end games
skill what is it called finally finally
what
the romanian end game
what
this looks like a drawer guys okay we
move to the yes we can
uh we are moving to the alice lee game
dc3 also
let me let me refresh oh she looks the
introduction
she got the she got all the way to c3
didn't allow the k the rook to write
shade and we still think she's stuck
right right
nothing to do with that no breaks
problems
um as long as the rook stays on the e8
square
keeping an eye on the e4 pawn the move
you could never get in the move f
f5 f4 and and i i i hate to say it but
even if you get a four i know then i
don't really
get to f5 and then i get to go bishop f6
and i and we hope and we have a little
brother i hope we actually take that
part and there's no other stuff right
maybe um
spinning in circles on this one
well
that's it that's all we have that's all
we have
63rd move in the copion versus chevrolet
game still nothing has changed rook to
c6 on the board you guys were laughing
but i think this is with 25.
[Laughter]
we got 25 more we're like
20.
is it all 20 move 20 yes they only
played two moves
oh wow
they were either way 61. i was 63. if
there's ever a moment to encourage uh
social media and any questions now is
the time because we do have the time as
we wait for these players and we do in
fact have we have a lot of questions
that we kind of keep
and sabina doesn't like to share
from patrick
shout out to patrick he enjoys uh
tossing his stuff it's playing spicy
chess good for your tournament winning
chances
yes yes it is it kind of averages out
i would say playing
very
gambler's chest playing this gambit
playing this uh very sharp positions
what tends to happen i've noticed is
that at tournaments you either
bomb completely right or you win the
event and in chess it's actually kind of
a funny sport because
you'd rather
bomb a bunch of tournaments and win a
bunch of tournaments then
score four three score fourth and fifth
and every third never win an event right
like for example a player like shabalov
he's a mini tournament
he won right but at the same time i've
seen him in like continental chess
association tournaments where like he's
on board 100 yeah
but that also takes a very special type
of personality that's true because
you cannot deal with those bombing
tournaments as easily as you make it
sound you know but if you are once
bothering like oh okay i messed this
tournament up on to the next one or
you're a guy like richie rapport okay i
messed this cannon this up on the next
one hopefully right um it takes that
type of personality that is more
inclined to be gambling if you're more
of a conservative player then try to
play more conservative chess that's the
beauty of chess you can adapt it based
on your personality and the way you view
life as well as the way you are and
all of those notions well this was the
thing that
again ben larson and i come back to him
so very often because he was very
inspiring he said yes sir
give up your fears about becoming a
grandmaster that's over what you should
be focusing on is winning tournaments
that's what it's all about yes sirs
winning tournaments
and boy that made a very very powerful
impact and ben larson
yeah he had his bombs he sure did but
boy he sure won a lot of tournaments as
well look at his record in the late 60s
uh all the top soviets would play in
in the tournaments with bent
and uh he won
i believe four major tournaments in a
row
so that when 1970 the match of the
century well no it wasn't called the
match of the century it was ussr versus
the rest of the world right
bobby fisher
not yasser not alejandro bobby fisher
said ben larson plays board one for the
rest of the world
well and
when bobby says i'm putting you on board
one
he earned that that's respect that's
respect so yeah winning tournaments i
i've got that and we have now
before we go into another question uh it
does seem like pedro is down to his last
minute so maybe look
g2 is coming and at some point you might
have to give up the g pawn
and then it turns into like a
theoretical draw maybe if you know it
right so let's wait a second let's not
give it
to pedro we're giving it as a draw just
yet no not yet
i think you check from the long side
right i think king c1 down to his last
30 seconds
is
and what we mean with this is that you
want your rook to be harassing your
opponent's king
via either h8h2 or a82 and you'd rather
do it on the longer side for the rook
the further away from the pawn
so you'd actually rather hide the king
somewhere else now perhaps what he's
also trying to do if you go
rook to g2 which was not played rook to
e2 okay i like this move so justin is
trying to wrong foot white if you go
king d1 then he wants to go rook g2
and with the double threat of which is
probably still a draw which is still a
draw of course yeah actually you plucked
yeah you plucked the pawn off still it
dropped right so what
uh alejandro was talking about there is
when you think about the board for just
a moment
if the white king were on the b2 square
the long side
the pawn would be a rook check on h3
and when he went
from d1
to the e1 square he went to
the
he's it's now the short side side for
the rook because
exactly but by the way king f1
hey
let's go
yeah that's the beauty of white's
position is you still have a pawn so
let's go you can actually use this as
counter play exactly the idea is for
example it's not the only move but let
me just put a move on the board for just
a moment
uh rookie five and i'm going to put my
pawn on g7 yes you're going to get your
rook behind the pawn there's no question
about that
but then it's going to be very hard for
your king your black king to hide as
well
so i think that that would be the
easiest well let's keep going actually
okay king d2
king d2 yes give me the
d3
oh yes i'll give you a check yeah yeah
that's that's a good move okay
i was thinking that you could win a
tempo right no no i don't want to go g5
okay i want to attack that pawn from the
side so d3 okay g7 or kf7 ah rook f7 i
want to put the rook on c7 and then get
the king to c2 yeah that's winning
whoa whoa
so is it
am i too slow no roxy seven no no roxy
seven of c7 oh rook c7 i mean yes you're
going to seven immediately yeah you
don't want to allow these checks
well never mind that i was trying to get
my king to uh protect the pawn oh right
and i think you're just one tempo short
one time for sure yeah
absolutely if you have the king on g6
you go rogue v8 draw yes
good point i didn't see that you could
you could attack the the pawn
from the side i thought you were going
to bring the rook behind
nice so king f1 on the board still some
tricks that pedro has to
not fall into i'd be the only trick in
the position it might be the only trick
in the position so what if you can i do
it in a different way no but what if you
just go g6 exactly against rook e5 can i
just go g6
i think this must be the easier way kind
of
for well no
i mean king one king you won
that's okay and now rook to g or rg8
yeah
i agree i think it's it's a it's a draw
um time for pedro again is he playing on
him 59 seconds for he's pretty much
playing on increment at this point
and but but justin only has three
minutes to start like black has all the
time in the world to put pressure no and
he made a move but i mean it was rookie
rookie five yes so we're expecting g6 g6
is the simplest i'm looking at alice
lee's game for just a moment she put her
king on
f1
guys what
oh my goodness ellen
had a win
what
on the board if she would have found
instead of bishop to d4 f4
f
f4 followed by king to f5 and that was
really tell me tell me well not right
now obviously it would be f3 baby
no what do you do first of all no well
you take on e4 not on f4 got it right i
got it got it got it yes uh after rook
takes e4 i just simply have f3 yeah f3
you just shut the king out d2 is too
strong
you still have
e3 but then i just go d2 and then i
bring the king your king is completely
shut off
okay so how do you oh you go bishop d4
at some point can you have five king e4
threatening well first let's play f5
because i don't want to allow you any g4
ideas no no no no
no no no no no no you're convinced
we're thinking the king will come to e4
the bishop will come to d4 and that will
be all she wrote she missed it she
missed it
yeah she missed it she played bishop d4
but look i mean ellen is still thinking
about her win with f4
now how is alice going to stop her she
played rook e7
well you can't play f4 well after bishop
c3 you can just
continue attacking the bishop right rook
cesar f4 c7 right
so will she see it maybe second time
around bishop c3
rook e8
f4
and what did she do well the problem is
i don't think alan is saying it
no
i don't think she's even looking at that
yeah
it's kind of a weird timing right
because it's the one moment you take
the e4 pawn for free right right this is
like the one time you don't want to do
it but then when you see f3 very visual
yeah
then you realize the king is cut that
would have been very very nice and it
does seem like pedro found the correct
way okay
he did not play the move rook to g8 he
played the move g6 first
and uh
forcing the rook to go behind the pawn
and now rook to g8 exactly
now rook very well played by young pedro
and right now this just seems to be easy
and he's done this rock g8
and rookie 8 i think is on the board
exactly yeah rick jacobs on the board
do you have any
move 50 uh stories because we do have a
pawn break in the shabalov's game yeah
we won't need them because we have a
huge move actually changing the
character of the position completely
five five finally timed something dirac
i'm not sure it's actually improving his
position very much though
but you have to do something like yeah
well if you're trying to win you're
trying to win but you know you can end
up losing something could go wrong right
you could also lose this one yes easily
now this mission becomes a little active
like okay so let's just see the action
of my body i actually know what i'm
thinking with i don't know take take
with the a pawn okay and let's say i go
b6 check he's taken with the a pawn as
well yeah yeah so you go b6 i take that
and i take c6
good morning st louis
i mean seriously i really i honestly
thought i was gonna go be uh grabbing
this part but we are going down this
variation and if we are going down this
line why why don't we take the a pawn
we're not taking the c pawn
by the way how do why did we get here
yeah exactly i mean
could have easily just moved his rooks
off the c file so that there would be no
b file or d
or you keep both on the c file if you
keep both in the c file you never have
this trick
okay i was going to say you don't have
the trick if i keep everything on the b
file either how are you going to play
but he found the one way where you do
have the chicken
one rook on the scene maybe he was
tricking his opponent to go playing for
and here we have it
what will shabbat do now but this is
what i said is his only chance get
chabalov down to his last couple of
minutes right now he only has two
minutes left on the clock
and try to find the break
that's your only chance so he found the
break
he did that good for vladimir very good
for vladimir and now and now
why not because of what we just saw
what christian showed us was pretty
compelling i didn't like giving the
i don't like giving up the b-pump for
the deep one
as a concept i'll tell you a funny story
playing b7 is even better
yeah
king b7 was winning
which board what kind of b7
not take the pawn on b6
boss chair boss chair
king takes
and this one is starting to become
difficult after rook to c6 exactly
because you've got yeah you've got
yourself spawn now not easy no the game
flares completely on you guys it
certainly does
hello hello
that this would be a huge bounce back
victory for a copy and if he manages to
convert this
yeah i was actually thinking you know
what what a
what a
shock
this could be for um
shabalak because he kind of like
put this game to rest
mentally uh for quite some time ago rook
to d2 he's playing as if he's got it all
under control
is
uh
uh
shabbat are we underestimating
procrastinating
no
i don't think so either i think it's
it's definitely a two result because
it's dangerous actually this is nice
definitely a two well how does the
engine feel like we feel that black is
definitely for sure for choice
i would maybe give it a one and a half
for black what does the engine not as
much no no zero point six zero point
seven zero point i got that wrong
completely i thought that this would
have
a moment ago minus three
team b7 instead of b6
not after you maneuver for the last 25
yeah to get the pawn uh going i guess
you just simply don't have time to take
on d6 because a4 just exactly
the pawn is really streaking yeah
and then uh
i get it all the way to the third rank
at least right right
yeah now on the second rank because i
give you a check
yeah yeah yeah this must be lost wow
and it's not like the b6 bond is running
away either no it's just a i can pick it
up whenever i want which is what the
main point of this is i think and then
once you lose the g2 pawn the age pawn
is running down the board agreed
uh missed opportunity there for sure but
still vladimir but still lots to play
right now
how do you make progress that's black
though this is the question because if
you do go a4 i give you a check
and that forces your king to go
backwards
because i don't think you won that c5 ah
do you go check and rook before
i guess exactly or okay yeah exactly
just you you tickle the pawn
so a4 might be premature
exactly
let's lead with the king let's go king
c5
no well i don't want to see the king
says i don't want to lead with the kings
he went on c7 king to c7 yes fascinating
move king c7
not the first one
not the third right right okay uh
strange but okay it's not like you're
doing
he's not really in a hurry right i mean
rooftop c5 is coming next if i play rook
a2 you'll play rogue c rook c5 yeah and
then i'll come with the king
i mean i don't think hiding on f2 bit
so let's keep going
f2 does protect the bishop king b6 okay
king where sorry b6 boy boy six gotcha
king david four
ideas of bishop c4 i don't know if
they're good ideas but so now i have to
find a better square for my knight it
feels
yep by the way can i go
96 i give you a check you go back
not easy not easy right right
so let's say i go rook c1 now
uh-huh look c1 let me get in feels like
yeah slowly slowly you're getting some
progress i'll give you that definitely
christian i definitely will feel like
you're you're doing bishop to b5
skittishly played
courageous rook c5 i thought i want to
play that anyway
yeah somehow well maybe i'll put my
bishop here and i'll just keep my king
on f2
this is what he wants but then the g2
pawn doesn't have um a defender anymore
well he's got one
maybe you might get it
maybe two
is that [ __ ]
kind of like this
because rook d7 checked no no i don't
think i can ever
make the trade of the f6 pawn for the g2
pawn so perhaps rook c5 helps you not
for white let's go rook c3
rook c3
and this one has finally been drawn they
went around forever but alice lee saves
a huge half point she sure does she
really does
ellen wang had this game
and this one is also going to be a draw
as we expect the movie that rook takes
the tour king takes g7 doesn't really
matter exactly
okay and pedro was like
should i offer a draw or should i take
your rook take the roof
i'm not sure what that takes the queen
yes and that's a draw a
draw between pedro espinoza and justin
wagoff long fight there for pedro two
days in a row no easy games for him
seriously i mean again he's coming in as
the lowest rated seed and so these
players are saying okay
i'm gonna play to the last drop and
talking about that we do have one game
remaining now the seniors bring it on
the right the fight
the fire the fight the spirit never
flares never extinguished never dies
yeah bishop to e8 and now that's what
he's done
let's see let's attack that bishop
rook d8
58 i assume you go bishop
i don't know let me say let me uh
refresh my board for just second
so king b6 bishop e8 rook david eight
why not why is i wrote
rook to d8 makes sense i probably want
to maintain it on the diagonal bishop a4
brook d4 and now you get to play a4
after bishop maybe if you allow me to if
i get the king to a5 i have a feeling
you're in deep trouble
good point
a4 right so let's go a4 yeah
not at this particular moment uh the
position we see on the board rook to d8
we think
might be the most testing
which suggests to me that after rook d8
i should know if i play rook b2 check
i've got to be careful about knight d3
later on later on king a7 it might lose
immediately yeah correct exactly k7 or
king c5 both of them right
just
i'm just saying that if i was thinking i
was going to secure the bishop on eight
whoops
and bishop b5 loses to rook b8 so
actually just busted exactly the spot
and as you say walking into this pin
very nasty losing on the spot
so there are
problems after rook d8 big problems i
think
vladimir enjoying the moment absolutely
what's the time situation two minutes 24
for both yeah so they both have about
two minutes 32 minutes 50. two minutes
uh 50 for chabal of two minutes and 15
seconds for
a copy i must say uh 48 you know the
board i am
really
a big fan of shabbat when i see him
attacking i think he's a i mean really
one of the great attacking geniuses from
the latvian school of chess yes but when
he's on the defense
yeah that's not his trunk suit it is not
his strong suit and the way he defended
this by leaving the rooks and allowing
the b5 break so he cracked under
pressure something that we see even
grandmasters it happens very often when
the other ground master puts an immense
amount of pressure and at some point
your resistance what we call cracks you
make an inaccurate move exactly and
starting the floodgates spill in and
this is exactly what happened in this
game where
um
now he realizes the same thing i did oh
no that the knight comes to d3 with a
check he just realized that rook to b2
is
busto time right that's slightly shake
that okay rook to be to king to a7
bishop to b5 only move
after king a7 yeah yeah but we thought
he was right here rook to b8 and now
rook to b3
uh-huh
ah you're still surviving somehow
but i don't know for how long
rook v8
b3 this is definitely not the piece
configuration you had in mind when you
went into this
how about rook b6 in that
just to lose the tempo yeah i like it
yeah yeah
just to ask you exactly what you might
be doing i cannot go uh rook b1 because
you have a4 correct that's the problem
that is what it's all about right this
looks busted looks busted wow does it
have to go king g1 but
no that actually allows knight to no
this is over guys yeah thingy a7 played
i think a7 just finishes the game first
right yep otherwise it was a piece
and he's done oh
on the board right
okay bishop p5 or resign otherwise
you're just down too much material
did you like um shabba we just saw him
play the move rook b2
uh oh uh oh uh oh did you have a kind of
a touch move error
in your career i mean we saw it like
hikaru nakamura had that famous moment
against uh aronia lavon yes
for me it was like an almost i played
the move rook hp8 and on the last moment
i saw i lost a piece but luckily rook
hc8 was a very good movie
okay and you uh christian did you have
one of those touch move moments where
it's like plenty of them
plenty of them and then you realize uh
that you're lost and sometimes you get
lucky and you're not actually lost
because you have some sort of resource
later on but there's still that moment
of uh cold shower right when you're like
oh my goodness what happened
uh here
shabbat has offered knight takes g2
checked
and i have to say that
i'm tempting
because you get a protected passport h4
yes
after
[Music]
i understand there might be a better
move he took it yeah but i don't think i
can resist i cannot resist that
temptation exactly exactly that is
scrumptious yeah but this looks like
game over exactly you have to take this
there's no way that you can keep that
pin no
it's time an issue because i just saw
also two minutes for both they're
playing on the increment no well not
really but it's just a lost position
it's just the last word
and what a resilient defense up to that
point
and after that he just collapsed now
collapsed you were saying that he
cracked he did crack psychologically
because
the position was still fine but he was
playing so fast
like he just knew how to make a draw not
that easy no stop and think don't play
b6 because up to that point if you don't
play b6 you're still
within
margins of equality
after b6 it's all over
what should he have played instead of b6
i've got the moment i think it was move
70 in fact after rook takes c1 not easy
not an easy move at that point rook to
a2 was the only move okay to maintain
the balance i can b6 rook d2
i'm just going to attack the pawn
actually
the a pawn then i'm going to attack the
d-pawn and now we're going to switch
back
yeah rook a2 yeah i think he got seduced
by this move b6 and now uh he knows the
unfortunate realization is settling in
yeah that
there's just no
no dealing with these two connected past
the two two passes
it goes f4 it's really the only way but
it's just it's another pawn right right
it well wait a minute yeah jack king
somewhere d4 how nice because you can't
go king back i trade drugs trade rex's
sense oh wait a minute you have to try
something though i'm not worried about
the pawn breakthrough
uh no i should be faster right
there you know what i mean you know what
it's hour six i've been there
i do not want to calculate the pawn race
christian take it away
there's always the dilemma in this type
of rook and games
especially in this one because you know
you're lost
what type of defense are you going to
employ passive or not passive or active
you always go active you have to go
active right at this point right because
you know you're busted right
when you're on the edge you don't know
exactly how to assess the position maybe
you have that chance of taking the
passive route but at this time you have
to go for it
i like f4 i think it's his only chance
rook g3 no he did not play rook chief
here i kind of i was angling for rook g3
there a moment ago that's not a bad move
all but uh taking's not bad i mean h3 f3
creating another pass bomb can be bad
yeah exactly
e5 so this is the point of shaba he's
going to try to create a passport but
unless my counting is off rook g3
actually picks up g4 right that will be
no no so you take on e5 no no rook g3
spoils it why rookie two
i did not see that move
rook rg3 spoils it actually there's only
that's why i'm moving
exactly
that is why we have christian kirilla so
there's only one move there's only one
move that one here only
i take with the pawn g5 f3 i think i'm
going to f3 and i'm so fast f3 e4 i'm
too fast and then my rook is ready to go
to g5
that's not trivial not trivial at all
but he has two minutes left to find it
yeah uh you can give me 30 minutes
[Laughter]
nice
f3
probably wins as well
but is not as clear after rook 282
gotta get this guy a better engine
i mean it probably won't say what is it
or it doesn't right it's such a
simplified end game
before
he found it in the fifth and sixth hour
he's not going to it's just too good
old-school armenian chefs yeah i'm
telling you these guys they know their
enemies and they do know their end games
right
yeah beautiful move secures the victory
easy now this is easy
why is it not easy okay f3 is easy
f3's f3 rook f2 f takes e5 please tell
me that's winning because the g phone is
hanging
yeah of course yeah okay
yeah
of course
of course i mean f takes e5 is winning
followed by f3 ftx e5 g5 is scary
really no no i don't think that and you
still haven't still uh bring home that g
pawn is not very advanced
i have too many pawns of my own okay
agreed too many pounds
that is a lot of possibilities it's true
it's four against one
that's true but f3 looks very tempting
f3 looks like
play me play me
no nope 35 commentators curse exactly
king e6 on the board
that makes any sense
takes on e5 g5 f3
rook moves e4
g6
rook
g5 let's just let's just do some of this
let me make some moves here so we're
going takes on e5 yeah
what's the best square for the rook you
can't go up
because that's f2 but it's all bad
so if you go here e4 e4 g6
rook
behind and then you can even throw in
rick g2 yeah nice and then h3 h now we
do have g5 on the there oh it's actually
not that fast on g5 no
f3 on the board
yeah no this is you know this looks over
there's nothing to to do he might resign
actually
i always i hear that always uh you know
they they bring the great grandmaster
out how was it i wanted to resign they
never reason
and he saves the game miraculously
brilliantly if my opponent had played f3
i wanted to resign
it's like you feel that you want to
resign until your opponent makes a move
and then you back it and then you're
like
come on i'm not resigning against that
move come on
i'm back in it f3 rook f2 g6 already e4
board g6
we're expecting the rook to come
in place behind the bottom g5 yeah all
right so rogue g5 king let's say king of
six or king yeah
g7 that's my only last chance last
chance i forgot that move existed me too
so now
i have to take on g7 well probably i
don't have to
but but i think i'm in time yeah h3 was
yeah h3 is just winning because you play
h2 and e3 it's just
known position exactly yeah that's it
you you saved me from playing queen
versus because i've got an extra fun on
a5
which is a good thing by the way yeah we
had a queen versus rook end game today
actually in the bundesliga uh hans
nieman with the white pieces lost to
fabiano caruana no great game by the way
wow really exciting stuff you were
mentioning at the top of the show how
great the bundesliga was because it was
like fabi and richie were on the yeah
no they're actually the same team oh
they're on the same same team which
makes the team pretty it's pretty strong
two candidates and three world champions
what do you
got that's the beauty of bottom bottom
right right
oh by the way he didn't play rook g2 no
you can play h2o
yeah nice nice
style style points
too many pawns next to promotions
once you have two pawns on the third
rank against the rook you always win
yeah you always promote automatically
actually that was something that i had
learned as a starting player beginning
players of my teacher jeffrey parsons
who literally helped me learn the rules
because i i struggled with ambassador i
really did oh my god struggle with
castle i struggled everywhere
and he said
two pawns
on the sixth rank
are worth a rook
i went no way
[Laughter]
showing no understanding whatsoever
worth a little bit more than a rook here
but it's true
h2
uh rook takes h2 and one of these pawns
is gonna queen there's no ifs ands or
buts about it
um
you can't stop it
you put it that way yeah yeah that's it
that's it yep that's how it goes
there's probably a lot of choices on how
to fleece this one right mm-hmm
just have to wait for his because i see
already like five different moves that
went right if he plays king a6 by the
way we're gonna go
bring out the sticks the k6 is just
winning right right of course it is
i mean here you know he brings his king
king d6 closer to the rook or something
like
what are you doing here dude
my goodness
okay what is he worried about
i think he's just trying to understand
he's just dotting his eyes crossing his
teeth making sure everything is in
perfect order
you don't want to spoil the six hour
game
true
true so
after h2 rook h2 e3 you still have rook
h5 i mean i'm not even looking in that
direction i i actually found e3 rook f3
e2 just promotes a pawn and then i
stopped
you it does promote the pause
e3 rook f3
e2 just promotes a pawn e2 you can only
he's done it yeah you can only stop one
of these points
e3 and then h2 and that's it right very
important not to go um h2 because then i
go to f1 and it's still losing after
rook g1 but that's not the point yeah he
wants to go eat it
and he's done it
nice finishing touch by the way vladimir
yep
like you say
closing the game of style
all right well what a grudge match this
was wow
this is a huge fight this is hugely
metal oh man
my goodness yeah these are coming back
from the from a loss
right right and a brutal one at that
because he had such a good opening
position in the game against novikov
that gave me lost but bouncing back with
the black pieces too yeah with the black
pieces
i mean it's huge it's a huge confidence
boost absolutely and shabbat resigns
what a game marathon game we've had
amazing two days of chess we've had
openings we've had end games we've had
sacrifices we had blunders we've had
comebacks we've had everything some of
the greatest uh preparation i've seen in
a long while i mean that includes the
candidates that we just finished exactly
andrew wow there's right there
there's that guy in the playing hall
kick him out exactly why do they like
sing field into this incredible i mean
come on oh the riff raff
what's going on
it's hard to promote a knight
okay uh christian close it up for us as
we got something maybe we should look at
the results first
and the results
i like me like all right and the girls
sophie moore suzuki is the early leader
the only player to achieve two points
out of two a perfect score uh after
destroying rochelle wu in the second
position we have talia cervantes and as
ellen wang who
really let go of a golden opportunity
today against alice lee and jennifer you
and alice lee with two draws 50 and then
the juniors in the juniors we also have
one player only with two points and that
is andrew hong he
what impressive victory
wow absolutely incredible christopher
you and justin wang are the only players
trailing him by half a point and we have
three on fifty percent i wonder there
half a point only i wonder liang our
2700 languishing in a tie for 7th
through 10th and in the seniors in the
seniors we have a closer group as
nobody's achieved two points perfect
start instead only larry christiansen
and igor navikov have one and a half
points as remember that even though
vladimir kopian did win his game today
he had lost yesterday so he's still only
on 50 absolutely
and now christian your final thoughts of
these two days of the national
championships well i have to say uh two
incredible days of chess and so many
stories developing we see sophie maurice
suzuki just surging through the rankings
two big victories in uh the first two
games and dominant victories those were
just like andrew hung very very dominant
and i have to say i'm liking what i'm
seeing from akopion he did not give up
after that a big loss in the first round
with the white pieces came back bounced
back with the black pieces against
chabalov and my pick right now he's back
in the game so i'm definitely looking
forward to see what's going to happen
and i forgot the next few rounds and
let's take a look at the picks actually
all right
in the ladies i had jennifer i'm kind of
feeling okay but boy jennifer had two
winning positions
and alice survived today
seventh game
and dennis
very nice i like it yeah leaders i'm
doing all right second place behind
andrew hong slow start for me but i
think he's very slow
i wonder come on uh thrill is with uh
wonderment and in the seniors
good day for me
good good finish for me i have the
status
how did how did we let this guy sneak in
the door
what is going on
very nice thank you everybody for
joining us for these two days of chess
we'll be back tomorrow with round three
of all of these championships so don't
miss a beat we'll be here back at 1pm
central actually the show starts at 12
50. exactly see you then good night
everyone
[Music]
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited
you